know that while you support your like five little ugly cleft
flipped disgusting children on your minimum wage slave job working
at uh Dollar Tree uh for a living all day and night with a wife
that's like getting in the ass to the next room. I want you to
know that I don't have to work at all because I was born rich
and handsome. You're a goofy looking guy. You're you're literally
Okay, I hate to tell you this. It's your genetic destiny. You're
okay. You're a funny goofy guy. You're not the dark, mysterious
guy. You're a funny, goofy guy. So, be funny and goofy and be
like have a good time. Don't take yourself so
>> He has to come in and save you because you're so incompetent.
>> I guess so, man. I guess so. You're running. Now you
are running. Now you are running. Now you are running. Now you
are running. >> Useless incompetent [__] argue.
Like you can't argue for >> You just remember the exact
quotes. Give me the quotes I remembered. Give me the quotes I
remembered. If I had Aiden's
I would I might cry about that and let that ruin my evening.
This guy's such an annoying neo baby que.
[music]
What's the Aiden thing? A bunch of commentary YouTubers met up
in England in London to have like a New Year's thing and Aiden
was kind of an [__] to somebody there and so a whole
bunch of people have been litigating just how big an apple Aiden
is.
Just how big an is Aiden really? Queen and Aiden, Dickers, Soul,
Skiibbidity, and Hellbent were the people who met up. Aiden,
while while Aiden was upset with how somebody was acting in this
social situation, he was going to like his chat, his he's got
like a like a kind of restricted chat that's not just his that's
not just his general chat called Icy Chat. It's like a play on
spicy chat, okay? And in his discord, they've got this chat and
he was like complaining about Hellbent, one of the people who
were there. Okay. And so then later that night they have a VC
and they argue about it. But this is all before anybody went
live and started telling the stories or maybe it's slightly after
Dickers was live. So Aiden had a talk in some ICV complaining
about Hellbent being hellbent IRL. I do believe is that the one
that Quimman jumped on cuz Quan was on some private call some
VC call in um Aiden's Discord that I've heard okay directly from
Quean that Aiden was super a mad because Quen like kind of dumpstered
him in the
Apparently, apparently, apparently. Okay, now
we go jump to here. The first thing we're going to pull up is
this Perry stream. Okay, so they had some party. There's some
party. >> Aiden was getting mad in group chats and then
there was a dinner with Quean and Hellbent and and um Aiden where
they got upset and angry and then people fighting in a Discord
and some VC in a Discord. >> Yes. So 30 minutes later,
Aiden calls into Perry, wants to defend himself. Also, Aiden
>> Aiden felt the need to multiple times like go live and
talk about how
he's not that bad a guy, how he's like actually he's the one
who's acting correctly. All right. Basically, everybody around
him in this social situation, this is the reality, okay? Regardless
of what happened, everybody around Aiden in the social situation
was going, "Hey, you're kind of this is like too much." And then
afterwards, they're like, "This is too much." And Aiden's like,
"No, this is the exact right amount." And I'm sorry, you just
never win that. If the whole point of being social is that you
fit in with like a group of people, right? If every single person
in the group thinks you're being weird, then you're being weird.
That's just how it is,
right? If literally everybody has the same criticism, they all
basically agree on the same core criticism. You are just being
weird. Now, maybe that's based on them hating you and to totally
making something up that they never apply to themselves. Possibly
that he could argue that. But what he can argue is I was totally
normal. Nope. You can't do that. Showing the lack of ability
to read the room is in and of itself not normal. >> Yeah.
I'm covering the Aiden versus Hellbent beef. What are your thoughts
on >> I I think that honestly it's a very pressing issue.
Um and
the public needs
>> Is it not true that you spent like three or five hours
last night complaining about hellbent?
>> Yes. Yes. I was sitting
>> I was sitting there in a dark room going along. I didn't
even I forgot I almost forgot for a minute that there were other
human beings at the end. I was just monologuing
and >> Okay. Also, Hellbent is like um we we've had Hell
we've covered some Hellbent stuff on stream before. We've definitely
covered her comedy before. Okay. She does like art. She's generally
in these communities. Most people know know who she is. Who is
the most normal out of them? Normal in what way?
Normal isn't like could probably adapt to many. It's almost certainly
got to be dickers. Like basically, but that's like
unironically might be Que. It's not. No, Quean is going to I
listened to some of Quean's stream. He was saying like uh people
thought I was going to be the least social, but I might have
been the He's not He's not like the most normal, the most social.
He's none of those things. Okay.
Uh you might be able to argue that it's the Soul Ski guy, though.
That guy just seemed like a lad, right? Just a random lad. No,
all Hold on. Klein Hila, all of these people would collab with
me. That's not the same thing. But he might be the most normal.
I don't know. Vickers is like socially capable though. Queen's
socially capable and and like flouts social norms. I guess Aiden
seems
after this, I feel like Aiden seems like he's kind of incapable
of reading >> And the impassion monologue
went on for about 5 hours. >> Well, we'll see. Um,
>> you are
>> it's um you're you seem like you're like giggling about
this. You feel like imagine if was saying what you're saying
now. Aiden, how would that make you
>> Schroingers is like when I'm trying to say that I didn't
do a thing, but I but I did do the I'm not even saying I didn't
do the thing. I'm saying I did do the thing >> is let's
see >> depends on the context. If there was like argument.
>> All right. So whenever somebody whenever whenever Okay.
So like whenever somebody makes like a joke that's not shreddinger's
you would be doing that if like you're using jokes
um if you're using jokes to like obscure like what what is like
an actual argument. So my question to you would be to demonstrate
that I'm doing that. You would have to demonstrate there was
an actual argument I'm attempting to >> you haven't demonstrated.
You have a demonstr. [laughter] >> Well, it's not the arguments
you're obscuring. It's your feelings you're obscuring. It seems
like people are saying that you felt strongly about Telbins being
bad.
>> All right, fair enough. It was your Schrodinger's um
let's call it um Havlo's.
Okay, point being you're here
>> You're here being giddy. You know for a fact that last
night you were generally upset at Helbent and you think that
she went too far.
>> No. No.
>> No. So you think that's everything Helen's done is awesome.
>> Wait, wait, wait. What do I think she went too far on?
>> She in forcefully inserted herself into
the group dynamic. >> That was that was not what Okay.
>> You said a lot of stuff. >> Ask like can I just
like ask like where you're sourcing this from? >> Um well,
you said it. You said um yeah, I just want to hang out with the
lads and uh Hellbent was a nuisance. >> I found her to
be like annoying. Semi annoying. Like what? What? But then uh
you didn't confront her at the time, did you? You didn't confront
her at the time, did you? >> No, I I did. I I actually
>> This will be another big thing is um Aiden basically
controlled the whole trip and he kind of has problems with Hellbent
in general. All right.
But instead of just making those problems obvious, hey, I don't
actually like her. I don't want her to be here. If Aiden had
just been direct and said, I don't want her here at all. But
instead of being direct, he like kind of didn't say anything
when she invited herself and then she set up everything and then
he basically like let her set up everything. She went and then
he just complained about her the whole time is the impression
I'm getting. >> Told her I find her annoying for
>> probably about a year. Uh and I I've done it in person
as well. >> But then you still met up with her. >> If
you found her annoying for a year, why did you meet up with her?
>> So wait, can I just ask where you're deriving that my
like failure to confront her in person from? cuz I did several
times. >> Well, how'd you react then when you when you
called her annoying in person? >> I mean, I'm sure he called
her That's not a great line of questioning. I'm sure he called
her annoying in person. >> Oh, I don't even remember. I
think just made like an unfunny joke. I don't >> So, you're
telling me So, I'm trying to just like piece up together how
we've gone into this state where Help is um
sitting here making this statement about how you've done something
wrong and you refuse to admit you did anything wrong. That's
what I'm trying to figure out here, Aiden. >> Well, I don't
know what I did wrong. I I was just like annoyed. >> Do
you really? You don't know. You have no idea what you could have
possibly done wrong. And so when when Helpin says, you know,
I've done anything wrong and you know or realize you're being
unreasonable and not a good person should feel bad. You disagree?
>> I I guess.
>> So you don't think you should feel bad for anything?
>> Nope. Nope.
>> But don't you think you're acting quite, you know, antisocial?
>> And that's a that's a bad thing. >> I don't necessarily
think it's that's always a bad thing. depends on the like antisocial
can describe such a broad category of uh behaviors that can on
their own vary so significantly by context that to determine
if it's a bad or good thing. You need to actually describe the
specifics. >> Dude, dude, actually, just because everyone's
calling me a weirdo doesn't doesn't really make it weird. And
you're not really describing what was weird. So, I think you're
kind of just, you know, you're just making things up. Did you
describe what I did that was weird? >> you are acting antisocial
in a way which is delletterious towards the other members of
the group that you were engaging in social activity with.
>> Sure. What >> just wait Perry just nailed it going
back the other way. He nailed he literally defined it in a fairly
in a fairly like rigorous way like an academic way. Yes, exactly.
Everybody else going you weird.
>> That means you're being a weird I do >> I thought
didn't you admit that you were doing this?
>> Doing what? I I don't know what I'm being accused of
doing. >> Doing antisocial behavior which was deletterious
to the other members of >> what what [laughter]
>> What behavior? Well, I suppose it would be causing like
a costic
um you know pass aggressive um awkward dynamic between you and
>> figure out what I'm being accused.
>> Now I in Aiden's defense here, Aiden is saying what
did I say to Hellbent or what did I do to Hellbent that made
it seem this way, right? And Perry is continuing to say, "Well,
you were acting weird." So, I do I get where Aiden might get
frustrated here. You know, it's not really a debate. It shouldn't
be a debate. This shouldn't be your first thing. Okay.
But if it is a debate and Perry's going to engage,
>> it seems like it seems like whenever your helmet's around,
you're just like in a bad mood and grumpy and like you've been
in your hotel refusing to goss with >> I don't even think
that was the accusa. Wait, the accusation wasn't that I I changed
my attitude specifically when Halpent was around. I don't think
anyone's made that accusation.
>> So, what's the accusation?
>> I don't know. That's what I'm trying to >> You
don't know. >> That's That's That is literally unironically
what I'm trying to That's why I'm like joking cuz I don't.
>> So, timeline wise, I believe this is after the dinner
with Hellbent. Hellbent, Aiden, and Quebe went out for dinner.
Just the three of them. Okay.
I think this is after that. So, from what I understood,
Hellband seemed to be saying that Quimman was like kind of tearing
into Aiden at that dinner. So, I think Aiden probably has a good
idea of exactly what's wrong
or what could be considered like going wrong and he's sort of
just pretending and hope thinking like Perry doesn't know because
nobody's talked about it quite in like in like a lot of detail
yet. Like this is a bit of like well, you can't say what I did
wrong. You just know people were annoyed with me, but I think
people had already explained to him what they thought was incorrect
or bad about the conduct. >> Well, it's annoying because
obviously I wasn't there. I wasn't there. So, I can't pick up
examples of the way you were acting with hellbent. But you're
telling me that you acted in a perfect nice and you know pro-social
way when you were around with hellbent. >> I think I acted
I guess
as I always do. I don't say I wouldn't say pro-social. I wouldn't
necessarily say anti can can there just be like a neutral middle
ground? That's kind of how I was. No. >> Right. So, there
is nothing nothing you did to hell vent which you think would
have put her off and she's just like making a mountain out of
nothing according to you. >> I I don't think she's doing
anything. I I don't know what I just personally find her like
annoying and unfunny to hang out with. Um and I just don't have
interest to hang out with her. >> And you think it's okay
for you to spend hours in icy basically like her?
>> The hours thing is an exaggeration, but if I was >> It
is. It was hours. >> No, no. Quum was ripping into him
for unrelated reasons. just bullying. Oh, okay.
Okay, that's funny. >> Which I didn't. >> What's
that? >> I only Okay, so >> it was at least two >> I
already leaked Hellbent that you asked me to like take the knee
off of Aiden's neck. I know that you did that. I know that you
want to I But here's the thing, Hellbent. You are also broken
in an equal and opposite way to Aiden. and you're going to let
somebody be a complete prick to you and further that what that
will well that will do to you is make you try to make him like
you. All right, this is like the worst behavior you could have.
This is like the worst like please abuse me behavior that somebody
could possibly have is you when people are to you, you decide
that you need to double down on making them like you and that
is really bad. No, I have given up on that. Wrong. Wrong. You
haven't given up on that unless you've gone to a psychologist
and gotten help for it. Okay? Not that it's not even like you're
not going to hurt anybody. I'm just saying for your own good,
you should stop liking people who are rude to you, who are like
super mean to you. Okay? I'm just the best person, dude. No,
you're not. No, you're not. Cuz if you're the best person, the
best people take care of the people who treat them the best.
That's what the best people do. The best people don't prioritize
their time trying to make other people who don't like them like
them. Those are broken people.
I'm I'm telling you this I'm telling you this for your own good
and I'm I'm actually doing this to help you and I need you to
understand that so you don't start making art for me out of nowhere.
Okay? Because I said something mean. All right? I'm actually
trying to help you. If you interpret as me being mean right now,
you're probably going to start trying to draw art for the community
or something. I need you to understand I am actually trying to
help you. Okay? Thank
>> Or not by I don't know. You can uh you can like keep
saying in the chat. Not necessarily by >> Wait, it was
only Okay. What you're referring to specifically was a conversation
where there was the initial complaint and then the conversation
continued because people came and started talking about it and
then everything after that was me responding to
questions being asked to me and points being made or like like
to when you say that I spoke about something for hours that would
imply that the directive was entirely on my end which it just
like wasn't. Um but even if I [__] did uh which I
didn't right there still wouldn't even be a problem with that.
So I I guess I'm I'm just trying to think >> I feel like
you I think you think there is a problem with people like you
know shit-talking you know people based on like you know personal
encounters that they had IRL
>> that's not what I No >> you don't think that's
>> Wait made art for me when I've asked Hellbent has literally
made art for me when I asked. I'm just saying don't try to start
making me like you or something cuz I was rude. That's like it's
already bad. It's what I'm pointing out is the bad behavior.
Don't do that. [__] talk.
If if you if so if if you dislike somebody cuz of
No. When have I ever
>> I'll tell you when you when you complained that I was
telling stories of Army. You were you were saying that was bad.
That was wrong. And >> do you >> But now you doing
that to Helmets.
>> Okay. Me explaining an attitude towards somebody is
like different than like recounting like all the specifics of
like all the specifics of everything the two of you are doing
at the time that it's happening. Right? There's you're literally
trying to like contradiction fish here where one does or hypocrisy
hunt I should say where one doesn't exist. Right. There are differenc
>> so Perry says
um like you didn't like you didn't like our interactions or I
think it's you didn't like that I was talking about our interactions
offstream so why are you doing it >> ways in which you're
doing it because in both cases people are you know after having
a cordial meetup after having a cord you'll meet up with somebody
or deciding to um basically like dump a bunch of information
which paints them in a bad light
>> oh hello
>> five gifties from anonymous thank you very much anonymous
five big gifties. Let's go.
That's another hour in the >> Whether it be your perspective
well just the way that you perceived the way she was acting.
You were saying that she was old and unfunny and uh and stuff
like that. >> That's all I said and I the same no new revelations
came from any information that I gave. >> Well, the revelation
is that the whole time that you were hanging out, you were saying
that like she was so uninteresting to be. You're basically trying
to like tarnish her reputation.
>> Yes. True. Very true. [snorts] I mean, yeah, that is
true. You're basically trying to, you know, after having a relatively
cordial meetup, try and like insinuate that like because you
met up with her, it was so horrible that like no one should engage
with her.
>> Was it a Was it a cordial meetup? >> Okay. In
in >> How old is old here? Like 28 or 38? >> In the
Listen, I'm going to be >> over 30. Okay. Trump here. But
in the interest of journalistic integrity, okay, can you at least
try not to seem so biased? Okay. Why are you asking [laughter]
the important questions? >> What are the important questions?
>> How then isn't a streamer or a YouTuber
What What interest does she have hanging out with a bunch of
like 20some year old guys? Like why isn't she like getting married
or going like doing something with her? Why is she just getting
Why Why wouldn't she just get married? Why is she trying to hang
out with me on New Year's Eve? Why wouldn't she just get married?
I don't know.
Like,
either either take responsibility for having her in your community,
letting her in whatever group chat where you plan, letting her
join up with you guys. Either take responsibility with that or
just admit you are a like soft, doughy boy who got raped by Hellbent.
Okay? Cuz I have no I have no idea.
Why does she want to hang out with us? Are you implying all it
takes to hang out with you is somebody just going, "Hey, I'm
going to hang out with you." And you're just like, "Oh, I couldn't
possibly do anything about that. Oh no. Oh my god. Oh, you're
coming to Oh no, I don't like this. I don't like that you're
coming, but I'm not going to do anything about it." Shut up.
[__] is your problem? Just say, "No, I don't like
you. I don't want to hang out with you." Don't come. Don't come
to this. I'm actually going to make it a thing. Don't come to
this. I don't like you. I don't want to be around you. Why? Why?
Why do this after? Shouldn't she get married? What the [__]
is that? >> Her [__] life. >> But you
allowed her to organize. You only say this after the meet up.
After the meet up. >> No. No. Okay. You know what? You
know what? I did do something wrong. I'll I'll take the L here.
The L I took was not being more assertive and saying [laughter]
and and saying I don't like just like putting my foot down like
cuz basically what happened was >> she invited herself
and then >> when the opportunity came to clarify and like
it's like I don't have to to be fair to her, right? She's like,
I don't have to come if you don't want me to, whatever. But >> Oh,
yeah. No, hell, Ben. I I literally don't have a problem with
like here's the thing is he's saying all of this. He Triple doesn't
get to say any of this once you were the one setting things up.
So, where this goes is Hellbent's eventually in those group chats
and then because Aiden isn't doing anything. Aiden is like literally
not planning anything. Hellbent sets everything up and at that
point Aiden can off. He's not even doing anything. He's like
there other people set up. He's just showing up at stuff other
people set up. Don't complain about the people who do things.
Complain about yourself. Complain about the people who are lazy
and just show up. Okay? Don't complain about the people who are
driving action, making things actually happen. That's up. >> She
like that made me feel awkward. Um, so I didn't assert myself
or whatever. The [__] So, sure. You could say I took
an L by not like asserting myself. Sure. >> Yeah. I think
that's a common pattern with you. I'm glad you're acknowledging.
>> But like,
oh, so it was established this was a streamer only. The person
that typed that is like some 50-year-old like old [__]
freak that is just like mad that like yeah
>> reading the chat automatically we can deduce that he
is tilted. He's giga tilted. The second you start reading another
streamer's chat while talking to them you are ultra tilted. >> Weird
that like you're spending your days hanging out with people half
your age cuz you have a lack of accomplishment in your life.
>> To be fair, I agree there is an age gap. [laughter]
There is an age gap. We're
>> where does Aiden get the sense of entitlement from
a if you ever are sitting there as an early 20-year-old who's
done nothing with their life at all. Okay.
Who's maybe at best attending university? What where is the entitlement
coming from?
You're just you're justifying being a like total like a totally
lazy layout for no reason.
Don't compare yourself to people who are 30 and haven't done
anything. Compare yourself to people your own age who are accomplishing
things.
Certainly this this like random trip to London, that's not helping
him accomplish any life goals, is it? Unless his life goal is
to just like meet up with Quean and say hi. Hi. Hi Queenman.
Hi. Hi Queenman.
Oh my god, you're Queenman from the internet. Is that is that
his life goal?
Because other than that, I don't know what this is accomplishing.
Clearly this stuff isn't going anywhere. Clearly, this is just
random internet bull that's not really going to it's not going
to be a solid life path for you for a long like in the long term.
Yeah, I don't know. I It's very bizarre to me that or maybe it
is like maybe he's going to make enough money at some point that
it will be. But it this is just fun. Why can't somebody else
have fun?
>> Okay, we're not talking about that cuz you know >> Wait,
and also there's another aside point here that I forgot about,
but Aiden was also hanging out. What is Aiden? Aiden was hanging
out with people hellbent's age when Aiden was like 12. So I actually
again don't even know where this is coming from. Like you literally
got groomed by a bunch of people when you were like 12 in the
commentary community. Yeah. You hang out with Chud Logic and
play Call of Duty with him. Dude, it's total.
Like it's actually total.
You've done this with so many other people that you don't call
out, but you just want to call out this one person.
>> I don't know if when you were like 16 or whatever you'd
have like 30 year olds in the group. That's like weird. I agree.
But you're like an adult. No, you're like 20, you know. It's
not like you guys are in different stages of your life that much.
Really? >> True. I agree. >> And you've you've hung
out with older YouTubers like Jack Films. Is he like Wait, I'm
sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Since when do I care that people
are >> That's what you just >> When do I care?
>> Dude, what are you doing? What is this weird debate,
bro?
She's like old and isn't married or have kids yet. She has no
accomplishments. Dude, when do I care that people are old? I
only care that they're old and losers. It's like, okay, I
that's why are you being a debate bro right now? >> That
since when do I >> I
think you're just trying to differentiate old losers from young
losers because you fall into one of those categories. >> I
care about that. God, I You know what? You make a really good
point. I've never used someone's age against them before. >> You're
not even restore to God speed. What the hell? But it's hypocritical
of >> No, no, no, no, no. I think I think chatters need
to be called out and call in debate as well. But I'll talk to
you. I'll address you as well. >> All right. Well, if you
want, if Goss wants, you can call in. If God wants, you can call
in. But I'm saying you're okay with hanging out with old people.
It's just that the fact that she's not a >> Soul's barely
a streamer. How's he around? How's he okay to be around? >> Because
outside of like the streaming thing, I like his personality enough
where we'd probably naturally be >> All right. So, none
of this has to do with whether or not she's a streamer or a chatter.
It's all just that you don't
>> the two the two criterion that would like make me interested
in potentially hanging out with her uh are non-existent
uh in her uh therefore uh yeah I just have zero interest and
hang out with this person. >> The two criteria are Wait,
did he say >> Yeah, then you know that's doesn't mean she's
a bad person. Just means
I am once again honestly just hang out. >> Oh, Sebs if
you want to watch the VOD just go back in this VOD and you can
watch. just the first like 3 hours of the stream. You want to
watch the Misk Crash Out stuff. >> Well, I'm telling you,
you really should be more assertive in these situations cuz it
does come off as like really that like someone was happy to,
you know, organize the whole thing. You guys were going to go
to like some fancy bar. Well, she she offered like location and
you said I don't want to leak this >> inviting some guy
to Wait, she didn't organ she didn't she didn't organize
>> I'm in the group chat. She was trying to organize stuff.
You were snarking her.
But you understand she was trying to organize some meet up with
Becket on a day I wasn't even originally going to be here on.
>> Wait, hold on.
I Okay,
what what's the problem with that? Is there a Wait, what's the
problem, dude? There's no way. This is my group chat. It's for
meeting up with me. How dare you try to meet up with other people
there? There's no way he could be that, right? There's no way
that he could be like so self-absorbed there that he's like you
can't plan other things in here with all these same people. No,
no, no. >> Like that's her level. Like >> although
I would I guess he might be just alleging that that's really
parasocial if Hellbent
and uh that could have no relationship possibly. >> It's
like there's no organiz she's she
>> to be fair though compare that to your own organization.
>> Does anyone remember this is a good analogy. Does anyone
remember like when like uh during the Yeah, I got to reference
an old [__] slop drama, but like Chud put it best
like when uh when Colton like tries to like interject into like
drama and like make himself like the arbiter of information so
he could feel like cool or whatever he's managing all the
>> Okay, that can be a thing when information doesn't require
that. However, when you're planning to meet up, when you're synchronizing
with multiple people and you're planning to meet up in real life,
okay, that's a different thing. Hey, we're all traveling to the
same location so we can meet up. You need concrete plans.
That's not somebody being the arbiter of information. Or if you
if you don't have that arbiter of information, plans fall apart.
People flake. Yeah. You need a direct time place. We're meeting.
THIS IS THE TIME. This is the place. Be
>> Yeah. You need somebody like that. Obviously the info
she like inserts herself as like she isn't invited to and then
likes to be the organizer and tell other people like soul that
like they're not wanted so that she could feel like she's like
whatever
one she's so >> the soul stuff. What are your thoughts
on the soul stuff? She did basically say soul you have a job
you're not allowed you can't hang out. What do you think of >> What
do you think of that? >> Do you think you want to hang
out with soul and she like is that how you feel? >> What
you said? Do you feel like she sort of like cuts Soul out of
the group?
>> I don't think she apparently she made some comment to
Soul that I thought was like mega ironic or whatever. But >> what
was that? >> Wait, was that was that her making a comment
that like other people had made to her? So she was like kind
of throwing that back at Soul as like a joke that hey you're
going after me but you wouldn't go after Soul for the same thing.
Is that what that's what I would
Is that what it was? Hell, was that was that what it was? Basically
like other people are saying you invited yourself so you like
started giving Soul the same energy for fun because it was funny.
>> Apparently she told Soul like learn when you're not
wanted or some [__] It was like it was like really
really I mean come on. Like if you're going to be like annoying
enough at least be like at least have like a shred of like self-awareness.
Holy.
>> Now Aiden speaking of self-awareness right you're saying
I can't believe that uh Helbin's doing this whole thing where
she's like the organizer. I agree. It's going to be annoying
when people do that. But have you considered that you're like
the most nightmarish annoying fsler to [__] meet
up with cuz you cancel all the time. >> Perry's speaking
from experience by the way. Him and Perry did meet up, right?
They did meet up. Um, so that's very funny cuz Perry's definitely
talking about a real thing that happened. Like he's saying when
we met, this is how it was. So I understand why she's trying
to plan things. Good stuff. This was after Soul left London where
he stayed at my place and we were all joking. Oh, then that sounds
particularly Yeah. And I've heard Soul go on these things and
defend you, so I I don't even doubt that you guys were on good
terms, right? >> No, no, wait. Okay, I agree. So, I'll
simplify the process. Don't meet up with me. Easy as that. Just
don't
>> You're saying this to Queen
I agree. I'm inconvenient to organize with. So, Hellbent, don't
organize anything with me. Don't meet up with me. Don't see me.
I agree. We can go part am part ways amicably
and [laughter] that's life. Say >> but you're not just
saying it's a hellbent. You're saying to Queman, "Oh, don't meet
up with me if I'm hard to meet up with." You're saying to Dickers,
"Don't meet up with me if I'm hard to meet up with." >> I
I I think meeting up with Quan was >> Right. But you are
Was Quumman nicer to him by the way? Or does Aiden I think the
impression I get
for better or worse
is that Aiden and Hellbent have the same disease. Okay, the thing
I diagnosed hellbent with. Aiden got that too. Except Aiden also
remembers when he was like the butt of the jokes when he was
like the the whipping boy in the commentary community. Okay,
he remembers that and he wants someone else to be that in like
his social groups and so I think he cast other people in the
role. Okay, I think that's what he's doing most of the time.
It's my diagnosis. All right. >> Nightmare to do that.
>> Still is uh in some places. >> Actually facilitated
it happening.
>> Facilitated. She didn't. She facilitated
>> But she Okay, that's just not true. Well, I don't know
the details, but apparently didn't she organized the boats like
meet up at the party. >> Name one thing that I did that
she
>> The whole boat party thing. No, >> dude. No shot.
Name one thing I did that she facil. No shot, dude. Name one
thing I went to that she facilitated. It's like, dude, it's not
all about you. You got other people to be interested in going
on this trip and then sometimes you weren't going to be there.
It sounds like these people wanted to meet up and hang out as
well.
Queen booked that, didn't he? Oh, well, I'm sure stuff will get
corrected. This is early on. >> The She wasn't. No, no,
>> she wasn't here. >> Are you serious?
>> What the What is wrong?
>> This is what I typed in Chipy's chat last night. Hurt
people. Hurt people. Okay. That Aiden was like Aiden was the
guy who got all of this abuse hurled at him and now he's just
paying it forward. Okay. hurt people. Hurt people. I don't want
the I wasn't there. Obviously, I wanted the details. >> So
then So then don't make So then don't make assertions off of
just like you're making up on the spot. >> I said I wasn't
sure. >> Bro, I'll be real. I watched some of this conversation
on Chipy's stream last night. Okay.
And
watching it with Que
and Que literally goes, "Oh man, Sleepy's covering this." When
he like wants me to go look at it. Oh man, Sleepy's covering
this. And then we watch for about 30 minutes. I was just playing
Civ. We're like listening to this content and Sleepy goes, "Oh,
Queenman, I see why you linked this to me." And I'm like, "Yeah,
oh my god, HOW DID HOW DID HOW IS SLEEPY covering this? I have
no idea. Oh my god." And then Sleepy literally says on his stream,
"Thank you, Queen, for licking this to me. It is very funny."
I'm just like, "Bro, you okay, dude? Okay, whatever you say,
man." >> I said I wasn't sure. I'm asking you nothing.
You assumed the answer that would be like the >> No, 100%
that happened. I'm not even joking. That happened 100%.
I could go find in the Chip Vod where he says it. It was so It
was very funny to me. Okay. >> He's favorable to me. So
you could like sound like you have a point. >> So who organized
the boat? Who organized the boats?
>> It was me, Queen, and Soul. >> I just can't get
over it because I I don't obviously I don't record like a random
VC where I'm just playing Civ, so I can't prove it. But I swear
to God, he was like, "Oh my god, oh my god, sleepy. How is sleepy
covering this? This is going everywhere. [laughter] >> In
a call that she wasn't in." >> So she organized nothing
at all.
>> Nothing that I have done or intend on doing. Has she
organized? No. >> Sure. Well, to be fair, something that
you try she tried organizing, you said no. That's that's >> I
don't want a part of it. She could go organize the like hellbent
con in some in London. I don't care. She could go do that. Nothing
that I am I have been a part of or want to be a part of has been
organized by her. You can't name anything because it doesn't
[__] exist. This is a point.
And you you just uh and your biggest regret is you didn't um
ice her out of the meetup earlier.
Uh, I should have said, um, you know, listen, I mean, I
I'm always happy to meet fans, but [laughter]
dude, I this
I Aiden's got like his own community. It's decently sized.
He He's got like a community that seems pretty disjoint from
like Queen's community, my community. He's got like a fairly
large sort of subset of his own thing. Okay.
But even so, the the ego here feels so unearned.
It's just a dude, he really thinks this is like all about him
that yet he's like,
dude, other people exist. It's really weird how far he's going
down this like total narcissist path. I maybe he's leaning into
it cuz he thinks it's cool. I've seen that theory, okay, that
he's trying to do the Patrick Baitman
and maybe
maybe >> of this >> he's just a 20-year-old. No,
lots of 20-year-olds have empathy. He's a 20-year-old streamer
is what you could say. But he's also a 20-year-old commentary
streamer, and I'm guessing he calls out these behaviors in other
people all the time.
If he didn't if he didn't call out these behaviors in other people
all the time, maybe he'd get more of a pass, right? But if he's
going to engage in this kind of behavior that he would call out
in other people, then probably he has to deal with getting called
out for it. I'm guess, you know, that's that seems fair to me.
>> Sweet. I should I should have been more assertive. Okay.
I should have been more assertive. Said, "Listen, I just think
this whole like thing is going to be going on way past your bedtime,
grandma. Uh, and you should probably be, I don't know, getting
ready for >> Yeah, this is kind of like shower arguments
where like you wish you said this to her in person." >> Hold
on. Hold on. The scene with Baitman admiring himself in the mirror,
but with Baitman replaced by Aiden is actually stomach churning.
Wait, but I hope somebody photoshopped a watch onto his hand
that he's looking at. Instead of flexing, it's like a watch on
his wrist. That would be perfect. Okay, >> but you didn't.
So now you're just saying it's >> Well, yeah, that's the
whole line. You're asking Well, you're asking about
>> regrets, which would be like my interpretation of what
I should have done or failed to do in hindsight. So, yes. Right.
But like your own that answer of course is going to entail arguments
I wish I made because that's the what your question would be.
>> But those weren't arguments. Those were dunks. Those
were dunks. I wish I dunked her in person, but I didn't. >> You
literally asked me what I regreted. I answered honestly. Yes.
>> It's not really a dunk though. That's like he said,
"Oh, I wish I would have just made it clear, been more assertive."
It's not really a dunk. I think being assertive would be the
the only path he could take here is just I'm not going to hang
out with Hellbent. I don't like her. I don't want to be around
her. You guys can organize stuff with Hellbent if you want, but
I'm not going to be with her. Okay. We're going to we're going
to do our own [__] >> No, that's fair. I'm
just saying that that is what that is. And I guess we >> Yeah,
sure. Sure. But that answers the question that you asked. >> All right.
Okay. No, I see we're we're both It seems we're in agreement
here.
>> Yeah. So, Hellben says thing is I did not tag along
to everything and Aiden was still miserable. I'm guessing
that's Yeah, dude.
Like that's the worst thing that can happen is somebody you you
ever see the uh there's a phrase in software called disagree
and commit as in we're not going to come to the same like understanding
or agreement on what the solution is. But okay, but after a while
after like
uh expressing your disagreement, your dissatisfaction, you need
to say, "Okay, we disagree, but we'll commit to this path." Right?
That if you just consistently whine and complain about the same
problem after other people have out overruled you on something
or you've been outvoted, it's over. It's like it's so stupid,
right? Like you those are the people you got to cut cuz they
they just make everything miserable. It's like, "Okay, well now
you're here with Hellbent. You could either make you could either
have fun, make some memories with your friends, or you could
be a whiny like the whole time. Don't pick number two. >> And
so, um, I guess just Are you going to do anything or are you
just going to stay in your bed rotting for the rest of the That's
how she's >> describing to wait for I'm staying here. I'm
staying here, buddy. I'm waiting for you. Okay. >> I might
go up I might go up north for a few days. I don't know. But you
know what, Perry?
>> I'm staying here, man. >> Wow. I will be there.
I'll be on the >> well next week. I want to say the exact
>> You know what I'm going to do until then? You know what
I'm going to do until then? >> I see you. >> Jack
[__] Okay. >> Why not? Queen could cry. Dude,
I always love how there's like some British like [__]
[__] that needs to posture about everything. You
came all the way to London and you're sitting in your bed doing
nothing. It's like, yeah, >> problem. I want to sit in
my bed and do nothing. I do want to sit here. I do
[__] I do want to rot. I do like what is the problem?
What is the issue? Slur that naturally wouldn't. >> Um
well, I guess the main two issues are one, it seems like you
canceled to meet up with Dickers. Well, not an issue for
>> I don't That's up like a gigachad thing. Don't giga
chatter those. That's less bad. It's less bad than giga chatting
like stuff, which some people do, but it's still pretty bad.
Yeah, I am a totally miserable loser who will never go anywhere
in life. Yeah, that's who I am. That's I go on vacations to lie
in my bed. Yeah, I'm a loser. Don't gig chat that. That's weird.
Don't Don't do that. That's just That's bizarre.
Although, yeah, don't gig chat. It's obviously bad. And there's
nothing dude. Everybody's gone on a vacation, had some stuff
planned, canceled it, and just laid in the bed in the hotel.
Everyone's done that. But you don't say, "Oh, I really love going
to this place so I can just be lazy and not do anything." That's
weird. Okay. >> An issue for your fans. And two, you seem
like you're a scared epsler who refuses to say all this to hellbent
in
>> I Okay, what have I said now? Okay, >> I think
that's the opposite problem. I don't know where the oh, you didn't
say this to Hellbent in person thing is coming from. [clears throat]
That wasn't my impression. I thought Aiden was being an Hellbent
in person as well.
Maybe not as bad. Maybe it was worse when he would like not be
around her and he could talk to other people. But I do think
he was also an to her in person. >> What have I been scared
to say to Hellbent in person? Hellbent
still in chat. Hellbent, did I call you an insecure [__]
at dinner?
>> But you said but that was just banter when we were in
the that VC. You said that was just banter.
>> Okay. [snorts] What?
>> Oh, wait. I hope Perry knows to pull up his Schroingers
definition from before where Aiden is now verifiably flip-flopping
between No, I really did mean that and no, it was just a joke.
It was just banter. Right. You remember Aiden's whole thing where
he's like, "You don't have to say how I'm like trying to avoid
making a real argument with jokes." Well, right there,
you said it was banter in VC when you were around other people.
Now you're here with Perry and you're like, "Oh, hell, Ben. I
totally said this seriously to your face." Uh-oh. >> You
say you said it, but you didn't like mean it when you said it
apparently. >> Okay, maybe maybe we have like different
definitions of the term banter. Maybe I I should say fac phys
facicious would have been a bit does facicious imply that there's
like
>> wait we all caught it right we all caught it
that he's clearly doing the Schroingers he defined >> an
underlying point but you're there's an emphasis on the level
of aggression or concern for the sake of >> um humor or
um >> no facicious is like sarcastic I think I think what
you're saying is it's um you're like burying the lead you're
using humor to mask your true opinions >> okay there I
am Not scared to say anything to Hellbent in person.
>> Okay. But you didn't say the epic dunks you came up
with on this stream in person. You said what you you said you
said. And she >> asking me what you Wait. Okay. Okay. >> This
is just revealing that when Aiden banters, it's based on some
real anger he has. Yeah. I I think that's pretty consistent.
Again, the one thing I'll basically push back on people for is
almost none of this stuff that I've heard about Aiden is surprising.
Like it's kind of maybe he has some point there like almost everything
I've heard about him I'm like yeah that tracks. Yeah that tracks.
Yeah that tracks. I've not heard something where I'm like no
I don't think anything I don't think that's real. I don't think
it's like that. I don't think he's like that. Everything I've
heard is just yeah that tracks. That tracks 100%.
So
yeah getting angry and when when he's bantering he gets angry
and he just says like the things he knows that will upset other
people. Yeah. I think that also just tracks. >> Can I just
like explain to you how
I can't name an example of that, by the way. I'm just saying
in theory, I feel like that is how I perceive him. So, maybe
my brain's playing tricks there. But, I'm going to hit play on
this. I need to use the bathroom and just grab some caffeine
really quickly. So, I'll be right back. I'll let this play for
another 2 3 4 minutes and then I'll be back and we can move on.
There's still a lot more content to cover here. So, buckle in.
Okay. There's like eight hours of conversations around all this.
I'll try to navigate as best I can. Although once we get past
yesterday,
I haven't caught up on anything today. So I'm not the best guy.
I have a layout for it, but I'm not the best guy. >> Like
this line of dialogue is your question was Aiden, what are your
like your question essentially was what do you regret? Meaning,
what do you wish you had done or had not done? I proceed to give
you something that I wish I had done. You then say, oh well,
this thing, you didn't actually do it.
No, but I'm saying
would lead to a reply.
Something I wish I had done. >> I understand. I am saying
that the statements of what you the regrets bely a personality
of a cowardly person. That's what I'm saying. That's what I'm
>> I'm saying that your statements of what your regrets
are bely they they show they reveal that you were like a coward
and a [__]
>> No, because like I was totally willing to like say things
that like uh took jabs at Hellbent. There were things that weren't
banter. I said jokes were unfunny. I like like no, there is nothing
that would indicate that I'm like uh scared. Especially since
like I've been completely willing to argue with and confront
people in person. Um I literally [__] uh I
I've argued with Queen. I argued with Queen in person and I have
no problem with doing that. There's actually like nothing to
demonstrate that I was scared to say anything. I'm sorry. You
just like made this up. >> The demonstration is No, the
demonstration was >> evident. It was evident you were looking
for anything to like stretch out the content of your stream.
>> Argued with Queenman in person. I I guess so. Wow. >> I
have another statement actually. >> Hellbent organizing
point says that she was that she wasn't >> I know. I was
wrong about that. >> Trying to think I'm trying to think
of like how much I want to leak from the uh cuz that was really
telling right there.
Okay. Ah man, I'm starting to see this a lot
and I do get it. I do get it
but man, it looks bad. I I think of things in these terms sometimes,
too.
How much do I want to Yeah,
cuz there's like a thing going on here where somehow Aiden just
thought that was like a big thing right there. I even argued
with Queen in person. It's like, okay, I don't What do you think
that means? What did you just say in your head? You just made
like a definitive statement like a like you were like I even
What does that say about his mind
that it seems like he's basically throwing something? I even
argued with him in person. It's like I okay I I I literally don't
understand what that's supposed to mean. But I to me in my in
his head he probably thinks it's like that makes me cool. That
makes me awesome. That's like yeah like he's scary and most of
you wouldn't even dare. It's like he's literally in his own mind
put Queman like above himself. Queen's like super cool in his
mind and I'm like oof that's probably not good. I that's probably
not great.
We'll see. But there's there's another little point that goes
along with that, but I don't know if I want to say it cuz it's
not my read. So >> that's I agree. I was wrong about that.
That's amazing. You don't do research. >> I couldn't do
research. I couldn't do research and you make up points. You're
taking it personal because you're in your emotions anyway. >> Actually,
I don't take this personal. You just made that up as well. Okay.
Well, so you're but the thing is you're saying there's nothing
that evidences because I have debates about Israel Palestine
with Queenman. That is true. But something like saying >> no
debate about So you just made that up as well. >> See now
now you're trolling. You're strolling. But anyway, but something
like I don't want you around. That's a lot harder. That's a lot
harder to bring up than uh some debate about some myopic political
disagreement.
>> There was no nobody has ever implied that the debate
was about a political
>> All right. No, I'm saying it's cuz
>> I've heard people imply Aiden is a clout chaser. Maybe
like a little bit. I don't know if it's totally that. I think
I think he's doing the same thing like literally everyone does.
He's engaging in like a social hierarchy where he's trying to
establish that he's above. But the weird thing it's weird to
do the social hierarchy thing and then put yourself explicitly
below somebody else, right? Do you know what I mean? like
like I
think he's doing like a social thing. He's putting everybody
in a hierarchy, right? He's doing his Jordan Peterson lobster
bit. He's put Queen above himself and he's put Hellbent below
and Hellbent is interacting with other people and they're not
treating her like she's below and so he's like trying to reinfor
It feels like he's trying to reinforce it over and over again
as people have done to him throughout his career. >> Whatever.
But it wasn't a personal >> No. Okay. So, just to be clear,
you also just made that up to fit some. >> No, I said or
whatever. So I said I wasn't sure about it, but um >> for
your argument to work, it would have to be of the understanding
that the nature of the argument would like not be one that is
related to like an insult or a detriment to either of the two
participants character, right? To meet that you made up that
it was political despite nothing in the
>> one without even trying. No, I don't think that's true,
man.
I have like a like a skitso theory on that that I will never
put out in the world. Okay. I I don't think saying he won without
even trying. No, I think he put a lot of effort into
making sure that things
that's all I will say. That's all I'll >> Story implying
his side. >> That was an inciliary detail that you are
fixating on in order to present me as a liar. >> State
that the argument was political because it wasn't. Okay. So,
you're just doing the thing that I criticized you for four minutes
ago. >> The relevance of the politics wasn't there. I'd
like to move on though.
>> Dude, Aiden's getting Aiden's getting it from all angles
right now. This is really up.
Aiden and I made plans to hang out and stream tonight and he
canceled one hour ago. O
hey dickers. I know I'm in London for like only like a week or
two. I know that like I'm supposed to be here making memories
and that's the whole point of going on a trip overseas,
but you know what? I got to go defend myself on the Purple Perry
gaming stream right now. I couldn't possibly I couldn't possibly
hang out with you in person. I gotta go live. I gotta be on the
Purple Perry stream. I gotta call in over Discord right now.
My honor is being impeded. People are saying I'm weird. That's
>> Dickers is saying >> that you and him agreed to
make plans to hang out on stream and you canceled an hour ago.
>> Um, can I get proof of those plans? >> Um, Dickers
the balls. Also, you also got to watch out cuz that could easily
be Kathy. I know Kathy has a convincing Dickers alt. Okay, that
could very easily be Kathy. So, you got to be very careful when
it's when it's Dickers or even me, >> man. Courts. >> Um,
but this would be just another example of how you're like self-sabotaging,
right? You >> another example that you can't prove and
you're going to have to move on from because there's no >> the
character testimony of Dickers. If you don't want to if you think
that Dickers is a known liar and you don't want to use his character
testimony and his statements as proof, that's fair enough. But
I think that many people in the audience will take him as a reliable
person in this case. Um, so you're saying this isn't >> Haven't
you said Haven't you said verbatim that Dickers is so dishonest
several times? >> I don't think I've called him dishonest.
I've called him an uh >> You've never called Dickers dishonest?
>> Um, not that I can recall.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> wait, why is he Why is he trying to weasel? He's just
weasling into another argument. Didn't you call Diggers? Just
say no, that didn't happen.
Why
isn't Dickers like really dishonest? >> The way I see it,
Aiden, this is just another example of you um self-sabotaging,
right? So, you're selfab you're refusing to call out
events. You're refusing to >> I'm not I'm I'm not refusing.
>> We have to talk about something on the internet. There's
a meta narrative that needs to come about.
When you find someone who like has a thing that they will always
argue on that is like harmful for them. It's basically like you
find someone who's willing to argue. I'm not a weirdo. I'm not
a weirdo. You should like me. I'm not a weirdo. When you find
the people who are willing to argue that significantly over long
periods of time, is there something abusive in getting them to
argue that to their own detriment for hours and hours for days
and days on end? Like, yeah, Pirate Software was always going
to keep arguing, right?
Are we are we doing something abusive there to like consistently
farm him on that same point forever? Is there something wrong
with us, too? Because I think that's what's going on with Aiden.
Aiden is like, I feel like Aiden would argue this for the rest
of time, and it wouldn't ever make him look good. It would only
ever make him look worse.
And
are we really going to Are you really going to farm him like
this? That's up. Like I can tell people I can tell people are
trying to trigger him and it's like kind of funny but like at
the same time I'm not telling people to stop. I'm just saying
there is something going on here where where people are going
to keep farming this and it's not it's not really it's never
just never be fooled into thinking it's because people don't
want Aiden to be weird or they want Aiden to be less weird. That's
not what it is. Right. >> Okay. Just never be fooled.
do anything.
>> Great. No, I'm in the past tense. I meant refuse. I
refuse. >> Oh, also don't take that as me saying I don't
want to farm him or anything like that. I literally talked again
last night and then earlier in stream about just making up some
stuff about Aiden's trip for fun just to see if he'd get mad.
Okay, so I'm not I cannot throw the first stone on this. I'm
not saying you guys are evil and I am not. I literally discussed
just making up a thing randomly to to throw out there and have
fun with. Um, >> I didn't refuse like I any in the- moment
uh criticisms that I had I was totally willing to bring up. I
>> It is lame though. It is lame to just like do nothing
on vacation, right? You realize this, right? >> Okay. So,
now we're just moving on to a completely different point uh about
how you're like mad on my behalf about the what I am or I'm not
>> your own and just like another point because you you
didn't
cuz you're lazy. >> Many people's fat. I wasn't even going
to stream. >> Get in here. Talk. >> You weren't going
to stream today. I I mean, yeah, I could tell spontaneous.
>> Just uh focusing on the quality of my stream and so
the fact >> was that was that Aiden like his stream right
there like in a in a not so subtle >> that you are a bed
rotting. Sorry. We're getting uh we're getting updates. Uh it's
he's scared to stream while on vacation because of Dioro. >> That's
uh apparently >> true. True. Dioro, Dan Salman, Queen Pixie
Jaw.
Why does he Why did he just invoke me? What?
>> True. True. Dioria Den Salultman, Queen Pixie Jst.
>> Wait, what does that make sense? >> Sorry, we're
getting uh we're getting updates. Uh it's he's scared to stream
while on vacation because of Dioro. That's uh apparently >> True.
True. Dioro, Dan Salman, Queen, and Pixie J. Stalk.
I I actually don't know what how what is >> Apparently,
you were talking to Hel about how she could help you rebuild
a Dioro Bridge. That's what people are telling me. >> True.
True. I was like
that that that is accurate. That is accurate. And then she said
she said no. And I was like you and I ran out. And that's actually
the whole reason I hate her. >> Sir, are we getting a new
accusation?
Does that just spend his par to jet around the world just
uh oh that Jimberly don't know that is probably a core critical
okay this is why I didn't and this this will come up later does
Aiden just spend his parents money to jet around the world just
to be the same flaky and sack maladjusted and sad flaky sad sack
maladjusted freak somewhere else I'm
that is a little bit what's going on um a little bit okay a little
bit little bit a little bit. This the the parents money thing
is the thing that gets rough for me when he like talks about
other people not having accomplishments and then you find out
that the reason he gets to go around and check off all these
countries from around the world is cuz he's just spending his
parents money to do it. So he goes to a different country where
he can sit in his hotel room the whole day consistently spending
that money and then he's like talks down to talks down to other
people and be is like then he talks down to other people and
he's like you don't have any accomplishments.
It's like what? Excuse me. What the >> parents want money
to jut around
>> problem? Yeah. It's like um wait, aren't you a socialist?
Verain.
Do I have to explain to that why that would be a problem in your
worldview?
justice freak somewhere else >> and be the same flaky sad
justice freak somewhere else. Thoughts on this? >> Yes.
Yeah, I do. I do. I want you to know that while you support your
like five little ugly cleft flipped disgusting children on your
minimum wage slave job working at uh Dollar Tree uh for a living
all day and night with a wife that's like getting in the ass
to the next room. I want you to know that I don't have to work
at all because I was born rich and handsome and you
>> isn't Jimberly like a software engineer with a of like
extra money?
I thought Jim I thought Jimberly was one of the software people
who hangs out and has just a ton of money >> weren't you're
bald broke. Um your kids are going to go bald as well. So even
if they you know their ugly faces if it might have been saved
by a good head of hair that's also going downhill for them. Uh
and honestly anyone uh with a iota of responsibility would have
probably been sterilized in your >> How could someone think
that's good to say? Uh he doesn't think it's good to say. He
knows it's maladjusted. He is vice signaling, right? This is
Asminold behavior. Just so we're clear, this is asminold behavior.
Okay? Somebody describes being a totally degenerate freak to
you and goes, "I'm awesome cuz I'm a totally I'm a massive loser."
You should just call them a massive loser and move on. You shouldn't
even spend that much time like litigating it. You should just
say, "Oh, that's a loser. I shouldn't really engage with them."
Okay?
No, he's not even doing XC. Your house is on my wrist. He's saying,
"Oh, I'll go do this. I was born like rich and handsome, so I
can go do whatever I want wherever I want." It's like, dude,
I you're literally not disagreeing with the the, you know, the
the bedrotting allegation.
You should be you shouldn't brag about being a loser. And again,
vice signaling is gay. We're going to have a whole thing on vice
signaling coming up cuz it's starting to become like a real problem.
Like like it's starting to become a thing on the right wing in
the same way that on the left wing, you know, how virtue signaling
and like just trying to show how good you are all the time was
really big. It's starting to become such an issue on the right
wing. Like literally those ice raids would be worse if you didn't
produce videos like trivializing them, making them like totally
dog [__] Like sorry, making them making yourself
look like a dog person. You're like, "Yeah, we are being extra
performatively cool to these people." Yes. Isn't that doesn't
that make it cool? And then a bunch of people on TWITTER LIKE,
"YES, THAT'S AWESOME. THEY'RE LIKE POKéMON.
Get the out of here, man." >> Right. So, you're basically
just admitting that's like you're a Nepo baby and yet you >> having
a rich family is not a vice. That's not all he's saying, though.
You you read the donation, right? That it was like, "Oh, you're
just traveling based on your parents' money. You don't do anything.
You're just wasting your time, wasting your money." Yeah. When
he says that, when he goes, "Yeah, I was born like rich and fa
rich and handsome and I'll do whatever I want." That's not That
is vice signaling.
Yeah, but he streams, right? Not really. >> Failed to learn
the basics of >> Handsome. Yep. Golden ratio, strong jawline,
uh, full head of hair, no balding.
Um, what else? Neutral cample
Isn't he like 20?
You just go no balding when he's 20 years old. He's >> So
he's probably not going to bald. They tend to have pretty good
hair. >> Yeah. Like these things are like measurable. They
have been measured. I also um I'm intelligent. Uh so yeah, I
mean I just like you can like say you can the problem is the
problem is >> Yeah. Um Kathy, you just linked a racist
caricature of Aiden in my chat. Uh please do not do that. If
you link another racist character of Aiden that is clearly photoshopped,
I will ban you from the chat. >> There are there's like
the delusional version of me from those who have interest in
perceiving me uh as inferior to themselves to cope with their
own inferiority. And then there's, you know, uh the measurable
truth that yes, I'm intelligent. I'm handsome. Uh I was born
uh into immense I was born into privilege so I could sit around
all
>> we really calling that a neutral canthal tilt. He's
already got his head tilted down. And he just like literally
touches his chin to his chest and then he's like neutral neutral
canal tilt guys. Neutral neutral neutral >> all day and
do whatever the [__] I want. Uh and yeah, honestly
just like winning in life while you're uh
>> uh Aiden made gorillions with his old YouTube. No, I
know he had a lot of viewers. He had like a big YouTube channel
or whatever. I don't know if he made a ton of money. I don't
know when in like the ad cycle of YouTube that
I know he has some bigger videos, but I don't think he would
be making like crazy crazy money back then. >> Speaking
of, um, whenever when when Dickers accused you of being an aderall
addict and abusing your ad prescription, you didn't say anything.
But when I did that, you crashed out at me.
>> What's that about? >> I am a drug addict. Uh,
and I will continue to be. What's the problem? >> Well,
the problem is that when when Dickers on history mentioned that
you abused your prescribed aderall, you had no problem. But when
I insinuated that, I didn't even say it literally. You tries
to burn the bridge with me. So, what's the difference there?
>> I was wrong, Perry. I apologize.
>> Okay. I'm glad we could get that hashed
>> I think we got to be getting pretty close to the end,
right? >> You're really just going to keep talking, but
>> do you want to go rock climbing? >> No way. >> When
I get there, you want to go rock >> That's up there. That's
really Why would you do that? That's
That's very rude. That's very rude. >> You want to go rock
climbing? I'll think about it. >> I'm going to go with
Hellbent. Uh if uh if you don't go with me. The thing is Hellbent
wants to go with me. So if you say you'll go with me, I'll cancel
Hellbent and then she'll be upset. Balls in your courts, man.
maybe we could go rock climbing.
>> All right, man. Um why didn't you are you going to make
any content while you're in the UK or are you just going to bed?
>> You know what? I thought about it, but it's just like
it's all so tiresome. You know what I And it's just like >> it
was it did win drama of the year I'm pretty sure is the content
that you made when you were in Malta. So >> I mean what
is there to even go live about like >> I don't know man
you have like a whole audience of Leo convoy analysts. I'm sure
they can help you out with that. >> Aiden does fun that
Leo Convoy thing but I mean listen you got to got to make your
money where you can. Okay.
Are we we're probably just about good with this right? We can
move on to the the the queen part. Is there am I missing anything
big by staying on this? It seems like they're just kind of arguing
in circles. Do they get back to litigating anything specific?
I think we're good to move on from here. But yeah, we're good
to Okay, we're good to move on from here. Let's Let's move on
to the I think we move on to the Queenman stream here. Queen
going live and start to talk about some of these
>> Wait, can I just get a link to the start of his stream?
Queen's going to tell the whole story again. Hold on.
What do I want here for highlights? [laughter] I feel like I
listened to some of this. Wait, let me go. >> I got there.
I don't know which day. The first day. Okay, so day one. I got
there and met Aiden.
>> Okay. And oh, we'll go from here. >> I had planned
ahead a bit. I knew roughly what we were going to do, where we
were going to go, okay? And I managed to get Aiden to show up
without asking too many questions. Okay. >> I I watch him
roast, dude. I I >> Why do I look so old in that picture?
Uh I I kind of look I look both 13 and 50.
Anyway, I'm going to be real,
but lighting and uh the
whatever AI was used to clean up a photo or whatever. But I was
getting ID all night, so I can't look that old. I'm going to
be real. So yeah, what was I saying? See, I met up on with Aiden
the first night. Okay. And I knew what we were doing. I'd planned
ahead
and I'd found out there was this uh
owned by
Vice Media in London. Okay.
When I looked uh what what live music they had on at night, there
was a
like
it said um
queer, trans, POC
bands or something [__] like that. I was like, "Awesome,
perfect, perfect, great, perfect. That sounds amazing." Quit
transparency UK on the ground. That's what I said. I was like, "Perfect."
Okay. Already,
dude, you're going to go on a trip to like hang out with people.
This should be what it is, right? You should try to go somewhere
awesome to hang out. You should try to do something cool. You
should always be willing to go try new things. Try to like just
do whatever the [__] right?
Just it doesn't matter. You go to like a new restaurant, you
try something. You know what I like doing when I go to restaurants?
I'll try something I used to not like. I'll explicitly get something
I know that I've disliked in the past. Just trying to see like,
was I right about that? Would that could that be good? Would
that be could that be awesome?
Right. Just trying to do the same all the time is so boring.
Amazing. That's where we're going. Obvious like obviously, right?
Hopefully that's clear. So, I take in there first. We walk in,
the music's like upstairs. We walk downstairs and go to the bar
and uh I'm like, "Oh, what do you want to drink?" And he's like,
"Oh, just whatever whatever you're drinking." I'm like, "Okay,
okay." So, I I am Amstill. If you guys know what Amstill is,
it's it's a popular laga.
We were both in Amsterl. And obviously Aiden is not keen on it.
It's pretty obvious immediately. He's not into the beer. He doesn't
want beer. Um I knew that was going to be the case. I knew that
would be the case. I know why. Like, but he said, "Order what
whatever you're getting." And it's like,
"Sure, whatever I'm getting. Sure. I'm not starting on spirits
yet, so that's what we'll but he does enjoy it obviously. So
then we go upstairs and we go to the uh the music thing and it
doesn't start for a minute. I don't I don't make it immediately
clear to Aiden, but there's like QR codes around for um this
person's like goofund me for that bomb stage I believe. >> Okay,
that's that's pretty hilarious >> on stage and they talk
about oh I'm rapping in Tamil and
they got quite a deep voice and it's just like it's quite funny.
It's quite funny. I won't go too crazy but it was quite funny.
It was quite funny and Aiden's just like looking at me awkwardly
like you know what what the [__] Thank you for the
$5 chlor I think. Can I see your app? Did you donate for the
surgery? Uh no no I did not. So we leave that pretty quickly.
We do leave out pretty quickly and then we sort of bar a few
different places just like looking on Google Maps like what bars
are around. Most of them are kind of dead. Then we end up somewhere
where they've got a band on and we walk in and we walk in the
band is doing like an rock cover of Shake It Off by Taylor Swift.
And I'm like, "Oh yeah, let's go." I'm I'm into it immediately
obviously because that's that's the sort of thing that you know
I'm a couple drinks deep at this point. That's the sort of thing
that I'm like totally into. You know if I'm a couple drinks deep
is all right. Why did he say if I'm a couple drinks deep? Like
he wouldn't go there totally stone sober and just hang out and
bop. Come on. Why is he You see that little subtle defense of
his own optics right there? Oh, I'm a couple drinks deep. So
I totally love
Be real. Okay. You you be bopping of that Stone Cold sober. >> All right.
Cover some pop song. Yeah. Okay. Awesome stuff. W cool. So I
might immediately enter that and then start like not looking
crazy enthusias whatever dude whatever dude. Okay. So we get
a drink and then starts on Ramen Coke and she says to Roman Cokes
after he's maybe drink a Spritz which was just you know whatever.
But I get Rum and Coke. He starts he's clearly enjoying that.
He gets a taste for that and um so we're in this in the bar for
a bit. We talk you hanging out and I kind of try to get him to
like you know dance and enjoy it a bit. He's not really into
it but they're playing like you know they go through
and they go through like Teenage Dirt Bag and Mr. Bright Side
and what else? What else? in too deep. I think you know they
go they go through all the want to reveal his I mean I don't
have secrets on him. He doesn't he doesn't talk about his personal
life. I don't have any secrets on this guy. I think it would
be like rude to discuss things we talk about private in some
cases but I don't have like I have like a theory on this whole
Aiden thing that Quimman's very satisfied with the way this is
going for Aiden. That's my personal thoughts on it. Okay. He's
very that he went and uh that he went and he made sure to go
argue with him in his VC cuz I think he knew how bad that was
going to go for him. I think he's like definitely made like an
anerted
effort to get other people to cover it.
I think he's very very aware of how it's going for Aiden and
enjoys it immensely. And so he's just poking little pokes and
nudges in the background trying to get all this stuff going.
Okay.
Trying his hardest. all the sort of songs that you I am totally
into. I'm out for that sort of music. That's what I'm out to
hear. I would love that same part. Yeah, exactly, man. That's
what I'm out to hear. That's what I'm out for. Throwing friends
and it's like the best night ever. I sort gets into a little
bit get into a little bit, but he's not he's not going crazy
or anything. It's okay. We're getting somewhere at least. Then
we go into the next bar and it's like notably worse. It's like
way more normie. You know what I mean? It's like they're playing
like Timber, you know? It's going down. I'm yelling timber. They're
playing that among other songs. And the thing is that usually
I wouldn't be that crazy into it, but there were some kind of
like cheesy like 2010 songs on there. I can kind of get into
that. You know, I can kind of get into timber, you know? I can
kind of get into timber. I can kind of do that. But Aiden was
not. And I was like immediately realized he was not going to
be able to get into
Oh, real quick. I'll just say that was the thing I wasn't going
to talk about was I just think Quebec had like way stronger hand
in in shephering this along then he'd be willing. Somebody was
like, "Oh, he didn't do anything. He just won cuz he he didn't
even try." And I'm like, "No, no, he tried. No, he he made sure
that this went this way." Oh, absolutely he did. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. 100%. [laughter]
So that's all that's all I was like not going to say. I was like,
"Oh, maybe I shouldn't say that." But it is just funny to say
that. That's almost certainly conspiratorial. By the way, he
never once told me, "Oh, I'm doing this. Oh, I'm" He never pushed
me to cover the story. Nothing like that. Okay. I'm just saying
I think I see little pushes and nudges and then him joining Aiden's
VC getting them to like vote on stuff or whatever or somebody
did like a vote saying he want I think 100%.
He wanted to push this along in this exact way. Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
I was literally in the chat. I was literally talking in his chat.
Yeah, I was there. But it was just kind of um it was kind of
disappointing. I had kind of like almost I don't know FOMO or
whatever because everyone else was very much into it.
Everyone else was very much into it in the bar. There were like,
you know, there were obviously um
male friends doing exaggerated dance moves together, like thrusting
each other and this sort of [__] to, you know, cheesy
2010s bangers. And when I see something like that, it's like
that is like, you know, I've been in situations plenty where,
you know, I've been with with groups that would be totally down
to do stupid [__] like that. Get into it, get drunk
and be into it like that. And that's always fun, you know, when
you're out with with the lads, you know, but Aiden was not that
type of guy. And they just like stood there like all these people
were all going crazy in this in this bar like everyone was having
so much fun. They just stood there the darkest corner of this
bar just like the jacket on up in his pocket.
I was just like okay. It was just so disappointing. It was just
so
Oh, Aiden just
man you I'll be real. People can pull that off. Okay. There are
people who exist who are like attractive enough, have a fashion
sense, and are like cool and can do that. Can do the like I'm
the dark mysterious guy at all times.
Aiden's a goofy. I don't know why he's trying to pull that vibe
off. Ain't nobody believe that vibe coming from Aiden. I'm sorry.
You don't get to be Patrick Baitman. You don't get to be You
don't even get to be the guy from Nightcrawler. Okay, you can't
pull that vibe off. That's not you. That's not who you are. You're
a goofy looking guy. You're You're literally Okay, I hate to
tell you this. It's your genetic destiny. You're okay. You're
a funny, goofy guy. You're not the dark, mysterious guy. You're
a funny, goofy guy. So, be funny and goofy and be like, have
a good time. Don't take yourself so >> I don't know what
I expected really. >> And I can be a bit like that sometimes.
Like, you know, if the music's not right and I'm not drunk enough,
I can be a bit like that sometimes,
but it's like, man, we we work a few drinks for that point. And
we just like, okay, I was ready to get started. So, that was
the first night. And then we meet we do meet dickers.
Yeah, that's just nothing really good happens from there. It's
just like dickers. We go in hotel.
We go and try and find booze. Can't find booze. We go back. >> Oh,
this is a this is a curse I wouldn't wish on my worst enemy.
Like how how could you even put that out there? We will not be
comparing Aiden to Richard Hania. We will not be making that
comparison here. That comparison will get you banned in this
chat. I do not curse him like that, okay? He can grow out of
it 100%. Please do not do that. That's [__] handed.
And I go to my Airbnb and that's it.
So that's the first night. So second night is New Year's. Okay.
So what happened for New Year's? Thank you for the $5 Jim. She's
saying Aiden is a brooding and sad drunk. Completely unsurprising.
Yeah, a little bit. Well, not not even really. It's just like
I don't know, man. He's like preoccupied with image. I think
a little bit. And I'll get into some of the argument we had afterwards.
I think shed some light on that. >> That's okay. That one
comment right there is a little a little bit calling the kettle
black. Queen gets away with it cuz he does it fairly effortlessly.
This is the thing. He does it fairly ef effortlessly. Okay. He
is he is carries very much about how he looks. He's consistently
cultivating his image. In fact, he talks about it all the time,
right? All the fashion stuff. This the little coffee cup, his
little espresso, right? That he wouldn't he wouldn't drink like
a he wouldn't drink like wine. He wouldn't drink like a rum and
coke. He's like a very distinguished Okay. But then also he could
have a beer with the lads. He could have a solid blogger with
the lads. I He's always cultivating his image. He finds it very
funny that a and I I get it a little bit if Aiden takes himself
way too seriously. There's nothing better. It's the pirate software
thing all over again, right? It's literally the pirate software
thing one to one is Aiden has an image of himself that he projects
and he wants his the image that he cultivates in his community
to be projected everywhere and every a lot of other people can
see that that's not really who you are. You don't get to be that
guy. You can't make me that guy, right? You can't do that. You
cannot make me that guy. Quimman doesn't force people to do it.
He just does it, right? He just he like he puts his image out
and he doesn't give any information away that like contradicts
it. Aiden is like there's a lot of contradictory information.
You're not like a super cool, dark, edgy, mysterious dude who's
just like brooding in the corner. Yeah. You there's your entire
like you've got all of your what do you call it? Um RFC stuff
where you're like the goofy little kid who everyone clowns on.
You don't get to do it. Okay. Tiny cup for tiny hands. No, it's
like a whole image. Queen's very like thoughtful about this stuff,
but he also knows that you can't force it, right? Yeah. But when
people say they see their young the younger self in him, they
mean like when I was 14 or 15 or 16. They don't mean when I was
20. That's not really what they
Quan said he eats microwaved eggs. Well, nobody's perfect.
I'm saying he uh he he's trying to cultivate like a very specific
image most of the time, I think. >> So, New Year's next
day. So, I'm raring to go New Year's really. >> I say that
as his as his camera perfectly slides out of focus and the whole
image is blurry. >> Like, you know, I've prepared mentally,
physically, everything for New Year's. I'm ready to have a real
good night out on New Year's. Also, my camera's out of focus.
Kind of annoying. There we go.
>> So, I'm mentally, physically prepared to have a good
night out on New Year's.
>> Actually, kind of just proving my point that he noticed
that instantly and fixed it, right, dude? Uh, >> I'm ringing
to go. But I know, okay, because before I left Aiden's hotel
the night before, Aiden, it was clear on his >> I'm sorry,
but I when I say that usually when he streams, this is literally
the stream he's looking at as well. Is you could tell he's not
looking at the camera, he's looking at his face on the stream.
Yeah. All the time. >> He was way past his limit. Okay.
He had overtaken me on drinks by far. Once I got him Rum Coke,
he had overtaken me and he was like knocking back and then Yeah,
I just knew that. And I knew it was uh going to be rough. And
I was drinking water and [__] like that as well.
I've actually I've always been for my entire adult life. I've
been a terrible terrible drunk like binge drinking uh who doesn't
drink water, doesn't eat. Yeah, that that's always been for that's
been for my entire adult life. And this is basically the first
time in my life where
I I have like, you know, managed to moderate my intake. And I
actually had a very bad drink experience a few months ago. So
I might have finally knocked it in. I actually managed to moderate
my drinking and drink water. And I was like, you know, it blew
my mind how much difference it made.
But Aiden was like totally past his limit. I was not doing any
of that.
It was already Claron's face. So, I did not have high hopes.
I'll be real. I did not have high hopes. But I was raring to
go. So, I'm ready and everything. I go and meet uh Soul Sciedy.
Okay. I go and meet Ske
uh near Aiden's hotel and we go for a
And I'm thinking, okay, maybe we have to
an hour or two until Aiden shows up. Maybe we have to kill an
hour or two. It's not the end of the world. >> Okay. So,
this is the next night when they're going for actual New Year's,
right?
That they're going to meet up for New Year's. He goes to meet
Soul Skiy. They're probably It's probably What did he even say
the time? It's probably like 7 8:00 p.m. or something. >> I
don't know what time I What time did I meet up with Sol Day?
See if I can figure out when that is. Let's have a look. Let
me see. Where was it?
I want to just I want to be >> cuz like I would expect
to if I was going out for New Year's with people, I'd expect
7:30 to 8:30 is the time. 8:30. I'm like, "Okay, you would want
to be hanging out by 8:30." 8:30 is about the time you're going
to go out for the evening. 8:30 or so is when you want to, you
know, you pregame like a little after work, you everybody goes
home, they do their thing, you go to somebody's place, you do
a little pregame, you you hang out for a little bit, and then
around 8:30, 9:00, you're like, "Okay, we're going to go to the
bars now, right?" I feel like usually, oh, depending on the night,
maybe sometimes you end up going out later if there's like a
house party, but I'd say, "Yeah, 9:00 you want to be on the town.
Any
later than that it's yeah I don't >> clear with how long
I probably met up with soul
half 4 I met up with soul okay half four in the afternoon I met
up with so I'm thinking maybe 2 hours maybe 6:30 Aiden takes
out and we can start pre- drinking at some pub
>> uh 6:30 is a little early but >> party I got tickets
for
>> so I was about 4:30 to go for a coffee and I'd say probably
about 2 hours pass and hellbent suggests eventually calling Aiden's
hotel and ask and trying to contact him through the hotel.
So me and S does it wait maybe we already dick by the point but
some point maybe dick but eventually we call hotel and we go
to pub we get through eventually Aiden wakes up we think okay
we're at this pub waiting for Aiden called him through the hotel
surely by now you clearly didn't party in college I'm talking
I'm yeah I'm talking about not in college talking about when
you're adults you got jobs and was was me talking about the job
a giveaway or what >> it won't be that long it won't be
that long we've gotten through to him so it can't be that And
we sat in this pub and we we've traed around London. Like me
and S have gone to walk around around area of London and walked
around like
in London. The pubs were all closed by 8 p.m. on a Friday when
I was there.
I'm talking you go at 8:00 p.m. cuz you want to have drinks.
You want to have drinks. You want to have a good time. You want
to hang out. You want to slowly build up how drunk you are. And
then at midnight you want to That's when things pop off, right?
What the [__] The whole city is like I don't know
if you ever been in London on New Year's, but when you're in
like the center, especially around embankment area,
anything around there is going to be like to it's like so locked
down, dude. Like you can't get anywhere good. You're trying to
like get somewhere down to the waterfront like um to cuz I I
wanted to see if we could get like towards where the fireworks
were going to be because I got the sense that we probably won't
have a good view from the actual boat thing we were going to.
Um but yeah, it's like all blocked off. It's like all blocked
off and it's like all packed. All the train stations packed around
there. Um, and we did manage to get seats in the pub like early,
but uh, yeah, it got busy quick. It got busy quick. So, yeah,
it weird. Like walked around, had a look at everything and it
was like totally packed. So, it was a little bit, you know, I
was a little bit like, oh, how's it going turn out? It's a little
bit stressful here. Someone's not showing up and you're waiting
for hours and it's busy as everywhere. It's like, dude, what
what is going to happen here? So, it is kind of like annoying
the whole time. Kind of put me on tilt that Aiden is not responding
to anyone. Not giving any [__] idea of what he's
going to do. Not giving any timeline.
That is really that is really tilting. So we like heranging his
hotel. Eventually we stop being able to get put through. So we're
just totally locked out and just have to hope for the best. So
we end up going there uh to this party we had tickets for.
And we get on and immediately
I'm thinking, okay, this is not quite quite what I was expecting.
It's not quite what I was expecting cuz it said permanently mored
boat. So you think it's going to be basically on land essentially.
So be like stable.
But it wasn't. It wasn't. It was like tipping and the decks were
frozen. So
So, as we go in to get drinks, it is like we try and walk over
to the bar. I think me and both saying like me and both saying,
"Dude, this is like giving me motion sickness. This is like >> Yeah.
How's that how's that going to be, dude? How do you how you going
to get a bunch of people drunk while making them seasick? That
seems like I hope they got good janitorial staff. >> This
is like bad. Thank you for the soul. Thank you." So, it was like
it was like tough immediately. It was real tough. I was like,
"Oh, right. This is going to be painful." Now, fortunately, as
the night went on, I actually did like even actually stopped
swaying and like or I stopped noticing or whatever, but it was
like totally fine.
Thank you. The two pound s Thank you. So, yeah, I'll get to that
in a minute. So, yeah, we got outside to have a smoke with our
drinks in hand, drinks down on the counter and they [__]
sliding around. I'm like having to find like the bit in the the
wood on the counter on the deck where it's like kind of chipped
and like there's a like, you know, more of a straight part that
you can just pull it down on and have it prop. It was like it
was bad. It was bad. And we're waiting for Aiden. It must be
like I don't know.
We must get there. >> DKF, you're reading way too much
into >> like 9:30 or something. I feel like probably around
the time 9, 9:30.
And Aiden, I think Helen shows up at some point in when Hellbent
shows up, uh, Soul is saying he wants to do this like opening
line to Aiden
where
uh, he's going to say, "Oh, it's it's icy out here, isn't it?
It's really I don't even know what the point was. I don't even
know why why this was a thing. I was like, you know, kind of
groaning hearing it.
It's just like, oh yeah, I see in reference to Aiden's Discord
chat. >> See, told you. I told you. I told you that this
soul Skippy guy was probably just like a lad. Like probably just
like,
listen, he's he's having a great >> I I see. Yeah.
So [laughter] like, okay, great stuff, man. And so sees Aiden
arrive and so be lands over there immediately in a frantic rush
to go and say this and then drops his line and then comes back
like that wasn't Aiden.
So he just went over some random person and just said this
wait [laughter] that's awesome.
I think that guy's a goes over. It's icy out here, isn't it?
What the you say to me, mate? Yeah, good one. Good one. >> Nobody
just Yeah, I know.
So that was that was awesome. That was great stuff. And so it
still hasn't arrived for ages.
Yeah. Ging for real. Ging IRL. There are a lot of moments like
that. There are a lot of moments like that. Sorry. One second,
guys. One second.
I'm I don't know about you guys, but when I meet people like
that in real life, I gas them up infinitely. I'm sorry if you're
making like bad jokes and I'm going to gas you up infinitely.
I'm going to make it me and me and you versus everyone else in
the group. Okay. I'm going to tell you that you are actually
funny and they they do just hate you. I'm just going to go hard
gassing those people up because it's so much fun. Okay, it's
such a great time. >> Drink my water and coffee. One minute.
I don't want to see you don't want you guys to see me, you know,
chucking water down myself if I embarrass myself. >> People
doing your Discord as well. Maybe
>> I'm coughing. Okay. Okay. >> No, no fool sip for
Cleveland. Okay. Just literally shuts the screen off. He didn't
want you to see what his hand looks like holding a regular cup
or regular bottle. Okay. He didn't want you to see that. He had
to kill He had to kill the stream. They got a screenshot once
of him drinking from a regularized water bottle. He's never been
able to live it down. Okay. Had to had to kill the fe. So yeah,
what was I saying? What was I up to? Where was I up to? So yeah,
so this random uh this retire random person. What happens next?
So then we're still waiting for Aiden. Aiden does not arrive
until
I think4 to 12. 12 I think it's 12 I think maybe 20 to 12. So
this is a New Year's party and he's not there until 20 minutes
until the like you know key moment of the party and the that
party only lasted until like 20 to 1 and then it moved into a
different place. So he was basically there for less than an hour.
Thank you for the $5 chimy mic in chat. That Gatorade bottle
screenshot did not Gatorade bottle.
Okay. [laughter] So Aiden's there for less than an hour. Okay.
>> Okay. Somebody get me the picture. Somebody's got to
get me the picture. >> We get to see some fireworks. We
don't get see the main display, which kind of sucks, but you
know, whatever. It's not the end of the world.
>> No, there's a regular size bottle. >> Yeah, Aiden's
there for like less than an hour. He doesn't even get to restart
drinking. You know, I'm immediately, you know, I am immediately
trying to get this guy drunk. I won't I won't make I'll make
no bones about it. I'm immediately trying to get Aiden as drunk
as possible, as quick as possible. Uh I think other people probably
had that same same sort of mindset. Thank the $5. Pig Fury, we
need more emotes. Can you give us a sip for that? No. Thank you
for the $5, Jenny. Thank you. So, yeah, that was a meet the goal.
So, moving to the next party. I'm getting like tequila shots
and [__] like that because he needs to catch up,
you know? He needs to catch up. And we're at this next party
or in fact, between this between these two parties, just to clarify
timeline, make sure timeline is clear. The >> was Aiden
taking the tequila shots? He didn't like regular he couldn't
drink beer, but he's going to have tequil
taken um between these two parties as we're walking from one
to the other. The opies photo is taken. Just you guys know the
timeline here. Okay.
So, we get to the next party. What's What happens here? What?
I want to make sure I miss >> Oh, I'm going to I'm going
to take
>> other than like the key things I'm already thinking
of. >> I don't know if you showed it yet. >> What
would I miss if I was going to miss something? Yeah. No, I think
it's just I think it's just the key part. So, we get to the second
party and you may have heard we met these two like >> women,
these two flat mates,
one of which is I think like Norwegian or some I don't even remember.
I think Norwegian.
This is the most anti-semitic thing I've ever seen in my entire
life. It's so up, but I have to show it on stream to properly
denounce it. Okay. Okay. I I don't know why somebody would make
this. I don't know why somebody would make this, but Jesus Christ,
dude. Why? Why? Dude, I think this would be a better comparison
as well if you if Could you find a like stonefaced like a expressionless
Richard Hania? Jesus. Okay. All right. Isn't this supposed to
be comparing two different images? Am I missing the gag? You
are not missing the gag. You get it. Jesus Christ, dude.
That's brutal.
Okay, this is what Queman's referring to as the upies photo.
Okay, I'd say people are joking. I don't know how tall Queen
actually is. I get the feeling he's like short. Okay. But people
are saying that this is him very much trying to control how tall
he looks. That he's like standing on top of something here. Okay.
And then the other photo, he's like using perspective to make
himself appear the same height as everybody else.
He's standing further from the camera to provide to give perspective.
Okay. He's like doing some Lord of the Rings clever camera work
himself. Okay. He's actually standing 15 feet behind these people.
You'd never know it. Okay. You'd never ever know it, but he's
actually they're they're across the street. No, I don't actually
know. Also, is the force perspective perspective thing would
you be closer to be taller? I literally don't know. I'd imagine
you have to be like closer, but it's fine.
Wait, this is an AI. No, this is an AI. I don't think so. Isn't
this AI? I don't think so.
Queen waterpick. Uh, let's see. Queen water pick. What is this?
Totally. Don't. Oh, dude.
You didn't even add an HTTPS on this. What are you doing, Verrain?
Hold on. Let's find it. Let's find it. Let's find it. Let's find
it. Let's find it. Dude,
that's not the picture I'm looking for.
That's not the picture I'm looking for. This is what we believe
to be a completely normalized Gatorade bottle. This is like,
you ever go to the store and get that standardized Gatorade bottle?
That's what we're looking at here. That's what we're witnessing.
There's a funnier picture of this that is photoshopped that I
was hoping we get, but it's fine. It's all good. It's all good.
>> And one is she's British, but she's the wife of an American
military guy. Okay.
And I think the first interaction,
Dude, this is >> Oh, they meet some they meet up with some
women at the bar. Okay. >> I don't want to talk, dude.
I don't want to repeat this, man. Holy. I literally don't want
to repeat, dude. Okay, I'm not I'm not going to talk about Okay,
I'm at the bar. I briefly talk about these girls. Okay, I might
go back over to the group and I'm like, dude, I had this cringe
interaction at the bar. I'm not going to go into detail. I don't
want to go to this into crazy detail interaction. This cringe
[__] interaction. I'm [snorts] I'm okay guys. Okay,
here's what happens. Okay, I'm at the bar. >> What are
the What are the details? >> And this girl says
I can't I can't remember what she says at first, but basically
she says, "Oh, how old are you?" I'm like, "26,
dude. What the?" She like, "Oh, how's your girlfriend?" I'm like,
"I I don't have a girlfriend."
And she go she goes, "Oh, good." I'm like,
then she says, "Um, I'm 27." She I'm like, "Oh, right." And she
looks at me like this.
Sorry. Did I say she said, "You don't look 26." That's what she
says when I say 26. She looks like this.
I'm like, "Oh, you don't look 27 either." Then like basically
walk off and go back to the grave.
And so I go back. I go to the group and I really like guys I
have the worst reaction. just like and as I'm talking about this
as I'm talking about this
999 as I'm talking about this that same girl walks back behind
me and I believe they're already talking to the American motor
that's a Norwegian girl okay she goes [laughter] over and starts
immediately talking to Soul okay right by like right behind me
as I'm talking to this group the group about what just happened
immediately talking to Soul in the smoking area and I'm like
dude what the hell
so we're talking about it
and basically this girl talks about her husband briefly and says
like sh to Aiden and he's like can you tell president like Trump
not to your president not to invade Venezuela you know my husband's
in the military or whatever is oh people trying people trying
like that
and we're like and wait no sorry first this girl basically says
to us that she's trying to get her friend laid that she's trying
to get her friend laid and says it's been a while I'm like dude
dude I can't man I literally can't I'm like cringing out my skin
the whole situation oh I didn't catch this part of the story
it's actually up that they went back to this person's is flat.
>> Damn. It's actually There's no way. Sorry, I'm I'm skipping
ahead. I'm >> so funny. It's like the whole thing is just
so funny cuz this like I'll be I'm cringing talking about it,
but honestly, this is like literally this whole situation. This
is the funniest way for me that this whole night could have gone.
It does make me laugh. Any awkward situation like that makes
me laugh. I remember it. It's like great, you know? So, [laughter]
how is this awkward? Cuz no one, Dude,
I'm not gonna say crazy. No one's interested, dude. No one's
interested. Okay, maybe I'm wrong. Maybe someone can correct
me. No one's interested. And certainly it ain't happening around
a bunch of online from YouTube. No one's going and spitting game,
bro. It ain't happening. It ain't happening. That's not what
anyone's there for. All right. Maybe Aiden was. Okay. I wasn't
there for that. I don't think was there for that. I could be
wrong. I could be wrong. It is a little up. You like go meet
some some people. Okay. You go somewhere and you explicitly just
try to get laid instead of hanging out and having a good time.
If it happens, it happens. But if you're like going to walk away
from your group and spend like an hour chatting some chatting
up some bird as they say in the UK. Okay, I think that's up.
I think you are kind of a loser
person. Person personally
that's what I think. Okay, so
the whole thing is just cringe. The whole thing is cringe and
funny as to me. I'm like laughing very I'm like you know the
whole time I'm like going from like pain expression to like grinning
to myself face because it's just like so [__] funny,
dude. Anyway,
what was I saying? What was I saying?
You should never be actively trying to get laid. No, that's not
true. Cuz guess what? Just like uh just like Queen just said,
that woman's out there actively trying to get laid. She's looking
for somebody to you can easily find somebody else who's like
that, right?
Who left her friends to do that? Nobody yet. Scream is saying,
"Oh, I don't think anybody wanted to do that." I'm like, "Oh,
yeah. Obviously, nobody wants to do that. You guys are there
to hang out, right? That's that's what it is." >> she wasted,
too. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. They're wasted.
So, we're there for a while and we're talking about this. >> Was
she like, "Okay, I don't know. She couldn't be like a 10 out
of 10." Okay, I'll put it that way. She couldn't She couldn't
have possibly been like a 10 out of 10. >> Perfect. This
is a perfect opportunity. I can't remember who I do it to first,
but I basically say, "Dickers, you need to go and say to one
of these girls that they're talking to.
Did you know this person is a famous YouTuber, here is their
channel?" [laughter] That's that's what I say to dickers, okay?
Cuz this is uh number one on my list. Okay, number one on my
list.
I'm failing. I'm Number one on my list of things to do on this
trip was that if the opportunity presents itself, someone is
talking to a woman, get their YouTube channel brought up to make
fun of them. That was my that was my number one priority all
out.
I think
that's funny. I hope he had like clips in mind for what he wanted
to show people. Like what did he what did he want to show people
precisely?
I think that I the idea of that is very funny to me, too. >> And
they end up both getting it done to them. So that was great.
>> Like imagine you're hanging out with K, I don't know
about these guys, Chud or something at the bar, Chudlo Logic,
and you like show the review intro to somebody. That the concept
of that feels hilarious to me. Like, oh, did you know this guy's
a famous YouTuber? Do you want me show you like a sample of his
content? You show Chud doing the the Holocaust streamable that
we watched. You show them that. That would be so funny. But anyway,
>> with Aiden, Aiden's the one that sticks. So I was kind
of, you know, wars back. Aiden's is on sticks talking to this
military wife. His dicker shows like Aiden's video when he was
like 13 where he's talking like an Uber or something like that.
He's like, you know, in his high situation an Uber day. Later,
the company changed its name from Uber Cab to Uber. The trend
of paying an Uber driver to pick you up and take you to your
destination has become a trend in the United States and the United
Kingdom, but there's been many occasions where Uber drivers have
gotten the passengers from hell. Many people find it quite scary
to get into a strange. >> That's real RZ right there. Okay.
Unfortunately for them, depending on the person, that could actually
work in their favor. That's a 731,000 subscriber YouTube channel.
They might automatically assume that Aiden is rich and like want
to that might actually be R in Aiden's case. Okay. >> Car
and allow him to >> Oh, whoops. I don't want to keep watching
this. >> I was [__] sorry. Everyone's like,
you know, joking about that. It's still very funny. It's still
very funny. It's all a good laugh. Yeah. Nothing. It's not a
big deal to be honest. It's not like super embarrassing. I'm
trying not to make it sound like it was like this huge like mortifying.
It really was not like a big deal. Um, you know, everyone kind
of rolled everyone was having fun. It wasn't a big deal.
And then as we're about to leave, these uh two girls invite us
to an after party at their
And so I'm sort of like, well, this is funny as it is, so you
know, [__] it. Why not? We'll go to the after party.
We'll go to the after party.
And there's a little bit of disagreement and grumbling. I think
Hellbent's kind of grumbling. I think this is part of what starts
annoying Aiden other than other than just Hellbent being Hellbent.
If you've seen Hellbent on streams, you probably know you'll
know what Hellbent's like in real life. Okay, it's not much different.
It's uh you know, you you understand why Aiden is calling annoying.
Okay, I'm not going to be just cuz we're going to talk about
the argument that's been happening since. And I just want to
make it clear. I understand Raiden's coming from when he says
Helmet is [__] annoying. I get what he's saying and
I get what you
but a lot of women are like that. Okay, I'm going to be real.
I'm going to be real. H >> a lot of women are like that.
It's just Yeah, especially women, they try to be funny and that
has that has ups and downs. Okay, that is the ups and downs.
>> I thought it was so cool how Queen came out and totally
like rode for Hellbent and protected Hellbent. That was so awesome.
He's like the perfect feminist.
>> Okay, keep watching. So, Hellb's making like jokes that
obviously aren't landing with Aiden. Obviously, you know, not
landing particularly, but yeah, it's funny. Who cares? Who cares
if the Who cares if someone's jokes aren't landing? You're in
a situation like this and you're getting like actually mad. >> I
just like like that's how you know it's banter between him and
Hellbent that when push comes to shove, he's willing to totally
throw Aiden under the bus just to make sure Hellband is kept
safe. Okay. That's the kind of that's the kind of guy Queman
is. All right. He just loves Hellb.
That's how it is. By the way, Aiden should be running with that
if you if you want a counter narrative. Okay.
This guy's going to tell you that hellband isn't even annoying
because someone who's making jokes aren't landing. You're not
just rolling with it and having fun. Anyway, you're like genuinely
like such a loser. I truly can't uh express enough. This is going
to be a common pattern. This is a common pattern. It's like similar
vibe I got from a lot of the motor stories is that Aiden like
Perry is like this eccentric character and Aiden's just not rolling
with it in any way. It's like,
dude, imagine getting like hammered and then showing up at like
a London
like street food vendor at like 2 a.m. getting like a a street
meat hot dog with Purple Perry Gaming. Okay, that would be a
time and a half. That'd be a story you would never tell people,
but you would treasure. Okay.
And Aiden passed on that opportunity at least in Malta. Okay,
maybe he'll get that chance in London. >> Play the straight
man a bit. Get some. >> Yeah. Street meat as in I don't
know if this is I don't know if this is pork. I don't know if
this is beef. I don't know if this is like straight cats. Okay.
This hot dog's made with something. Might be straight cats. I
don't know. And that's part of the fun
satisfaction out of the entertainment that the comedy of the
situation you're
>> Oh, you would get kebabs in London like Donaire or something.
You get some Middle Eastern fair. Yeah. Falafel. Donaire. Something
like that. Yeah, for
Is that really that hard? Is that really that hard? Are you so
preoccupied with the idea of being like, you know, awesome awesome
YouTubers there awesome YouTuber friends that you just can't
possibly handle that guys. I need to grab another drink. Okay,
two seconds. >> What a coincidence him trying to get laid.
What's her number? Can you guys imagine what DMs Perry would
have leaked >> Quick quick drink break. I don't know why
I don't just skip through it. I get eased after party. That's
cool. I don't blame him. You know, I won't go to party. I want
to keep hanging out with people because it's funny. Um, but you
know, I get the sense Aiden that's cool. He's getting he's out
and getting after party. That's awesome, isn't it? So we go there
and we sit down. No, sorry. Wait, I should I should be more let's
not skip any steps here. We get there. It is like have you guys
seen a tackle block? We don't know tackle block. You know the
you know like how >> is that trade in a tackle block is
like that style basically you know flats. It's awesome. It's
like you know proper London you know proper London.
>> It was awesome. Okay. I was like so happy Aiden was
going. I was so happy Aiden was there. You know, it was like
actually actually got to show something authentic for once in
this trip. Save the $5 shim.
Oh man, they be pissed me robust on her toes. Pied. I was I was
so I was so happy. And we go in, go into the living room,
turn the lights on. Aiden sits down on the sofa, looks to her
side, and sort of jumps up. And there is, you've already heard
this already. [laughter] There is a girl laid across the sofa
asleep on the sofa
that Aiden did not see as he walked in. And then and then sat.
>> What a cool edgy thing. Aiden sitting down on the sofa
without looking where he's going and then jumping up like a cat
like Emir and Misk just touched her abdomen. Okay. >> Down
on the legs of as he sat on the sat on the couch. She doesn't
wake up. She doesn't wake up and we s like you know sit around
like laugh about that. We like sit down like the other sofa and
then the girls who fight come in and they uh come and wake her
up basically and they're like oh you know we told our other flat
mate that she can have people over if she wants but just let
us know and she didn't let us know and we could use in the living
room and other [__] like really we could just left.
totally fine to leave, but they were obviously insistent on this,
I guess. So, they send basically like after 10 minutes, shepherd
her upstairs
and send her away. Um, which quite funny. Then we sit down and
there's not it's not like crazy eventful but basically we're
just sitting around talking making jokes and stuff and this uh
the girl who was sort of um who spoke to me at the bar and then
spoke to so was like literally you know kind of ping ponging
like backwards and forwards between people and then ends up leaving
and probably assumably given how long she's gone for throwing
up. So that happens
and while she's gone we're like you know realizing that talking
about that and Helman's sort of going like before we realize
that I think Helman sort of going so go do your thing so like
so like that and Aiden's getting like annoyed with this I think
it's just funny I think it's like funny and I start sort of mimicking
it taking the because I can't tell I can't tell I don't think
anyone else can tell either where the hell how serious hell went
event is being whether she's doing it to deliberately just like
[__] with soul and make a joke or whether she like
actually thinks this is like going to happen and s's going to
like go and you know hit on girl whatever Go rap. Just go. Go
do your thing. Go. Go. You look like a go. We're going to do
something like no one can read. So I just make fun of it a little
bit and just keep going to so so
going on. So
and that's all just funny to me. That's all just funny. And then
they're just doing which Oh, I threw a poll up in the chat. I
just want to know how much I can skip through. If I can skip
through everything or anything cuz I there's a poll in the chat.
If you're listening, go fill up the poll. It seems like actually
most of you guys have I literally can't skip. I was thinking
about skipping a little through this but we probably need to
get decent amount of this to have context for later. So >> like
you know this girl a military wife like I don't even know. She's
like climbing up on top of the radiator and like a knee is like
held up the wall. She like dude what is going on? And eventually
we we basically go to leave and as I go to leave I'm about to
go to the toilet and I open the door and that military wife girl
is curled over in a ball on the toilet just like face down.
Great. So I can't go for
leave. Basically, you know, we I go
the night really kind of ends there. I think that's >> Well,
hold on. That's the military wife, though. She's not the one
who's trying to get laid. It's the Norwegian girl who wants to
get laid.
Uh, how many for another hour? I think it's I think it's the
full eight subs. We'll get through a decent amount of this even
if we don't make it. But it would be the full eight to get through.
I could do six for the $30, but I'm not going to >> main
events from the from New Year's Eve. Um, okay. And I'm like totally
wiped and I'm asleep like a full 24 hours and she's totally so
Aiden. So yeah, the next time we go meet, did she leave her in
the bathroom? Yeah. Yeah. What the hell? I told her friend she
was there, but I wasn't doing that. So that's all the main events
from New Year's Eve.
Show the We can do it anyway. We can do it now. I'm just explaining.
I'm
So Oh, in between that when we get back from the afters, me,
Hell, Bent, and Soul watch Doctor Who. And they're now Doctor
Who Chris Rockson fans. So I converted them. by showing them.
Okay. So, that was that was huge. That was
So, that's a successful trip as far as I'm concerned. You know,
Iraq if he wanted to, but in London. >> That's all he wants
to spend his time doing, like laying in a hotel room or
>> going to Italian restaurants. We'll get to that. >> So,
we end up settling on the British >> More ripping on Aiden
>> and I lock us in for the British Museum. I think I achieve
it. >> Okay. Sorry. He does talk about how he's trying
to get Aiden to go out again. Aiden is like resistant to going
out and finally Queen gets him to go out by saying let's go to
>> giving him a set time and booking it for and making
sure he has to shop for a set time. I think that's how I achieved
it and so he couldn't flake. But yeah, we decided to go to the
British Museum
and we go in and we're like walking around. Oh, sorry. Before
we go to a coffee shop beforehand, we go to a prep because uh
we couldn't find like a half decent coffee shop end up being
a prep which was, you know, disappointing. But hey, and we're
I'm looking on my phone the digital guide for the British. Dude,
I will say [clears throat] I it's particularly bad for me what
Aiden's doing because he's got like a friend who is trying to
show him London. Like Queman likes being British, shockingly.
Okay, he likes being British. He wants to show you what's awesome
about Britain or awesome about London or whatever the right like
it's so easy. All you got to do is just say, "Hey, what do you
want to show me? What's like cool about London? What do you like
about Britain?" And then you just go and do the thing. It's like
so not hard. How How is it difficult to just show up and like
have fun? Somebody's like, "Oh, I like being British. I'm going
to show you some cool
Just go have fun, man." >> And the only tour guide thing,
the only tour booklet thing on the digital app that's free is
the one about like colonization and should be stolen. It's obviously
free on there. So, they're not like, you know, disadvantaging,
you know, whatever the [__] It was like it was like
immediately obvious to me. So, I was like, "That's brilliant.
Let's go. Let's go." So, I look at it. So, I'm scrolling through
the
>> and I see what do I see? A beautiful exhibit. beautiful
what what appears to be a vase or a jar of some kind called the
the Somali milk vessel it's labeled as and I'm like that's it
we have to see the Somali milk vessel if there's one thing that
I that I am going to the British Museum for today
it's the Somali milk festival okay that that's what I'm there
for
cuz like why the [__] not man why the [__]
not
so
we go in there and we start sort of walking around and we go
into the like Greek and and Roman exhibits and all this and just
like, you know, I don't really like this. I've seen all this
before. I've seen all this before. I've been willy. I've seen
this before. It's I mean, I suppose so. You've seen some of this
stuff before, but you're not interested like what the specific
things are. Like I I can look at I I've been to like, you know,
wait, wouldn't the British Royal Museum or the British Museum
I don't know why I said royal. Wouldn't that have like way different
Roman stuff. Like if you go to Italy, you're not going to see
a bunch of artifacts from like early Britain. Like, couldn't
you get the history of like the the like Celtic
uh what do you call like Celtic conflicts? All like the history
of them coming into Britain. It's all stuff we stole. Oh, is
it wait in the Roman Why wouldn't the Roman museum or sorry,
why wouldn't the Roman section have all the history of the Roman
the Romans like inter ah invading Britain? That's what you would
want. You don't want the they stole. You want the from the Romans
coming and invading Britain and that story.
Well, I understand the British Museum is full of a ton of stolen,
but I just wouldn't think the Roman section would be.
I would have thought that's from all the colonial uh colonization
stuff. Yeah, that's that that would be the whole point of what
you would do. Yeah. Okay.
Where have I been? Where's the museum or something? I I think
we were talking I think I've been to the Imperial War Museum
as a kid but I don't remember like so I've seen like a lot of
the stuff like seeing the shapes but I'm not going to remember
like all the details that are on the signs and you know all this
different [__] that show there and I don't remember
that the intricacies of that and that's like the fun of going
to the museum though is going there and appreciating these things
and learning a bit about them and you know thinking oh that's
the significance of this so I see what the significance of this
is. It's like you know maybe as a kid I wouldn't have had any
appreciation for that. Maybe even as a 20-year-old like Aiden
I would have had any appreciation for that. My understanding
was Aiden was up for that and I was up for that. I'm at a point
now, where I'm up for that, where I want to go to a museum. I
want to go look at the in the museum and read about it. That's
what I want to do. And it's not a big deal. Just to be clear
that Aiden wasn't into it. And I was happy to leave. I want to
leave. We were, you know, I was there to hang out with Aiden
in London. Really, I'm just saying I just it just feels like
he doesn't actually appreciate the the museum. He doesn't actually
appreciate the uh you know, going there.
It's like he appreciates the idea of telling people that he's
the type of guy who goes to museums. Like he wants to be able
to tell women or tell his YouTube chat that he goes to museum.
>> Wants the image. wants the image of being the guy who's
like, "Yeah, I went to the museum and I saw something really
cool that made me think about something different." He wants
a stole a whole story attached to it. He wants to be able to
like create a narrative about himself with it, but he doesn't
actually like doing it. Like Aiden, oh man, I think they comment
on his or I think Quimman comments on his wine drinking as well
that like Aiden only drinks wine because he wants to look like
a guy who drinks wine. Like he doesn't actually like wine. Wine
is gross and bitter to him, but he wants to look like a guy who
drinks wine.
So, he drinks wine. It's like, yeah, it's okay. I like I get
it a little bit. That's the That's
what I think is like a lot of people's problem with Aiden is
it's just he he's super conscious about his image, like self-conscious
about his image, and he wants to cultivate a certain image, but
that image isn't who he is. And so, it's like I get wanting to
be selfcon or being self-conscious, wanting to cultivate an image,
but you got to be that guy. and he picked like an image to cultivate
that is just not him at all. Uh Juice 131, thank you for the
five months. Appreciate it, dude. >> Museums enjoys museums
and be seen as a sort of person who enjoys museums but doesn't
want to actually doesn't actually enjoy going to the museum.
Thank you for the $5 chimy. Thank you. He appreciate plays all
hydra. Yeah, for real. For real. He saw this on Fortnite. He
saw the build of this on Fortnite. So that that's how it sort
of felt. So we do go we go through a bit more of the museum though.
We go through the enlightenment part. That was really cool as
well, dude. The enlightenment exhibit that got there. That was
epic. And I'm like mad as hell cuz we got the the whole Assyrian
exhibit is like shut off.
And this is the other thing like this how you know Ed is just
like not into any of it at all. So we go to the Chinese part.
Okay. I'm going around anything I see that looks like a sword
or some [__] like that. I'm like I want to see what
that is. I want to look at that. Or like any statue I want to
see what that is. I want to look at that. Aiden's just like looking
around. Look around looking at [__]
Any statue I want to see what that is. I want to look at that.
Aiden's just like Aiden POV.
Aiden POV. Amazing.
Yeah, look at you. >> You need to take this. I want to
look at >> Hold on. A just like
you need to take this face and put it on Patrick Baitman as he's
walking through the hallway with the headphones on. >> Look
around. >> Right. Just slow down. >> I want to look
at that. >> Sorry. I'm going to do it one more time.
You put this face on Patrick Baitman as he's walking with like
the headphones,
>> you know.
Not even going over to him.
It's like, dude, you don't want to see the Chinese ceremonial
swords. Are you >> I feel like I feel like Aiden's 100%
the kind of guy who'd be like, there's a better YouTube video
on this. This there's a better you there's a YouTube video that
explains this better. Feel like that's Aiden be like >> so
disappointed. It was like not disappointed, but like yo,
>> it was like
enjoy this. Just don't enjoy this.
>> It is toddler behavior. It's like hardcore toddler behavior
like you know. And then yeah, so we go to the Assyrian exhibit
and that's like all shut off and I went mad as hell about that.
That was really disappointing. That was actually disappointing
cuz uh they had like you know these huge the stone faces and
cool as hell and it was all it was all shut off. Sucked. And
then we
dude those sneak up on him every time. One of these guys one
of these guys the Easter Island faces these kinds of deals. Yeah.
Yeah. Cool. Very cool.
Everyone wants to see those. Obviously, >> we [clears throat]
find the Africa
and we search far and wide. Okay, I'm going to drink a cam. >> Wow,
his hands look almost normal size there. I wonder where he found
the filter for that. >> We search far and wide for the
Somalian milk vessel. Somali milk vessel,
but just cannot find it. It is nowhere to be seen. Part of it's
closed, so I'm assuming it was in there. >> That's brutal.
>> But the Somali milk vessel was just nowhere there. So
the one thing, the one objective that was set for this museum
>> to see the Somali milk vessel,
which
failed on
it was. Now, what I did get to see I did get to meet the board,
guys. Okay, I did get to meet the board. Okay, I don't know if
you guys know about this. This guy might even be the chairman.
I'm not 100% sure. I will start showing photos >> Uh oh,
this is Easter Island statue
>> Rapanoui
huge. >> There we go. >> I'm at the board. Aiden
wasn't even impressed by this thing. Aiden wasn't even impressed
by this. You could you could show this Aiden guy anything and
you would not be impressed. Dude, >> you have no idea how
you have no idea how ecstatic I was to see one of these.
I was like literally I had to take a picture but it sounds Aiden
had a board meeting. They were $5. Chinese pops don't line up
with the era of this ultraic Chinese time period. Actually, he
cares about nothing else. So true. So
So yeah, I was like literally so happy to see this. Aiden wasn't
impressed.
Thank you for the $2.
>> Yeah, he's not impressed by the board. Lot of detail.
They didn't want didn't want me to the board. They didn't want
to meet the chairman. But yeah, so that was a bra museum trip.
So we end up leaving. So then >> Oh man, it's like not
too much detail. It's like the exact right amount of detail,
but it's taking forever. >> Aiden goes back to his hotel.
I briefly go back. So I go back and then we basically we meet
back up for the meal for the Italian meal. Me, Helen, and Aiden.
Fifth. But I will say, okay, I only raised serious objection
15 minutes before. Aiden is right about that. I only suggest
like, let's do something different 15 minutes before. However,
throughout conversations in the last 2
I had said to Aiden, it is a waste of time going to an Italian
restaurant in London. That's so pointless. Find something like,
what should I eat? British food, roast dinner, toad in the hole.
It's like, well, no, there's like, you know, there's restaurants
in Britain that well, they don't necessarily do like specific,
you know, stereotypical British food. They do like
>> uh I I challenge you to find a bet a place that would
serve better Pakistani fair than London, England. Okay, you just
whatever what do they like in Pakistan? Whatever they like there,
they're going to do that. Second best in the world in Britain.
Okay. In in London itself. That's what you should be looking
for. >> Beef cooked in a nice way. You know, you can go
somewhere that's like a little bit or fish and chips. Exactly.
>> Like could I get could I get a lamb? A whole lamb like
the lamb's head. Can we get that like lamb skull? Can we get
that? I feel like you could get that in London, right? For sure.
No. Bmpton is is terrible Indian cuisine. Okay. The low cast
Indian cuisine. Not terrible. Tastes good. Low cast Indian cuisine
is Bmpton. London is Pakistani fair. Okay. >> Exactly.
We could go and get some fish and chips or something like, you
know, there are more London specific places that you could go.
Or >> Name me a British meal. Um,
bangers and mash
would be my go-to for naming a British meal. Bangers and mash.
>> Even and this is what I end up suggesting a curry house.
You know, it's almost like it's a bit of a joke, but is like
a bit more it makes a bit more sense at least.
Thank you for the $10 DK. Aiden was waiting for a scene at his
favorite zong burst and says we take him back when colonized
by brain kang. Hey, whatever. So, yeah, I had mentioned to him
numerous times before it's a waste of time, but I did being fair
to him. I only said let's do something else like 15 minutes for
his reservation. So to be fair, at that point it was a bit too
late. Fair enough. I wasn't going to, you know, I didn't kick
up a fuss or anything. I don't want it to seem like Aiden. It
should have, you know, done something different at that point.
Obviously shouldn't have a deposit and all this.
But we go to the Italian restaurant and of course he's being
mad neurotic cuz we just take him to chill up
even though he's the worst person to organize with. Well then,
you know, at the actual restaurant, it's first of all, it ends
up being mid. It's like mid as hell. It's like pretty small portion
sizes because it's meant to be like me like a selection thing
or whatever. And it was like kind of cold when it came out. I'm
not going to lie, it was like kind of cold. So, it was just whatever.
I can't remember what I what I had what it was called, but it
was like some beef thing and it was like it just tastes like
any old [__] beef, you know?
It's just any old beef. Yeah. The main focus of this Italian
restaurant to be honest for me was the the awful table manners
and manners in general on display from Aiden and just general
American behavior was going on.
So, we get there and Aiden has already ordered starters. He's
ordered like some cheesy garlic bread thing and some fried bread
thing
and that shows up effectively $20 from the southside. Happy New
Year. It should take him into a no-go zone
and that shows up arrive.
to try and cut through this cheesy garlic bread. It's like a
it's like a spread out thin dough. He's reaching over his his
plate and everything to like saw through it. and he's getting
like arms leverage like soaring on it and it's like shaking around
in the middle of the table and it's like man can we
just like let's think about what we're doing a bit let's limit
our motion dig in with the fork try and separate you know really
drive in I will say the knife sucked the knife was pretty blunt
the knife sucked but there just didn't seem to be even any attempt
from him to if they're bringing you out like a piece of bread
why aren't they bringing you a bread knife is there a restaurant
where they do that where they serve like bread that you have
to cut up and they don't bring you a knife to cut the bread Cuz
you you don't just want like a steak knife. You don't just want
like a butter knife. They're literally knives made for cutting
bread explicitly.
The places where you tear with your hands. Sure. But then they're
going to tell you that or it's going to be obvious you tear with
your hands. Oh, I've had I've had Italian restaurants in Canada
where they they basically bring you out a big loaf of bread and
they'll either pre-cut it for you or they'll just bring it out
with like a knife and like there's like butter in the tray. But
I those are kind of nice restaurants. So, I don't know. Maybe
that's like a different kind of thing. I've experienced it a
few times >> Do something a bit more,
you know, put together. So that's the first thing. And then when
Aiden makes an order one time, he doesn't say please. So I'm
like, Aiden, please. He's like, please. Oh god. He's like [__]
whining at me like a [__] child.
And then I think they put down the menu and Aiden says, "Thank
you." I think I forget to say thank you. As they put down like
a drink menu. It was Sorry, it was a dessert menu that Aiden
asked for. I didn't I asked for I said no. Okay, thank you. But
they just bring over three menus, put them down. like, "Oh, thank
you." I didn't say thank you because I just, you know, hadn't
even registered the dessert menu. He was going down. I asked
for the dessert menu. And then he goes at me, "Say thank you
when someone say to me." He does even like not even with any,
you know, tacked or anything. He just like literally is like
raging like say thank you when someone get something to eat.
Like dude, [laughter] I'm not even order anything here. I'm not
even order anything here. Take a That might have been the point
where Queen decided he was going to try to laden from this. That
might have been the exact point where he's like, "Oh, you're
going to throw that back at me like that?" Okay.
Okay. I see how it is. >> I'm just like asking for the
bare minimum. And then he's drinking out of his wine glass and
he slams it on the table and he's like, "Ding." I'm like, "Dude,
can you just please like you've got like no like a total ape,
dude. It's so bad." And yeah, I'm unconvinced that Aiden enjoys
wine. I'm going to be real. I'm totally unconvinced Aiden enjoys
wine. He claimed to me wine's like the only alco I can drink.
Absolutely enjoys Ramen Coke way more. He drinks that way easier.
But he takes ages to get through it. And then by the time he
left, he had left like a bunch of his drink. So I end up nicking
a bunch of it. I end up just I tip out his drink into into my
glass after he leaves and finish it off. I do the food as well.
I finish the food too,
>> Dude, I normally I'd be like, "Oh, I don't know about
that." Not maybe not the food, but dude, you buy alcohol at a
restaurant. You're paying like $20 a glass for wine. It's crazy
out here. Okay, you wasting You're wasting alcohol you bought
at a restaurant. That's
That's how you know his parents are rich. Okay,
you you're wasting
wine or or alcohol you bought at a restaurant. You out of your
mind
in a salt hotel. And so I think during this some point during
this meet in this um meet up for the the Italian meal. I think
Aiden does sort of say that HB's like annoying and he's sick
of him
But it was just like you know
I see what he's saying. I totally you know I I find him as annoying
as the next person. Okay, trust me. I see what he's saying. But
it's just not bad enough to where it warrants sulking a whole
trip and making a big deal out of it. Especially when Helwin
is nothing but nice to everyone. Helvin is literally at no point
Hel is like help, you know, helping and trying to find his rings.
She gave him this USSR medallion thing from the Olympics or whatever
that he lost immediately.
Oh, that was where I was going to um that's where I was going
to make something up. I was going to say some like you know for
a fact that Aiden just threw that in the trash.
You know, he just threw that in the trash. He didn't actually
care. He was like, "You hellbent your gift." And he's just like
in the garbage.
But now, now I think they found it, so I can't even make that
up. >> He's like, you know, running around after people
offering places to say stay. Soul's never taken a train before,
so she has to help him book everything and then shop, meet him
at the train station, and he's never been in London or a big
city, so she has to show him around everywhere and all this.
So, it's like running around after everyone basically being,
you know, totally happy to mother these people.
And then Aiden is just like a complete prick just throwing it
back in her face and like over the most minor like social faux
piles that amount to you know they shouldn't be any more than
just like humorous little moments that make you think okay this
person's a little autistic
it really should not be any bigger of a deal than that
but he just has to sulk about it and throw up such a fit over
it. So yeah, that's been the whole last couple days basically
is uh Aiden and Discord throwing a fit over over a helmet being
slightly annoying.
So we we um we spoke about that briefly last night that's been
spoken on par stream earlier.
Aiden's made his snow. Everyone everyone hopefully knows Aiden's
just like totally rotting in his hotel. Um you know doing Oh,
what else happened? What else happened? Let me think. Where is
it? There's probably more that I'm forgetting to say as well.
Sorry things said that were like wrong. Guys, yeah, this is my
um this isn't upies by the way. This is my real height. This
is my real height. I have very disproportionately long legs.
There's no obvious here. That's a lie. I have disproportionately
long legs. I have to use people to >> You get um you get
an idea for who these people are just from the picture.
Like I think you you can you can sense pretty accurately who
each of these people are from the picture alone. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Because [__] >> bone issues long legs.
>> Okay guys maybe.
>> Yeah. I think about the other picture,
Stylo I think said somewhere only regular smoker is the only
one not smoking in that picture. You can just tell he knew this
was not hard. Like I did see I did see Aiden,
you know, Aiden was like, you know, >> okay. Jesus. >> I
don't know, man. Trying to farm, do you know what I mean? >> He's
trying to look. >> Yeah, Aiden Aiden is trying to cultivate
like a cool image
and it's like, brother, you you goofy.
I I don't think if Aiden really wants that like cool guy image,
he can probably never have that in these communities, right?
Like he just he's always gonna be that like annoying squeaky
little brother in these communities. I don't think he'll ever
get to farm like a oh, I'm really cool.
I don't think that'll ever be who he is.
So, I don't know. If he wants to be that guy, he's probably going
to find somewhere else to do it. But I don't like it's going
to be just as gay of him to do it anywhere else, right?
He could. No. No. Canadian caller. People are always going to
throw back all of his old clips, all of his old like cringe moments
from all of his old dramas with the commentary people, right?
People are always going to throw that [__] back in
his face.
He'd have to go somewhere else. If you can't integrate like who
you are, if you can't like h laugh at yourself, this is the worst
community to be in. And to like try to cultivate a I'm really
cool and and awesome image.
Like, yeah, the whole point of like this these communities is
like taking people who think too much of themselves and setting
them straight. You're never ever going to be able to do that
here. I don't think like it would take such a drastic change
in behavior for such a long period of time. It's like goofy.
Yeah. Like to be clear, he would be gay for doing that anywhere
else,
but he wouldn't get caught for it necessarily in these communities.
He's just caught and he can't do it, right? Like it's over. Cool.
You sure look cool. I was like, "Okay,
I'm not really I'm not really interested in taking photos. Still
look cooler." And this high five. That's very gay. Thank you
for the $5. Thank you. You look like you're smoking, not because
of habit. Because you press the other cool. I'm not I'm not smoking
the images. What do you mean? What do you mean? >> Don't
think Quimman is cool. I mean, his viewers think he's cool. And
unfortunately for Aiden, Aiden's going to make his viewers think
that Queman's cooler than him, too. Which I don't know if that
was what he was intending to do. Yeah. See, this is the thing.
So, after my argument with Aiden or during my argument with Aiden
last night and after something he said to Harry earlier, I get
the sense that Aiden's less interested
in
uh going out and doing stuff and more interested in sort of like
the abstract idea of being able to having said he's done stuff,
say he's done stuff. That's what I mean. I think right bad bad
phrase on that, but he just he just want that's all he wants.
He wants to be able to say, "Oh, yeah, man. I went to London
and I hung out with all these other YouTubers, man." That's what
he wants to be able to say. And because Hellbent is is just like
some who doesn't make him look cool in social situations.
That's a problem. That's a problem. You know, it's like every
everyone else has something that pull into him. Helmet has doesn't
have this the factor that lets pull our weight.
Oh yeah. Also
also though could nobody think to include Hellbent in like a
picture or
Hey guys, we're hanging out with like Hellbent. It's like the
three of us.
Did nobody think, "Hey, maybe we can get Hellbent in one of these
photos so she could have like a memory as well." I I personally
am like, "What the Dude, that's kind of [__] up.
She's like hanging out with you guys. She's not in any of the
photos. You guys didn't take Oh, she didn't want to be on cam."
Okay, if she didn't want a photo taken of herself, then that's
fine.
No, no, no, no. If If she just didn't want to be in the photos,
I do get it. But a little bit I'm like sitting here, I'm like,
"Dude,
you get what?" I understand like not all of them or I understand
wanting like a lad's only photo, but you couldn't get her in
like one just to just to pretend.
>> Oh, oops. Let's go back. >> Because he just doesn't
seem to he doesn't seem to enjoy anything. He just doesn't actually
enjoy anything. Yeah. When I was at the British Museum in London.
Yeah, exactly, man. Like you can see two years from now when
I was at the British Museum in London. It's like
he he didn't look at anything. He just wandered around and
did I was just picking on Hellbent to divert attention from him.
Well, here's the problem. Okay, make there's no bones about it.
Okay, I realized this. I was He had a very legit German complaint
with Perry about Perry not having boundaries. All right.
He had a very legitimate complaint with Perry not having boundaries.
But it's become clear to me
that's not really the
Okay. Open invitation for Aiden to come to Canada. Okay. Me and
Aiden will hang out and we'll see if he can find a way to not
be weird if he comes here. Okay. We go do something. You hang
out. We'll see. Cuz at three times if three different groups
of people in three different countries find you weird. think
you're like a socially awkward.
>> That's kind of curtains right there, isn't it? >> Issue.
That's not really the issue. And that's that's a scapegoat issue.
That's something he's just blaming for for the broader issue,
which is that he's a
loser. He's just like a rich kid loser who just wants to be able
to say he's done stuff and post images that make him look hard
on social media and not actually do anything or experience anything
or have any fun. Just mad he got or walked by a 30-year-old Russian
vet. He needed to level up as a man. Okay. So, what else happened,
man? What else happened? The poser allegations are damning. He
was It's just like posing, man. It is. It is. So yeah, I've seen
people say they were expecting me to be the most antisocial one
on this trip. People I've seen viewers saying that was not the
case. Was not the case. Was not the case. Now I will say I'm
slight slightly asocial sometimes. Like for instance, I was when
we were at this after party and these, you know, two women were
being kind of weird. I was in a group chat laughing about it,
talking about what was going on as opposed to actually engaging
with it because it was
funny [snorts] for me as an observer than to be part of it. And
how they how' they let him get away with this? How' they If you
wanted to like, bro, how are you getting totally farmed by Queen
is Aiden? You don't bring this up that like Queen's on his phone
in a group chat talking about instead of interacting with human
beings. That's why somebody I think somebody in my chat said
Quean was the most normal one and I'm like no no no
don't say that. You could say Queman was not the weirdest, but
the most normal? I don't think so. I doubt >> I found so
I found it quite I found it quite funny. say, "Yeah, but again,
but again, there's nothing wrong with that." And he doesn't necessarily
paint himself that way. Okay? He's not concerned. He's just like,
"Yeah, I was a little bit weird. I was a little asocial." He
says it, right? That's it. Takes the wind out uh wind out of
anyone else's sales who wants to attack him with it. He just
he just says it and he's like, "That's that is what it is." I'm
just sitting. I was just
going to say what we talk about. To be fair, actually, that's
not even true. I did, you know, I tried to promise some conversation,
but it just dies quick. you don't have like a whole lot of issue
with someone or a whole lot there then you know the conversation
does kind of die eventually
like whatever
>> I am I the only person who sees this totally differently
like oh if there's no interest if there's I feel like if there's
no interest you could just say increasingly like deranged things
until they react and think something's funny or walk away and
I don't mean like not rap jokes or some [__] like
that you just start whatever weird you've been thinking about
recently you start bringing that up I didn't have a good example
off the top of my head. Hold on. I'm trying to think of like
some innane thought I was having somewhat recently. Oh, I can't.
I can't off the top of my head. I feel like I I can't. But you
just like start asking weird questions. You ask them what kind
of content they watch. What do you What do you do with your time?
You watch You watch shows. You watch something like this. And
you just pivot into something weird
or as weird as you can.
I don't know. Like, dude, you have somebody you're not interested
in. What's the worst that can happen? They walk away and they
stop wasting your time. >> Sorry. What? What else happened?
What else happened? >> This would be a good one. Mark Cardi.
Yeah,
dude. That's Listen, I think everybody did know he was a
But they're like, "Yeah, but he's also really cool. He's also
It's so Dude, have you been to the island? Dude, you can stay
away from the kids. Have you been to the island? It's awesome."
Right. Exactly. Yes.
I think that's what all of his friends were like. They're like, "Dude,
this guy's just such a great time. How could we not love him?"
Yeah, he's got his
flaws. What is he thinking about? >> Oh, yeah. We're racing
around the corner from the Batman pogo scene location. That's
true. We were around the corner from that. I pointed that out.
>> that's true. >> Okay, he pointed that out. I feel
like
if there was one prediction I was going to make before I heard
anything about this trip, I knew it would be Quan either arguing
with somebody about Better Man or pointing out stuff from Betterman.
It'd be like one of the two. I would bet I would have bet so
much money that he would bring up Betterman in some context.
Why did I lay that out? Well, I didn't lay it out because I actually
watched a decent amount of this content. Although, I don't know
if I saw him referencing Better Man, but yeah, I knew he would
reference it somewhere. I knew he would talk about it for sure.
He could. He can't help it. He literally can't help it at all.
I also argue someone about Batman at a pub because they were
they're a Robbie Williams fan that >> um no I actually
am socially capable Maximus which you can see on the stream most
of the time to be honest
at least in most situations.
I'm like the guy who's like um socially capable in like a corporate
friendly corporate friendly way. Like I've been to corporate
retreats where I'm meeting people from like other offices and
I'm always the person who like is the nexus of that. Not like
a a probably with like uh different friend groups with different
senses of humor, not as much. But terms of like not having to
be super edgy to make people laugh, I I'm usually pretty good
at it. >> Didn't like Batman. I was like, "Dude, you suck."
What else happened? Didn't like Batman. I was like, "Dude, you
suck." Should argue with someone about Batman at a pub because
they were they were a Robbie Williams fan that >> didn't
like Batman. I was like, "You >> Okay, so he pointed out
the pogo scene and he argued with somebody at a pub about how
Batman was awesome.
Bro,
>> what else happened? Like what else
Oh, wait. Yeah, there's a story that Dick has told that he [__]
up. So, tell a story about Aiden debating a girl at this after
party. Okay. It wasn't quite like that. Okay. Not quite what
happened. So, I think I think Hellbent
was doing
No, don't don't even try and correct me. So, you guys are way
more. Don't even start. Hellbent was doing one of the things
that may have been off where she was like trying to force a conversation
being like, "So, so the accent, why are you guys why you guys
talking to each other whatever the force conversation?" And Slay
talking about psychology. She was like a psychology student or
some graduate wherever the [__]
And it was like a it was a you know it was like any any time
where you try to talk to a woman about what they're studying.
It's like this. It is like this every [__] time where
basically all she could do is
recite
like the definitions of the schools of psychology. It's like
they're literally going backwards and forwards. They're just
saying like, "Oh well, I think behavioral psychology is like
where you study people's behaviors." I'm not even kidding. It's
like a terrible conversation they're having. Just like bouncing
backwards and forwards saying they should each other. It was
like terrible. It was like absolutely terrible. So, I'm like
cringing, laughing, just like this is rough. I I can't tell if
anyone else like understands the topic will have to realize how
bad it is. But I can tell that Aiden's like Aiden is like obviously
knows that and knows this dumb as hell, but he's not really engaging
more anyway. He's not engaging in a way that will actually prompt
a real deeper conversation. I feel like they basically end up
just doing like the most stock.
So, I I love this because Aiden's entire defense. This sort of
I don't even know if Queen meant to do this. But this kind of
undermines Aiden's entire defense, right? Is, oh, I'm just this
way, and if you don't like that, that's too bad. That's how I
am. I'm just like everyone else in these communities. This is
how I am. This is how I am. But then when the prospect of like
some 27year-old Norwegian rears its ugly head, Aiden's immediately
like, "Oh, I'll have the dumbest conversation ever. I'll have
a totally brain dead conversation for for like forever." Yeah,
100%.
It's like, dude, you couldn't take that same level of social
acumen and apply it to just treating Hellbent with a little respect.
I know. I know it's difficult. Just pretend that you would hell
hellbent for like two seconds. Okay, just Hey, then maybe you
can act like a human being. Actually, Patrick Baitman, okay,
the only time he acts like a human being to somebody else is
when he's trying to
>> like nature >> in that one way. He is very similar
>> nurture [__] as they're talking but it's
like to say it's a debate would be >> totally overplaying
it is like literally like just bouncing backwards or forwards
saying nothing. >> It was like nothing. It was like so
empty. So yeah, that um that was that conversation. That was
one thing I said that I was like that was a bad recollection.
What else happened? Oh, we're at the second boat thing. I got
two free shots of tequila from the bartender.
Immediately gave them to Aiden. Made Aiden drink both of them.
That was good. That was good. Um,
what about the toilets in the first barge? Oh yeah, it was like
some awful like dude, it was like it looked makes shift as [__]
They had this awful urinal where the collected on one side. It
was like terrible. It was rough. It was rough. See, thank you
for 10 memberships, Lyn. Thank you. Huge appreciate it. Thank
you.
Wait, Critical Rad, the only way you know Hellbent is as Queenman's
mod.
Why wouldn't you introduce her by her far more famous title?
Nicholas Dioro is m [laughter]
after aiden Aiden basically soaked off from uh the restaurant
and so me and hell went to the pub and we bumped into DFL's comedy
friends and that's one of the people I argued with about man
which uh yeah that was great that was great
really great stuff there yeah comedy friends yeah
that's why that's why protecting Hellbent okay only Hellbent
knows just how he got in the middle of a far like 10 pints deep.
Okay. About
better man with this random guy from the he he literally almost
came to blows. Okay. He's ready to fight this guy. We're going
to go to where that they shot that pogo scene and I'mma fight
you.
Albance's the person keeping his secret.
Were they funny?
Uh no. One of them didn't like Stuart Lee, so I couldn't
couldn't possibly respect that.
Harry's saying bring up the meeting with Goat. So
yeah, before Aiden got there on New Year's, he basically said
he was in a meeting.
So I take I take that to mean he was on VC with Goat. That's
what I take that to mean. That's what I take. >> That
is potentially horrifying that he
was like multiple hours late for years to have a Discord conversation.
>> Very weird.
>> I'm in a meeting. >> Robin Ro on FaceTime in this
hotel room the whole break. Oh no, I wasn't saying that. That
was Windy actually. Sorry. I'm standing Perry. Sanding Perry
when he said that. Why didn't you go? Uh, I wasn't invited presumably
because they knew it would be very expensive to go just to meet
them one time
and unless you had your parents pay for that. Why would you do
it? >> Oh, what else is there? What else is there, man?
Yeah, just generally aiden just being kind of a loser. Just trying
to sit in this hotel the whole time. Just tell the queer. Did
you miss the Oppy? We did the Oppy photo, dude. Barry wants me
to talk about this photo as well. Hold on one sec.
So, I took this photo, guys. I took this photo. >> Okay,
I took this photo. >> I think they they talked about it
for a >> Oh, a red phone box. Soy soy.
Take a photo with you with it. Take a photo of you with it. Okay.
I was happy seeing that. I was I was genuinely happy seeing him
sort of eager about something, you know, sort of about something
kind of relevant to to Britain, you know. I was like, "Oh, cool.
He's into something. He's finally taking something slightly."
I was I was very excited. I was like, "Oh, isn't that cute? Isn't
that cute?" Didn't last very long. Did not last very long.
Wow. Okay. Going to switch over to I believe Queman goes over
to watch Dicker's stream for a little bit. That's the next place
we got to go to. Guys, if you like the content, go ahead, throw
a couple subs my way, you know, buy a TTS message, send some
kicks, all right, get some more money on the stream. I'm going
to try to get through this because I do want to have tomorrow
open to do whatever other content I want to do. So, we might
as well get through this late. We might as well get through as
much of it as we can. Okay. Uh, it's the next part of
>> Oh, wrong wrong link. Wrong link. I meant to go to the
kick clip.
Oh, this >> is anyone going to want to meet up with you
again? Can you? >> Hold on. Let's see if we can >> Is
anyone going to want to meet up with you again? Can you complain
about the fact that other people are like leaking stuff about
you? Maybe. But it kind of weakens your argument. >> Yeah,
Louis. So, it was on the first night after we met up with Dickers
when we're going back to Aiden's hotel. It was me, Dickers, and
Aiden. We get an Uber from where we were drinking to Aiden's
hotel. and he leaves his phone in the Uber and it drives off
and Dickas goes sprinting after it
and when Dickas gets back in he's like it's okay my dad my dad
will get me a new one in the morning literally like
>> it was like you know
again that's something where it's like
if I had Aiden's personality
I I might cry about that and let that ruin my evening this guy's
such an annoying neo baby queer You know,
I don't think Nepo baby's appropriate there. Um, Nepo baby doesn't
mean like in like you inherit money means you get into an industry
based on family connections. But other than that, yeah, that's
kind of just goofy as I don't like that. I don't like people
who
Dude, I can't stand I frankly I can't stand it. Okay. If you're
somebody who's like a rich kid and you like flaunt that wealth
without knowing or without meaning to, you don't understand how
like socially offputting it is when you say statements like that,
that's rough. Okay. I can I have been known to do that with like
my own money, like accidentally flaunting my own money without
really thinking about it. But I think that's a way different
thing. I think it's I personally think it's way less detestable.
But if you're flaunting like your parents' money, that's gay
as
I'm guessing he is memeing. Are they Wait, are they memeing?
I don't think they're memeing. That's the impression I get is
that this is very much who he is. >> But no, it's it I
just find it kind of amusing. I'm like, "Oh, that's this guy.
That's who this guy is." It's kind of >> Uh, no, it doesn't.
Nepotism is literally succeeding in a specific industry through
connections. It is not just being paid for by your wealthy parents.
It's like that. It just doesn't mean that word. You don't get
to just make up words. It literally has a >> That's kind
of funny. That's cool. That
>> JTO has money. I thought you were a poor streamer. H
I made a lot of money when I was in software. [laughter]
I make okay money in streaming. I don't make like terrible money.
>> It's okay. It's okay. >> Crazy. Yo, that goes
crazy. WW. That's
>> As soon as somebody's trying to be like nice to you
and you're saying they're like ruining your trip or saying that
they're like, I don't know, ruining the night or I never wanted
them there.
Is it really necessary?
Um, so then the funny thing here, the funny thing here is there's
like total meta signaling going on where these guys clearly tried
to warn Aiden that like, no, you were the we all think you were
the you shouldn't keep talking about it. And then Aiden kept
complaining about it, kept defending himself when every single
person who talked about it a little bit tried to signal first
like, "Hey, no, you kind of were in the wrong here." And Aiden
just bulldozed those like original, "Hey, no, maybe don't do
that." Right? He just bulldozed over them and was like, "No,
I am gonna complain about it." Well, well, then we get to the
most critical player >> in all of the drama. Arguably,
it's not Aiden. He has very little effect. It's not Hellbent.
She has very little effect. Me and Quean were in the background.
It is the chatters who make the content happen as always I guess
because as you would expect predictably
any Discord user when people are each other over interpersonal
drama or a meetup that everyone is talking about everyone then
goes and asks Hellbent about the nasty nasty things that angry
angry Aiden is saying about her. So, Hellbent is just getting
constantly DM'd by people in Aiden's Discord or tinged by them
in Aiden's Discord saying, "Have you heard what Aiden's saying
about you? Aiden snarking you right now, bro. Aiden's snarking
you." And Hellben just feels pretty cheesed off. I think Parry
already leaked this earlier.
>> Wait, was Hellbent mad?
>> By the way, I was going to say when he's talking about
people messaging, he's just talking about Perry, who is in fact
not a chatter, but a streamer. Perry definitely messaged Hellbent
was like, "Aidan said this and this and this about you. Do you
have any comment on this? Would you like to come on my stream?
I I'm I represent the Purple Perry gaming stream. Would you like
to come on my stream and talk about this?" >> I missed
this out as well. Sorry. That while we [laughter]
dude, while we're at this after party,
I just keep turning to other people in the group
and just going,
you know,
homies are linked with rats just to prove they get cheese
and just saying this like again and again. And I'm sort of saying
it as like
>> a jab at soul scity talking to this girl, but I just
I was like
literally I was just like spamming
like verbal dick
cuz of this salvo tweet saying it. I was just it was like every
few minutes just saying it. It was bad, dude. Voice is fun. And
I say I'd mix in like what like you know hey men and they have
pigs.
>> Okay. I think we've missed out on the watch story which
might be critical here. So I am going to probably try to find
the watch story in here box. Oh no no no.
Was the watch story on kick? Maybe the watch story was on kick.
Oh it was here. No no no. Here we go. Here we >> But that's
not possible because this is the definitive Aiden Hill and drama
stream. So there's no way that can possibly be true. Okay. >> Oh,
they all went live to try to farm this as well, which was pretty
funny. Check my timeline and our messages. Wait, hold on.
Well, I s I saw the timeline, but whatever. We'll go to the Aiden
stream next. I'm just going to go to I'm I'm going to skip over
most of Queens. Just watching Dickers.
>> Okay, hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
>> Dude, Aiden Aiden shouldn't fight this as as hard as
he does. He should He should actually know
He He should know to chill, but I have a feeling he's going to
fight hard. >> No, I don't particularly care.
Um, [snorts]
this is what every time I go do, it's like every little detail
is like, "Oh my god, I heard that you walked. I heard that you
and then it's this like annoying game of like telephone where
uh somebody else for uh
>> I heard you like broke this gift that that Hellbank
gave you intentionally like in front of her. I heard you just
like broke this like Olympics medal thing. What the is exaggerating
something or overplaying something and like the chat is like
too
stupid to decipher a joke. So, I just have to explain things
secondhand, which is the worst thing on earth to ever do, and
I hate doing it. It's so annoying.
Okay, man. Okay. Yeah, you're you're you
Yes, you're >> How is it not just pirate software to a
large extent?
Like I I don't know. Maybe how are so many people are like this.
It's so easy to just go, "Oh, here's like a thing I did that
was bad, and I'm not gonna I'm not gonna say I was right on everything."
I listen, I I did some bad stuff. Here's some bad stuff I did.
And just give people like a the literally just take a knee and
be like, "I wasn't perfect." Yeah, I'll take a knee on >> Hey,
Aiden, I am sorry for annoying you. I hope we still friends.
Yeah, man. We're like this, bro. We're like this. Looking more
dead than normal. It might have crazy thought. Okay, crazy thought.
This is going to be
shocking to some. It might have something to do with me being
sick. People Yeah, Aiden's been like sluggish. Aiden's been like
He doesn't really wanted to like leave his room. I've been sick.
I've been sick for three days.
I mean, I'm getting over it now, but like Yeah, I'm not like
I am sick.
Not like too sick to be like seething on Discord 247 though,
right? Like pretty sick, but not too sick to just be seething
the whole time. I did. Obviously, there's a level of sick. That's
that. But >> he alleged that I was That's really cool,
man. That's really cool. He's a hunchback. Like literally. Thank
you for >> Queen
got some kyphosis. But Queman's watching Vos and if Quimman's
watching Vos a lot, he'll know Vosch gave you the the trick,
okay, to get rid of your kyphotic neck. He gave you all the stretches
and stuff. He went over that today on stream. >> Oh, what's
with >> I only tune in for Vos's like lifestyle and or
life tip advice. I never watch him for politics. I just tune
in to see what he's saying about fashion and what he's saying
about getting healthy and having a fulfilling life. And then
I'm like, "Oh, politics. Yeah, I'm out. Bye.
>> The red hair. You're colorblind.
>> Oh, a Vosch political opinion. Throw that in the trash.
Vos fashion advice. Let's [__] go. I'm here. What
is your deal, man? Can you calm down? I am calm.
Why were you mean to Hellbent? I thought the criticism is that
I wasn't mean to
to her. Like, I was complaining about Hellbent, but I wasn't
doing that to her face. Now, I was mean to her.
I I honestly I don't even >> I don't even It's It's a It's
a joke. It's a big dude and they have little Queenman coffee
cups and this almost >> This is why This is why Queen tries
not to drink on stream. Look how badly he almost drops that.
He was so close to having a moment. >> Coffee cups.
>> This [__] country, dude. >> His hands
are kind of shaky.
>> You saw it wobble, right? It wobbles as he does the
switch over. Hold on.
Look at the look at the liquid slloshing around the cup wobbling.
A little wobble. >> [__] country, dude. Is
this the streamer you retire?
I'm considering it, man. I'm considering >> Oh, he is on
like every He is on like everything to get him like dialed in.
Nicotine, caffeine, amphetamine,
every mean. >> Why are you and Perry different heights?
>> Every
Yeah. >> I don't know, man.
talk about >> it was like midnight when he was streaming.
Wait, was it midnight in the >> The restaurant. I wouldn't
talk about because it's the most uneventful, unexciting thing
ever. Like there's like nothing exciting about it. Um I was going
to go for dinner. I found some spot. Uh everyone said uh Quan
said he was I thought Dickers was coming. He said he actually
wasn't. Hellbent was coming. Uh I got a reservation. I pull up
uh like 10 minutes 4. Queen was like, "Are you sure we you want
to go to this place?" And it's like, "Well, if we don't, I have
to I think I had to pay like $40 if we missed the reservation."
Um, it's like, "If you want to go somewhere else, you could just
tell me, you know,
not like 10 minutes prior." That's a little weird, isn't it?
That we
we have Okay. Oh, well, we missed the reservation. If we missed
the reservation, we lose 40 bucks. But also, who cares about
my phone? my dad will buy me a new one >> or whatever.
Uh,
not 10 minutes prior to leaving, like 10 minutes prior to like
the reservation like [__] starting or whatever. It's
like, okay, I guess. Yeah, I'll just um
The Romans didn't conquer London. What?
They objectively conquered London. They might have founded the
city that was became London.
Wasn't like Londonium or Londonum? Yeah, they founded. Okay.
Well, they founded the city. Yeah. Okay. Okay. But they conquered
the territory that London was in and then founded a city there.
Lum. Yeah, something like that.
I literally Sorry, I couldn't I I've seen it spelled Hold on.
Hold on. Sorry. You say Londonium. I know I said that, but you
know how you you get it and it's like when you're looking at
like an old Roman name, there's like eight different V's in it
and you're not sure what sounds they are. Like you're looking
at an old Latin name for something. It's got like eight V's in
it for no reason.
>> Yeah, it's like that. It looked like >> It wasn't
great. I just like I don't see what's like if you if you find
any of this interesting, I mean, >> oh wait, it is Londonium.
With all due respect, like you need to take your own life. I
am encouraging you to do it, to go through with it. It is so
uninteresting. This is literally like I say, it's like wine moms
that watch Bravo and Real House. It's like who the watches this
>> gives a [__] what she's wearing or she's
going for dinner or it's like that but somehow even more stupid.
It's so so
This is like
this is particularly dumb for Aiden
when he knows that a big part of like the whole group community
following for like the
the SFTP like RFC type guys, those all those commentary YouTubers
was like their little friendship that was budding off stream.
They're just a bunch of little squeakers who are hanging out
off stream together, right?
Like this. You're literally a
You're like a personality who
part of what you sell is like insight into your life and and
like the way you live and then people are going to see you hang
out with a bunch of other people that do that kind of thing and
there's going to be like amusing stories that come out of that.
Everybody cares. Yeah.
I don't know if you know this. The reason you have all these
people typing in this chat right here is cuz they give a about
what you say.
How the [__] is that confusing? They give up about
what you say and what you do. Yeah. They want to know. They literally
want to know. That's why they give you money and show up and
listen to you talk.
I know your life is not that boring. I mean, as a compliment,
I know even the the biggest loser in this chat.
No, you don't mean it as a compliment. You are framing out anybody
asking about this, you're trying to make them seem like a loser
on the basis of them asking about it because you know that you
don't want to answer questions about it. You know that you're
done talking about it because it makes you look bad. So, you're
trying to say, "Anybody who cares to make me look bad is a loser."
That's what you want to say, but you won't say that. You're like,
"Anybody who cares about this is a loser." But what you want
to say is anyone who makes me feel bad is a loser.
That's what you're trying to do. Obviously, clearly >> does
not have a life boring enough where they could ever ever justify
interest in what the I had for dinner one night.
What? There's no drama.
What is the drama? I'm I'm confused. >> This is literally
yesterday during the day. Okay.
So, this has 1500 views
and I think at least like eight different streamers have covered
it.
So, he says there's like nothing going on. There is no drama.
He's trying to do Look at his hand movements here. >> I'm
confused. What? There's no drama. What is this? >> He's
trying to do a little Jedi mind trick here with his hands.
>> Little Larry Ellison moment. Jedi mind trick. Is it
like serious drama? No, it's not serious drama, right? Obviously,
it's not serious. It's like goofy ass drama. It's you could just
go hey yeah I'm a little a I'm a little weird probably would
just end
but when you go I'm a weird I don't do anything and that's awesome
then people are like I don't know about that you want to okay
you the full breakdown of my trip all right here's your little
breakdown of my trip this super let's see what the drama is okay
let's see what the [__] drama is everyone I would
not be interested if there was cuz
>> it's particularly weird for him to say there's no drama
when he created created the drama explicitly by whining about
it in his server, right? By whining about hellbent like repeatedly.
That's how he created the drama. He made the drama. >> There
is nothing happening. Do you think it's interesting that somebody
ate that somebody ate food? You think that's like that? You think
that's interesting? You
>> I think it's funny. I can picture in my head
Quimman slowly starting to see as his like wine cup is it's like
slloshing around because the table is rocking cuz you're putting
your entire body weight into this bread. I can just picture Quean
slowly getting more and more agitated over the course of you
just trying to saw into this bread. Yeah, that's funny. And painting
that picture is funny. Aiden understands all of this by the way.
He doesn't get it when it's his personal life. >> Came
out and said you I got I got annoyed. Yeah, I got annoyed by
some. I'm sorry.
>> You can just see it. Like literally just the tiniest
little bit of red wine spills out of Queenman's cup onto the
table with Aiden like rocking it, putting his entireing hips
into sawing through this bread, right? And Queen is just like,
I'm going to end this guy. I'm going to I'm going to end this
guy's whole life right now. It's over. Did I just pause or is
he AFK? >> Grow. What? >> I don't know what the is
happening. I like unironically
for the last 24 hour I don't know if it's like I'm disassociating
or whatever I like unironically feel
like
everyone else is like crazy. I know I know that's like it's like
only crazy people say but it's like
I legitimately
I've tried to think about it from every angle. I can't figure
out what's going on.
Like I it feels almost like a fever dream. I don't know what's
going on. Why are you vague? But was I was just annoyed. I was
just annoyed. There was nothing specific. I was just annoyed.
Something that I don't think Hellbent's like a bad person or
whatever. I just don't enjoy Hellbent's company. Something I
personally don't like. >> Again, I think this is also not
really I'm I'm pretty sure
Dickers or somebody talked about this that like basically Hellbent
said something rude to him or or might have said something in
a drama. Oh, no. It was hell. Aiden was supposed to have an interview
with there's this guy named Jake Wed who did I can't even remember
what Jake was Jake Wedle did he do like a Mr. Beast thing. Was
he a part of the Mr. Beast drama with Chris Tyson? He like somehow
made his name there slightly right
and then
was he the guy who leaked the the gambling thing? Maybe did a
video on the gambling thing maybe. I can't even remember. Okay.
But this guy was a YouTuber. made these videos and then he tried
to do like standup comedy and he was just a goofy law type that
a lot of the commentary people were farming but his girlfriend
was somebody who was supposed to do an interview with Aiden and
Hellbin apparently messaged her and said don't do the interview
with Aiden you shouldn't do that and I think Aiden has been like
it's a blood feud from here on I I hate you forever I will kill
you if I can okay I will do you harm if I am able so now he felt
like I don't know it's like a blood dead at that point and he
just never liked her and I feel like He I don't know why he doesn't
say that. He's like, "Oh, she's a nice person." I just I don't
know if I I don't know if I get her vibe. It's like, "Dude, you
hated her before." Come on, you got to hate her. Have you talked
to me the people involved on stream? No. Hellbent was going to
come on tonight, but I literally just have to go through it first
before I talk to anyone about it. It might already be done by
the time we go through it. >> Like is like when people
like get personal, not personal. I don't know what the word I'm
looking for is like I don't like not saying Hellbent did this,
but a good example like I don't like sentimentality.
I don't like I like hanging with people. I don't like when people
I'm not saying hellbent did this. It's just explaining my overall
personality type. Like I don't like if somebody's like Aiden
like aren't we such good friends or not saying hellbent once
again over a good figure. I don't know how to word what I'm describing
but like I had a like if somebody's like Aiden like you're like
a uh you mean a lot to me or good
>> dude. Dude you're turning into Eden. You're in a headsp
space and should probably log off for a while. You have BBPD.
Haha. [laughter] You hung out with Bolex. Bob's IRL, but with
an auntie, you tried to slit her throat.
Put those Luna bars down. I'm kind of on Hellbent's side here.
True. All w Hellbent. Can you tell us something cool about your
trip so far? [laughter]
Aiden was a delight at Aiden Underground. Or Aiden, was I delight
Skippy? Was I a delight?
The worm is turned. Haha. Wipe the tears off, bro, and get on
with it. Aderalind induced mania.
Aiden, why are why are you a ginger all of the sudden? Hellbent
broke you. If you're sick, maybe it's just that it's just what
it is. Did you say please? Sounded like a Okay, so it's like
80% trolling, 90% trolling. >> Like I get uncomfortable.
I just don't
>> like that or whatever. And like and like, you know,
I kind of I'm facitious uh towards towards people or whatever.
And like when Helmet was like, do you do you have like an issue
with me? Do you Well, it was I got like a little uncomfortable.
It's like cuz I just got like annoyed just like cuz it's just
like we all jab at each other. You just move on. You want to
be like um um is there anything I could be doing better? >> It's
banter again. >> I hate people, dude. I hate people, >> dude.
He's reading this chat. I don't blame him. >> Someone tried
to make friends with you and you were I wasn't a [__]
I don't How was I a [__] >> How much of this
is him being afraid to be around women?
Oh, I woman. I don't think that's it. I think, like I said, I
think he already hated Hellbent. He didn't want Hellbent around.
He also didn't want to fight and say that. He didn't want to
be like, "No, I'm not hanging out with Hellbent, this stupid
bitch." Which is all he had to say, by the way. Could have just
been like, "No, I don't want to hang out with Hellbent, this
stupid bitch." But now he's even I guess this is
like yesterday, so this would be two days after the first drama
was going on about this, and he's still sitting here like, "Oh,
I don't know. I don't really have a problem with her. It's like
whatever. We just didn't get along. She was overfamiliar.
Like, dude, what? >> I'm not I'm terrified of confrontation.
That is like the biggest like self-report that you're drooling
like mongaloid. I used to get in trouble in school for chronically
arguing. That was the main thing I get in trouble for. I have
no issue. >> In middle school, I was really annoying. I
was just known for being annoying. Everyone thought I was annoying.
>> I just don't like conversations of like a not argumentation.
I can't I don't know the word I'm looking for >> like personal
sentimental
anything describing a relationship between two people like a
friendship or
I have a brother like my brother called me and he was like you
know you're such a good brother to me man or whatever like I
get like uncomfortable I I don't like I just like to be mean
dude I just like to be my own guy kind of like there you know
I don't know I don't know I just get like did I annoy you? No
soul I found you to be uh very pleasant to be around. Thank you
for the two. Uh GG's with the five. Why are you a ginger? I don't
know. Wipe the tears off. I'm not. There's no crying. It's a
Who's it fault? Like I don't
Notice how like they're so terrified of my intelligence they
disagree if they never call in because they know they're too
stupid.
Like it's a character, right? This is a
>> How like they're so terrified of my intelligence they
disagree if they never call in because they know >> I think
that's a character. That's like a joke. He's like trying to lean
in and gigachhat a joke out here. Right. >> So they're
too stupid to talk to me. It happens many times, many cases.
You lost her Soviet medal, by the way. Uh, it fell out of my
pocket. If she wants the money, she gave it to me as a gift.
Uh, it was a nice gift. Um,
>> no, that can't be baiting callers. It has to be explicitly
like a joke. There's no way it's just baiting callers. Come on.
>> Sadly, uh, I lost it just like I lost my rings. Um,
now
if she wants I I could buy her another one if she wants it back.
like I'm fine with doing that. Uh
yeah. So I'm I said thank you. I was grateful. I literally said
this is really cool. Thank you. Or is the gift like this? See
this is why I also don't like taking gifts from people cuz people
will give you something and then use that to like hold it over
you. They use like a mechanism of control. Okay. Now you have
like a now you have a bond to this person. You owe them something.
>> Wait, was I doing that on stream? I wasn't like clicking
my tongue. I was like, "Wait, are you asking what Aiden just
did? Was I like clicking my tongue on stream?"
I might have been doing that. I sometimes do like little ticks
where I'm like, "Was I doing that on stream?" Oh, that's my bad.
I was I was I was trying to line up the next piece of content
and reading and doing that to myself in my head. That's my bad.
I do that sometimes.
That's Whoops. I I like realized as soon as I read it, I was
like, I just did that out loud, didn't I? I wasn't just like
doing it with myself. Okay, that's whatever. [laughter] It's
fine. >> You have to do and and it's like >> like
did I just do that on stream? Oh, god damn it. >> It's
like I was I genuinely appreciated the gift. I accidentally lost
it just like I lost my own possessions. Uh and it was a mistake.
Um I could I'll do whatever I need to to compensate for that.
Um but I don't owe any like I don't know what I'm supposed to
really be doing here. Thank you for the five. Not How do you
Okay.
Do you think it's like an intentional act to go and like How
do you think losing something works? >> Yeah, I think he
intentionally threw it in the garbage. I still think that even
though they found it, I still kind of think he just intentionally
threw it out the second he could just despite
or he just lied about losing it. Was like, I did lose it. Cuz
he never wanted Hellbent to think he got the gift. That actually
maybe that would be the most believable.
And then it turned against him online so he's like, "Oh, I found
it magically. It fell out of my pocket along with the other that
was in my >> By the way, that's an intentional lie. I'm
just lying
or I don't know
at least. >> There's nothing I'm saying that's like I honestly
I feel like I'm in like a dream. I don't understand like what
the issue is. >> Does Aiden start debating people here?
I feel like he starts debating people at some point.
Maybe I start skipping through >> conflated now five times
and despite all these clarifications,
you're still so
you still can't get it right.
>> oh, hold on. >> Someone tries to help. No. Okay.
You understand that people can offer help for like that actually
isn't help. It's like actually like a complete burn what I did.
My ring was not a gift to me. I want it. You're so
What's your name? What's your name? Mark. I've specified three
times now. It's not the pin. It's the ring. The two things people
have conflated now five times. And forget it, ma'am. Forget it.
Forgetly.
It is like,
forget it, ma'am. Forget it. Forget it. >> People are just
going to keep trolling him forever. This is so mean. This is
actually evil. >> Are we of the understand? There are two
evil. Okay. I don't know if
>> is it like a thing of object permanent. Well, no, cuz
neither of the items are in front of you. But I want you to for
one moment be able to think of two separate concepts at once.
There's this pin that Hellbank gave to me that I said thank you
for, right? And then there's a ring. I lost a ring. I lost a
ring. I looked for it. I couldn't find it and I didn't care cuz
I wanted to leave. It was my ring. I bought it. Hellbent has
no connection to the ring. Hellbent is like pulling apart these
people's couch for this cheap ring. And I was after I just gone
to look for it and couldn't find it. I was explain I don't want
it.
um after I'd already just gone and looked for it. Uh >> right.
So this is about basically with Hellbent. They were at those
those two
the Norwegian, the military wife, I think they're at their flat
and Aiden lost a ring or something. Yeah, Aiden lost a ring and
and he was basically like, "Let's just go. I don't I don't care
about the ring." >> That was not the gift. That was my
ring.
>> Okay. You mean to tell me? [sighs] >> Yeah. Here's
the first caller for you there now. >> What's up? >> You
mean to tell me you went on this trip to London for New Year's
instead of hanging out with your family, right? Just to act like
a prick the entire time. just act like an ungrateful little ass
when they went out of their way to invite you. >> Wait,
who am I? Nobody inv Wait, who am I? Who invited me to watch?
>> Like, so so you were like being like a complete [__]
to hellbent the entire time even though she's over here like
being super nice to you and everyone else and you're just like,
"Oh my god, she's so [__] annoying. Oh my god, she's
actually
with me." Like, why? Like, like what was the issue?
>> That's what I'm trying to figure out. How was I being
a prick to her, >> dude? Dude, dude, dude. Cuz like literally
everyone is saying that like you were being like the biggest
[__] most annoying little prick. You were just [__]
chronically unhappy on this. Can I give you a hypothetical? Can
you give I give you
no people like
no no no no no no.
>> Saying that it's okay to have sex with children. Would
you accept that as fact and then go and have sex with a child?
>> Someone told you was okay? Would that be okay? Would
that make okay if you if you if you said if somebody said would
it be okay immediately
first analogy that pops into his head. What if
what if guys
>> So then you go on stream to like mold about like how
I don't like people. I just I don't like when people try to form
bonds with me. Why are they trying to be friends with me? That's
so gay. I only like arguing with people. >> The hypothetical.
Can you engage with the hypothetical?
>> Can you such a loser, bro?
>> Can't engage with the hypothetical. He >> You
actually can't talk to people, bro. >> they invited you
on a little trip. >> She got you like this amazing like
gift, this super expensive gift. And what do you do? You lose
it. And then when you lose your This ride or die friend is like
tearing apart this poor woman's couch to find it. And you're
just being like an ungrateful disgring
someone else's couch without their permission. Now that's rude.
>> I'm obviously exaggerating, but like let's be real here,
dude. like she was being a ride or die. Okay, she's helping everyone
out. Helping Soul Skippy, this poor special boy
>> engage with my hypothetical. Engage with >> Use
public transportation for the first time in his [__]
life. Okay? Like literally helping him around like she's his
mother. She's being incredibly nice to you, trying to like be
friendly, trying to banter. Even [__] Queenman of
all people, which people thought that he was going to be the
most antisocial one. You're over here like, "Oh my god, this
is so [__] gay." I'm just
Who said that? Who said Queman's going to be the most antisocial
one? I heard Queman say it. This guy just listen to Quean say
it and then he's like, "This
I I heard Quan say it. Did this guy just get that from Quean?
>> So chronically annoyed by this girl trying to be nice
to me. Like why is she being so nice to me? I'm so antisocial.
I'm too cool for this. Why did you even >> Go where? >> Like
why did you even go? What's wrong with you? What do you mean
where? What? Are you stupid?
>> No. I'm I'm just asking. Go where? She She wants to
go to like I have no interest in saying I don't want to go
talking about right now, dude. Like, do you even know what we're
talking about right now? >> Is not like a representative
of the city of London. You can like go to London without wanting
to see. >> I never said that. What are you talking about?
What >> is she like is she like a golem of like like you
you enter the vicinity of the city and she like spawns in. I
went to London. I went to go see people in London. She invited
herself and my only shortcoming was not telling her that I had
no interest in seeing her. >> Asking about where you went
earlier. You were asking about like where? What do you mean where
like like you don't know what you just did? You just came back.
>> I actually don't know what I did. >> Are you actually
[__] Like
>> what did I do? >> You're you're brain dead, dude.
I
can't answer a simple question. >> I feel so bad for people
like you do because it's like the dumbest question when you can't
answer
the most simple. What did I [clears throat] do? That is like
Dude, dude, >> we're literally Oh my god.
What are you talking about? >> You're so lost. You're so
lost. Oh my god. We're talking about Okay. Can you >> I
think to be clear, I think he's trying to argue. He didn't do
anything wrong. As in, not what did I do, but it's like what
did I do wrong? And this guy's like, "Oh, you're just like, oh,
a whole bunch of people have called you out. Why are you pretending
you don't understand? >> I will just be your pain." >> See
where the disconnect is here a little Dang Devil donated $3.
The reason Aiden brought up the
is actually misdirection. Aiden's point isn't that the caller
would children if everyone said it was fine. It's that Aiden
children precisely because he's not beholden to the whims of
the crowd.
>> Oh, you actually got through the whole message. I thought
I was going to have to pick that up. I was just reading along
trying to make sure that I could pick that up once it finished.
But long do. But sure. Yes, exactly.
You think pedoph You think laws control this man's behavior?
Only he controls his behavior. >> Talking about the trick
that you did and you were asking or was it the uncle?
>> What? What are you talking about? >> Your school
or was it your uncle? >> Dude, look. Okay. I don't know
who you think you're talking to, but I'm not that person. Okay,
it's okay. They're not here. Okay, it's fine. It's fine. >> Oh,
it was a teacher. Got it. It was a
>> Can Aiden really throw the first stone on allegations
of being or groomed? Is this really something he can do? >> Dude,
why are you projecting so hard? Like, why is that the first thing
you think of? Like, like someone getting
>> That's so weird. Like, why is that the first thing you're
thinking?
>> You're saying teacher uncle?
>> That's so, >> bro. No, he
Yeah, you can't get this
>> Look at the hand. Look at the hand go.
>> The hand is tremoring out here.
That's like that is all of the uppers at the same time. Your
hands are just like
>> I was asking you like who was responsible who responsible
for teaching you about questions because like you clearly don't
know how to answer them. So whoever it was they like failed.
Nobody said anything about >> it's really weird your mind
went to >> Shut up. Shut up. Shut the [__]
up. Shut the [__] up. Shut the [__] up.
>> Wait. Why are you thinking about
you
You're This guy finds This guy finds little kids getting very
funny. This is like a caricature right here. This up. I hear
somebody photoshopping this earlier. It was not photoshopped.
>> Do you tend to think about kids getting touched a lot?
Like whenever you have the chance.
he brought it up. He literally That was his hypothetical first.
Twice actually.
Bro, what is that gaslighting?
Um, why are you talking about little kids getting [__]
bro? You did twice. >> You genuinely are the most saddest
on earth. Okay,
>> you genuinely can't talk to people. You see every conversation
as a competition. >> You're having an one-way monologue.
You've actively avoided direct questions. You've come in here
to get what you believe was an easy duck. And you've literally
been unable. You've been unable to substantiate a single point.
You've been able to answer a single question.
I'm going to cross into snarking right away. I don't want to
do that to Aiden, okay? He's already got enough problems. I don't
want to do I don't want to do >> She's being so nice to
me. It it it makes me so uncomfortable when people try to like
form bonds with me and like Oh my god,
Aiden doing the Larry Ellison like it's crazy. Like it's like
it's going out of style. He's trying to get all his Larry Ellison's
in. >> God, it makes me so uncomfortable when people are
sappy like that. Like you're >> Yeah, I'm sorry. >> You're
gay. I don't like I don't like
you, bro. I'm sorry. [clears throat] I'm sorry,
>> dude. Oh my god. >> So, can you answer questions?
>> YOU'RE WHOA.
I'M NOT ON Twitch anymore. We're actually fine. >> You
can't answer the question. Just answer. What did I do? He left.
He [laughter] I just wanted to know what I did. I asked him four
times. Couldn't get an answer. Could not get an answer. Anyways,
uh thank you GG's for the five. Helvin tells me, by the way,
the last time that guy called in, he was like supering dogs for
you and I had to remove him. >> Sorry. I just wanted to
uh I just wanted to say a fact. So, you met Harry in Malta, right?
>> Okay. Apparently, not that many of the callers are good
after this. Just give me a second cuz we trust me, we want to
go a little bit further because there's like Dicker's whole retelling.
Do we need the Do we need Do we need Dicker's retelling? Is that
critical?
Like I'm guessing it's the same events. >> Um so I thought
that Aiden had like a plan of what he wanted to do. Like he's
in London, right? Um he's in London. >> Yeah, I'm doing
the watch story. That's what I'm doing. >> He hasn't asked
me to make plans. I've tried to make plans with Aiden. Okay.
I have tried to make plans with Aiden and he just doesn't really
respond much, I guess, which is really annoying. But Aiden hits
me up.
Hayden says, "We should go shopping. I want to go shopping while
I'm in London." Yeah,
I'm I'm going to go We're going to We're going to go shopping
while we're in London. Cool. He meets me in a in a cafe all the
way up at the top of a department store.
We have a coffee there. We go back down. We walk around for like
an hour in the department store looking for clothes. I don't
know why Aiden is denying planning to buy Levi jeans. He planned
to buy Levi jeans. He was walking around looking for Levi jeans.
I guess we decided eventually it was like too expensive there.
So he expected me to be able to take him out
into the high street and be able to pinpoint him the exact store
that sold like adult rings. Um
I I couldn't I got no idea. So we just kind of walked along like
different shops, right? Went into one, walked around and didn't
like >> this is a second narrative that Quimman is not
so subtly pedaling. Although too subtle for me cuz I thought
he was saying the opposite.
Quiman needs you guys to know, okay,
Dickers is getting fat. Okay, Queen wants you all to know, it's
very important you all know that Dickers is getting very fat.
Okay,
it's like critical that you guys include in your retelling of
this It's like Queman's running his own version of chorus. Okay,
he's got his chorus. Talking points. Talking point number two.
Number one, Aiden is an like Nepo baby. Talk point number two.
Dickers is fat. Dickers is getting fat. You guys got it. Okay,
I'll collect my check.
Well,
why don't we hit play here with Jonathan? We went to the next
one. Repeat, repeat, repeat until
we got to Jack and Jones.
That was how it happened. That was how it happened. Rings. No.
Eventually we went to a I guess like a we saw like a HM Smiths
or HM Samuels like went in there and was like I I wonder if they
sell like like male rings. They did. And they Okay,
I'll admit when Dickers keeps saying male rings, adult male rings,
I do assume he means rings. That is actually my like first impression
is he means rings. Why is talking about rings? Why you going
to buy matching rings? This is very bizarre. >> They're
like super expensive and so Aiden didn't want to buy any. Um
I think when when Aiden says that he wants to wear rings, he
wants to buy ones that he buys for like $10 off of Etsy. That's
what he means. Um however,
there is an interesting story to be had.
Oh my god. [laughter] There is an interesting story with when
we went to go and buy the watch.
Do you guys know about this? Aiden said he went to went to went
to go and buy a watch. Yeah. So,
after we were walking around
ages going around different stores, we eventually walk into a
watch store. We walk around
like two seconds, we find the first one that Aiden sees.
Near enough, right? Near enough.
And Aiden says, "Oh, yeah. Um, can I get a shop attendant?"
just looking around,
stares at a woman for a bit, and the woman comes over. Oh, can
I help you? Yeah. Yeah. Can I try this on? Sure, sure. Sure.
So, Aiden is has the display version,
and I guess he's trying to put it around his wrist
and he's kind of pulling on the strap and he's really pulling
and he I don't think this guy's ever worn a watch before. I'm
not going to I don't I genuinely don't think he's ever put a
watch on ever. Um, it's like it's like watching somebody trying
to trying to put on shoes with their mouth. I don't know how
to describe that. >> When Dickers like pretends to be this
friendly nice guy,
just know that this story was not known to anybody. It was only
between him and Aiden. This story never had to be made public.
So like later, I do think he streamed with Aiden tonight. Later
when he's acting like they're buddies. This didn't have to be
told. There was no part of this story that had to be told.
And I hope Aiden understands that, too. Okay. No part of this
story actually to be told.
Dickers just wanted to take his like 5 minutes to farm this as
much as he could.
All right. I'm just saying this, none of this was leaked. As
far as I know, it was just between him and Dickers. I I don't
think Dickers had to add another log of fuel on the Aiden is
a completely sped fire, but he did. >> But he's like his
wrist trying to like get it on there.
And then after he puts it on on like the smallest setting, right?
He's like, "Yeah,
yeah, I like that." >> See Chud's posit about the group
getting rings. Nope. >> This one. So he reaches into his
pocket and he starts like going through his wallet. By the way,
we're on the other side of the store, by the way. We're on the
other other side of the store to the It's only small, but to
the cash >> Um, I've watched this before.
[clears throat] But I do feel a little bad because I just watched
Queman AFK steal this content on kick.
I didn't actually watch Dicker's version of it. I just watched
Queman literally not talk or interrupt at all and AFK reram Dickers
on kick. It's a pretty good
and he just pulls out his wallet and he pulls out his card almost
to like hand it to the lady.
I tell him that's a that's the display version, mate. Do you
want to do you want to take this display version off first? He's
like, "Oh,
well, can I not buy?" Oh, yeah. Okay, I guess. I guess.
And the woman even says this little Indian woman. It's like,
yeah, I wonder why he didn't want to give that back. Aiden wants
me to call in right now.
>> I'm not weird. You're weird. I'm not weird. You're weird.
I'm not. You're You're the weird one. I'm not weird. >> Hopefully,
it's to talk about the Watchers. What? He's arguing with Gamma.
Okay, I'll finish up the story. I'll finish up the story. All
right. Okay. So,
he's going through then.
>> They go through >> and they give him the actual
>> Hold on. Apparently, this is critical chud context we
need. Okay.
>> Where's the chud context here? >> Um have one
of these tattoos >> and it's me, Aiden, and sold it of
the >> What's this?
Aiden is see like slowly building with more and more and more
violent rage.
Let's get a picture of Aiden just to demonstrate [laughter] this.
Right. >> Bro, what the actual >> Okay, here we are.
>> Bro, what the actual is this?
>> I hear that I hear that Aiden Creamman and Dickers and
Skellyy
all left London with this tattoo. That's what that's what I'm
hearing on the grapevine. [laughter] That's what I've heard,
dude. A little bit a little bit of you know behind the scenes
nattering
>> it as well. >> Okay. Isn't that more of more of
an achievement of the vist fisty rather than the fister? Yeah,
probably certainly. Okay. Where's my not this one >> the
actual version? He's like, okay, thank you. >> With the
story for a little bit. >> Go over to the till.
He's buying it. It's like, okay, can I not have the rest? Could
you could you leave? Could you put the rest in the bin for me?
It's like, oh, the rest. He's like, "Yeah, yeah, like the bag,
the box. I don't I don't want any of that. I could I could I
not have any of that?"
You just want to pay
over like a hundred close to £200 for this watch and then just
like you don't want to take Hey, the weird thing about this that
I don't know if anybody pointed this out.
If the watch breaks, how do you take it back without a box? Like
most stores don't accept something back if you don't have the
packaging for it.
It's the whole idea. Yeah. They send it back to the manufacturer.
They try to restock
>> You don't have the box. You just want to like take the
watch out. Say, "Yeah, yeah, yeah. Thank you." He just takes
the watch off. Standing at the tail still. Standing at the tail
still. And just again goes through the same process of trying
to his wrist to force the watch onto it. It's like, "Would you
like help?" No, no, I've got it. I've got it.
Thank you very much.
And then we just walk out. It was the most cringeworthy
shop experience I I have ever seen. And then Aiden walks out
the store and guess what he says?
Guess what he says?
>> Something mean.
>> Stupid [__] Didn't want me to buy the watch.
Cow.
something miserable. Wow. Aiden said something miserable again.
No way.
Aiden's so cool. He's just always like upset and mad and miserable.
So awesome. >> Well, she is she she's supposed to be a
salesperson. She She sounds like she didn't want me buy the watch.
>> Okay. Okay. Hold on. I don't think I don't think he
told it like that. I don't think Aiden just said like that. Come
on.
No way. >> Oh my god. >> It wasn't even that interested
about a
>> Okay. I just I just wanted to tell that. That was like
a beautiful That was a gorgeous It was just It's just Aiden.
It's just Aiden all the way through. Just I feel like I'm in
a fever dream. I feel like I've I don't know passed out and just
like I'm on K. That that that's that is actually what it feels
like going through a social interaction with Aiden. I feel like
I am on drugs watching him speak to another human being. It's
so [__]
Anything else you do on on your dates? What? Me and Aiden? Oh,
yeah. We went to like a restaurant and stuff. That was pretty
good. I mean, you've heard me describe this guy putting on a
wristwatch. I had to watch him eat a crab. I I had to watch him
use the little things to like d-shell a crab.
No gloves, no bib, no nothing. I used the gloves. I used the
bib.
It was rough. It was very, very rough.
>> How's it going, guys? >> I don't like big parties.
I don't like groups. I much rather prefer like sitting in like
a group of like four people and like smoking some weed or some
than being at a party drinking and there's like >> what
did I get? Um I got >> Can we get the viewership numbers
for each of these streams?
I want to know like Dicker's viewer numbers, Aiden's viewer numbers.
What are the viewership numbers for each of these streams? I'm
just curious.
I mean, me and Aiden shared the crab, so that was kind of cool.
It was like you could just like put it onto your own plate. like
the little arms different little little pieces and stuff. Aiden.
Okay, I will not take this either that Aiden has got like some
autism around eating only Italian food. That's not true. Okay,
that isn't true cuz Aiden goes in and he sees it outside. I'll
probably tell the the full story later. After we wait in the
queue, we're like casually talking about like dating relationships.
I tell a story where I What did I What did I even say? Oh, yeah.
I just Aiden tries to ask me about like the Tinder dates or Hinge
dates that I've been on after the story that Perry told the other
day and after the Queen after the story that um I guess Queenman
told as well about him trying to make streaming sound as offputting
as possible whenever a girl asks about asks him about his job.
I just don't I've got nothing. I've got no stories. I've got
no story to tell. I've never like been on a date and like I don't
know like like spilled a drink. I've never like I don't know
like cut a woman. I've never raped a woman on a date I guess.
Right. Okay. I'm calling in later then.
I've never cut Wait, what? I guess
Oh, I wasn't talking about on kick. I was just curious like
they're all farming this drama at the same time. Very economically
inefficient. That was basically it. Just very economically in
could have spread it out, >> I guess.
>> All right. This why this guy wants to spam me between
calling and live off >> Um, at least went to Chinatown.
In my behest, actually.
Yeah, in my behest.
>> Chinatown in London is actually pretty.
>> Yeah. Apparently, there's something about pork feet.
Aiden eating wanting to try pork feet. Wait, did he actually
eat the pork feet? >> And enjoy, you know, like a party
with them. Enjoy like, you know, being at clubs with them. uh
or or bars, but it seems that you specifically only want to like,
you know, just tolerate uh one or two or maybe up to like, you
know, just >> one specific person at a time. >> Dickers,
are you here? >> Aiden, buddy, [clears throat] I didn't
realize you'd be on my stream tonight. How's it going? >> I
feel like I'm losing my You got to see me oneon-one. Okay. You
got to It's like It's like Mind Hunter. You got to do an
>> What do you think? What do you think about my ability
to social
to
to socialize? Sorry.
>> This is what this has come down to. This is what this
whole saga has come down to. What do you think about my ability
>> Yeah. Take take the biggest people pleaser that exists
in the entire space. Put them on the spot in the moment. Go.
Dickers, tell everybody that I'm normal. Hey Dickers, tell everybody
that I'm normal right now.
Hey dickers, don't you want to tell people how normal I am? Dickers,
dickers, dickers, don't you want to tell people I'm really normal?
I'm like super
>> It's going to be some like mostly you were fine, mostly
you were normal, but like
with Hellbent you were weird or some in some like, you know,
on the edges you're weird, but mostly you were fine. I thought
you were fine with me. I thought you were totally fine with me.
Like you were kind of weird with Hellbent, but I thought you
were totally fine with me. >> And also, by the way, I'm
okay with Hellbent coming out. It's queen. I don't want to say
it. [laughter]
>> Is that a bridge burn? Can we get a bridge burn there?
>> See this? >> Wow. Just don't want to hurt >> this
guy. So dramat queening guy is so
>> Um but we're
>> I think I think your ability
>> Do you think Do you think Aiden has even
Has Aiden even seen the story that Dickers just told about him?
Has he seen it yet?
I think that might be the mo like one of the worst sounding stories
that has been told about him. So he might dislike Quean. Aiden
could dislike Quean for all I know.
But really in comparison to that story that Diggers just told
Dick just made you look like a total psych. >> Socialize
is
fine. Uh you just seem like incredibly low energy. >> I
preferred drunk Aiden like 100 100%. or at least you on the first
date.
>> Your ability to socialize was fine, man. Your ability
to socialize was
>> Is fine. Uh you just seem like incredibly low energy.
I preferred drunk, Aiden. Like 100 100%. Or at least you on the
first day when you weren't like I guess hung over or ill if you
want to use those excuses. Um you were probably all right.
You kind of seem like slightly awkward and a little low energy.
I probably not but yeah. Well, actually slightly factors to that.
They're contributing factors to that. >> Well, Aiden, no.
Sorry, I'll let you >> Would you do would you say of yourself,
Aiden, that you like go to go to clubs, go to parties,
hang out with people IRL just as a >> I don't typically
like doing that. No. >> Okay. But you don't you don't do
that regularly. You haven't done that since you've been to like
uni. You haven't had like a like a uni night life or anything
like that like hanging out with people in like I don't know societies
or stuff like that. >> He's like actively in university
right >> I have hung out with I've hung out with people
but I always I always do it solo. I always do it solo. Like at
most what I do is I have like I have a few on
friends that will occasionally like come to my apartment or like
Wait,
I go out solo.
I guess that's possible. I don't
I don't think I've ever done that. Wait, have I ever done that?
I'm trying to think of any time I've just gone to a bar by myself
like just I've been like I'm going to have a night out and I'm
I like go to a
I'm trying to think. Yeah. I don't think I've ever had cause
to to just be like I like if I want to go out if I want to go
out and do I'm like I'm inviting at least one friend maybe in
a new city. Yeah, sure. If you're in a new city maybe you'd go
do something like that. I try to meet people through something
else. Work
um like I don't know wreck activities, some sport
>> like drink or smoke weed or something and that will
be it. I don't really I don't like to go out and party.
>> Yeah. Uh, so I think your social skills are
fine with that as a proviso. Um,
I guess [laughter] like that is exactly how I how I perceive
you. Yeah, I perceive you as somebody who doesn't really go out
and spend time like partying very much or going out in >> Way
more insightful, funny conversation. You have way better conversation
with people when it's a small group as opposed like a thousand
people. Like I I just find people are way more open. people are
way more um there's not like loud music. >> This is like
the exact autism that a lot of people have. Dude, I bet you
there's just so many things that I could see like when I was
younger that I'd probably think like this. I remember thinking
going to like the gym was cringe when I was in my like early
20s. Oh, it's cringe. It's cringe to like try to get in shape.
Used to think that.
Then you like go to the gym, you're older, you're like, "Oh,
why was I why did I think that? That's like so gay." That was
like the gayest thing I ever
I feel like Aiden would think that same thing. Like going to
the gym is gay. Getting in shape is like a waste of time.
Being in a mosh pit for the first time will change you. Well,
it depends on what you mean by a mosh pit. If you just mean like
the uh the standing area of a concert, I don't necessarily agree.
You're talking about like an actual mosh pit where people are
like moshing, then
I'd say
the different energies in different
at a metal gig, dude. The metal gig one was the first one I went
to. It was gay. It sucked. People were stupid.
I I like
But I go like at like rock concerts and [__] It's
awesome. Just being in like the swell of people. That's awesome.
Mosh pits at like a metal concert suck. Just boring. What band?
Uh local band.
There's like a big local band or maybe not even local like regional
kind of >> music blaring near you. You can barely hear
anyone. There's not like dumb like drunk stumbling in between
you being like has anyone seen my boyfriend or some like it's
just like you know you get quality experiences with people that
you don't >> but that's like that is that's funny though.
That's okay. the girls that we were talking to or arguing with
>> be out there and experience
>> like it was so for example soul being pulled away one
of the people we're hanging out with being pulled away to go
and talk to some like cougar [__] like that's annoying
we've got a friend that's like I guess like been taken out the
out the friendship group or like been pulled away from us but
that's like worth it even though it's kind of annoying cuz it's
like a story to tell or it's a funny thing that happens >> I
guess for you sure >> what h Okay.
How many stories have come from us like going on a single night
out together where you turn up like a quarter to midnight and
we spend a little bit of time together compared to all of the
other times that you've met up with people? >> The time
you met up with me to go like shopping and then like go to dinner
>> or the time that you went to Queen with to go for for
a for a museum trip and then went to dinner.
>> To be fair, the two times I met with you guys solo,
once again, I was low energy. I was sick the New Year's thing.
Yeah, there that was a more eventful night, but I feel like there's
not been enough experience of like me at a normal baseline to
like interpret
um
>> like you are as a whole at every like at every environment.
And
>> wouldn't it be like really really like um reckless of
you to draw conclusions about me without sufficient data? Wouldn't
that be really reckless of you to draw conclusions about me without
sufficient data collected? That would be really reckless and
and irresponsible. >> I guess that's fair. >> Thank
you. >> But like another another thing that people are
like taking notice of by the way, which has kind of like been
neglected so far, is that like some of your justifications uh
for like why you behaved in certain ways just kind of seem like
completely apathetic, >> right? Like earlier you you seem
to have been like really annoyed at the uh at the fact that Halen
was trying to get a ring back for you that that you had lost.
And I think that you like inherently didn't value the ling the
ring, right? I didn't I didn't know.
>> Oh, the ring thing came up again. Not
Damn. Imagine being low energy going to the Holocaust Museum
with Quebean.
H. It wasn't the Holocaust Museum. Okay. They're both Why would
they go to the Holocaust Museum? BB Poison. It's like you're
not even paying attention.
Come on, man.
>> Oh, but but like the Somalian Holocaust. Yeah. When
the British went to Somalia, there was probably a holocaust for
them to be honest. >> That was that was probably pretty
bad. I don't I although I can be appreciative of somebody looking
for something for >> I didn't want her looking for me cuz
>> Oh, what the
>> What's up? >> Okay, can you hear me? My thing's
lighting up.
>> Yeah, I can hear you. Well, I can hear you now that
you said can you hear me? >> Oh [__] Yeah,
I said hello, but my thing didn't light up.
>> I think you were muted. It looked like you were muted.
>> Oh well.
rip. by now.
What's up? >> Yeah, I just saw you watching uh the the
London drama. >> Uh yeah. Yep. Yeah. I'm I got I got the
sheet with the talking points. I pointed out multiple times that
Aiden's like an NEPA baby freak. I've even slid in there that
Dickers is fat. He's getting fat. Done that in a couple times.
>> Have you heard the watch story? Have you Have you been
the watch story? >> The watch story. Yeah, I've heard the
watch story.
>> that's my favorite. I think that's my favorite one.
>> That's Yeah, that's a good one. You got any extra thoughts
on the watch story? Any behind the scene thoughts on the watch
story at all? >> Well, I did call in and speak to Aiden
about it earlier today.
>> Wait, did you propose your hypothetically? Have you
had a theory about that? Did you propose that theory to him?
>> No. No. And listen, Aiden's Aiden's feeling Listen,
I had that call with him earlier. He seemed like
your claws were out. This guy's feeling sensitive over the way
this trip's gone a little bit. So, [laughter] we'll take it easy.
Oh, well, he's not going to like my coverage. Hopefully, he Listen,
it's only on kick. It's not on YouTube. He might be able to just
avoid it. >> Yeah. It's when he started saying to me, it
was like uh when me and Perry are like making fun of him and
he's like, it's another excuse to for everyone to go after me
like I always do. It's like, okay, dude. I wish you could like
explain. I
I it might be lazy, but it's so much like Pirate Software that
it's like eerie when he's like the exact thing that he's doing
wrong is a thing he can't avoid doing again and again and
nothing like Pirates. Pirates Software is like a pride
middle-aged, you know, narcissist. Stay is just like a,
you know, Destiny fan 20-year-old who who wants to, you know,
seem like cool and detached all the time.
>> Yeah. But I think a lot of this comes out in like image
building. Like he Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Sorry. He's trying to
build himself up as this like cold cool guy, dude. Also, it's
like rough for him being in this community like where he's already
been the nerd that everyone picks on. Like I don't think you
can re people talk about it. You can't like reinvent yourself.
You can't like exist in a community and reinvent yourself. The
environment you're in will like kind of determine what you are
too.
>> I think you
I I think Aiden I I think you can definitely over time, you know,
kind of reit you can't you can't just go away and then come back
a different guy. But you can definitely over time change how
you're read and perceived. I think >> you can change, but
people like,
oh, it's like a thing where nobody will even notice a change,
right? That's how slow and gradual it would have to be. Like
people will just kind of forget. But I don't I don't think he
wants that. I think he wants to be a cool guy now. >> But
if he wants to be a cool guy now, I think he's got to go do something
else,
>> which like I don't think he should, by the way. I think
that's just fake. He's trying to be somebody he's not, >> right?
I don't think it's ever going to be a good cool guy. >> Yeah.
you're he's like a goofy but like there's nothing wrong there
is you can be a cool goofy funny guy.
There's nothing wrong with that.
Also, uh we got this. >> He's trying to be like like Dexter.
He's trying to be like Dexter, but he's like Larry David, you
know?
>> A little bit. Yeah, a little bit. But Larry David's
funny. You just got to But you got to be okay with who you are,
too. Sometimes life deals you a certain set of cards. Okay. Are
you ready for this? Have you Have you seen this?
Are are you looking at the presentation? Am I presenting? >> You
haven't got the presentation up, but I've got your stream up.
>> I'll I'll present. Should slide into
This is [__] up. I I I basically said I should probably
ban the person who came up with this.
[laughter]
>> It's It is It's like 20 years in the future. It could
be him.
>> What's look like Gman? What is going on?
>> Cuz I think they made his head massive. They like put
his head on this, but it's not the same scale. Okay, >> that's
crazy. That is crazy. >> Possible futures are receding.
Possible hairlines are receding. Okay. It's not
>> That's a >> He does kind of dress like Nania.
He He dresses a little bit like Nania and and Jarvin do. >> Oh
god. We shouldn't listen. He's already not doing good. I don't
I don't know if we can entertain this line of
like conversation on streets. >> They're like cool intellectuals.
Okay, that's what Aiden wants to be.
They're not cool intellectuals, but they're intellectuals.
Like the opposite of cool intellectuals,
dude. You think about Yarvin. Didn't Yarvin meet his wife through
like BDSM forums or something? He's like the exact kind of guy
who's in like a BDSM polycill or some [__] He's like
that exact dude. Libertarian weirdo. Like >> delusions
of grandeur. Yeah. I I don't know.
[__] Weird stuff. Anyway,
what are we What are we on to here? Oh, I'm watching him on this
call with Dickers. Dude, I said this earlier.
I get the feeling that eventually Dickers is gonna be the guy
who's like, "Okay, we have to stop making fun of Aiden and you
just did it here." I'm like, "Dude, Dickers went live yesterday
and for no reason just farm this watch story that didn't exist
and wasn't public and was only between the two of them." >> Like,
you can't you can't be like, "Nobody go after Aiden." And then
farm this story where you just make him sound like a totally
like antisocial freak like walks out of the store. Aiden brought
it on himself, you know. Aiden brought it on himself cuz he just
the moment people were gone and he got straight into Icy. He's
like sounding off about Hellbend and all this. So it's like,
you know, if if you're going to go and be like, "Oh, this person
is so annoying. This person," it's like you are talking about
social interactions that we've had and using them to make someone
look bad or feel bad. It's like you kind you kind of deserve
to get a little bit of the bit of the same treatment. But I feel
like before it went public even he also brought it onto his stream
I think first like I think he brought it onto his stream as well
and he didn't have to do that. I got the feeling just from like
some of the messages I saw or even just talking to you and some
other people involved that it was like he kind of got signals
from people like hey you weren't exactly the best either. You
should probably not talk about this. He just wanted to keep going
hard on it. Like he just couldn't drop it.
Um yeah, I don't know who brought it on stream first. I'm not
really sure how I think I thought it was um it all just spiraled
out of um his Perry who brought it on stream first. I think it
was but I'm saying that there were um there's a rule against
leaking his discord and this guy called Jimmy did like a stream
where he leaked Hellbent's message saying it's Aiden stop being
mean or whatever and uh so it all spiraled from there and people
started picking up bits of it
and going on stream and talk about it.
Yeah. Yeah.
I just think the call in stream was a lot and I like I said,
you went and talked to him like in his Discord. As far as I could
tell, that could have just been the end of it, right? Like, hey,
take the hint in the Discord that like you're not you're not
like without fault here, so maybe don't keep trying to defend.
>> Yeah, I saw Zena was unbanned, guys. Cover that in a
little bit. >> Oh, bad. >> Also, Aiden Aiden found
the um Aiden found the Soviet medallion thing now. He found it.
Yeah, I heard about it. I was I was lamenting that early on my
stream. I was like, I want I have this whole lie ready to go
that I was just going to totally make up out of nowhere >> that
he threw it away. I can't even What is funny though is that he
said he lost it and had hellbent running around looking for it
when he hadn't even looked for it properly. He just sort of assumed
he lost it and didn't didn't bother looking properly. And then
even when Hellbent is running around trying to find it for him,
he still just sat there like, you know, I didn't ask you to do
that. I didn't ask you to do that. tearing apart those random
drunk women's
>> That's where they were, right? Yeah. >> Yeah.
There's that. But also, I think she was she was calling like
the places we were at >> trying to see if he left it that
the last last day or two.
No, it wasn't a ring. It's a medallion from like was it the Russian
Olympics? Somebody said USSR. USSR Olympics some
>> Whatever. Whatever. Yeah. >> To go against thousands
of years of evolution to lose a coin. Okay.
>> Chill, chill, chill. Be chill.
>> Jesus [clears throat] Christ. >> Axe Spang.
>> Jesus Christ, dude. Yeah, apparently Zena got unbanned
from kick as well. Zena's unbanned. Misgif streaming random drama
on on kick as well. He just spent like two hours arguing with
his chat why he's totally and can never collab with people again.
It's good time. >> I'll collab with Miskf. I'll collab
with Miskf any day. Msk, reach out.
That's what I was saying is like he says nobody will collab with
him, but he just doesn't want to. He could easily go like Aiden
Ross did, find a bunch of like hundred to thousand viewer streamers
who could get like a huge boost from him, pull them on your stream.
They'll all be funny, right? They'll all be funny. They'll all
be willing to like do crazy [__] He could just farm
that up and make a ton of money. But he doesn't want >> too
lazy to do like that. Yeah. >> I I think he wants to go
back in time. He wants to be like the super cool guy who everyone
all the >> Yeah, that is it. He wants he doesn't want to
build anything up. He wants to just be placed back in the um
cool group and be able to, you know, have all the popular women
coming over and be on stream and all this. He just wants to be
placed back in it for sure. Yeah. >> And it's like, okay,
I hope he understands that literally Ambu could come out and
say, "I actually made all of this up. It was all fabricated.
Nothing, none of that happened." That won't happen because I
think a lot of it is true. But she could do that and he still
wouldn't move back in time. He still wouldn't be like fine. >> Yeah.
It's just like cope that he's holding on to the past. I don't
know. Kind of sad.
Whatever. Whatever. All right, let's uh let's continue on with
this. I'm trying to think. We got this and then there was a conversation
between you and Aiden as well today, right? You were on Perry's
stream you just said.
>> Yeah. Yeah. >> Oh, I got sent a picture. Wow.
That like Moscow. Does it say Moscow there in Russian? Wow.
I can't believe Aiden wouldn't treasure this completely.
so [__] up. I >> mean, he's such a big US saw
fan as
>> Is he actually? >> Yeah, he's a big Russia,
whatever the [__] you call it. >> Be honest.
Did Aiden go like, "We should all be smoking for this?" Did someone
say we should all be smoking for this? We should do a picture
where we're all >> Uh, I don't know. I I wouldn't be able
to I wouldn't be able to remember that. It certainly seemed like
that was the vibe. Like that was the idea. >> Well, you
can see Dicker's cigarette is isn't even lit. I don't even know
if Aiden's is either because he's got his his arm sort of positioned
ready to ready to light. You sort of see that he's he's grasping
a lighter in that hand just off the corner.
>> Yeah. Okay. Oh, no. Well, it's lit for this one at least.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah.
>> He's taking a drag while the photo's going off >> cuz
he actually smokes cuz he he's not just doing it for the photo
cuz he really smokes. >> This queen small.
Yeah, he's doing some insane forced uh forced perspective stuff
here to make himself look the same height as everybody else.
>> I am actually sat on something, but I'm like one one
or two inch shorter than the shortest of them, I think.
>> I had no idea. Wait, what? How tall are you? You apparently
people are like He said like eight different heights on his >> I'm
5'5. >> Is there an official 5'5? Okay. Well, you're just
like Nick, man. You're just like Fuentes completely. Yeah. >> Same
same dude. It's crazy.
All right. Okay.
Where is I watch this? We're back to this. You to watch this
for a little bit or did you just want to get a word in or what?
>> Oh, no. I'm happy to watch this. Okay. >> First
of all, I would never It It is like humiliating to have someone
else looking for your
right. It that is like humiliating. I would never want someone
to be looking for my thing if I was the one. Besides Bes Okay.
Uh, this is the person who was it Jar who hung out with this
person? It wasn't Jar. Somebody goat. Goat Kau.
>> it's Zayen's new girlfriend. >> But wasn't this
the person I remember her being in some >> who am I thinking
of?
>> She was with um she she dated um Birdie.
Yeah, she's in one of those dramas where she was like in calls
and with this with this like
>> short stack goblin avatar.
>> No, no, that's Romantic Goblin. That's a different person.
>> Oh, that's who I'm thinking of then. Okay, never mind.
Never mind. Never mind. Okay. >> Yeah. So, so they're all
from the same circles. Romantic goblin was the one who was hanging
out with Kumo, who helped with the cine stuff. Uh, this person
>> Kumo
Kumo videos is where I remember that person from.
>> he calls Akuma all the time. Okay. >> This person
dated Sine's X. So Sine's
X birdie Jack whatever the name is.
>> This person dated them years ago.
>> Yeah. They're like I don't know if they're quite but
yeah they're like some >> I think we talked about how they're
like too even understand. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Aiden's fixing
or something.
>> Aiden's fixing to be content for Becket pretty soon,
isn't he? That's like >> Aiden Aiden's content for everyone
right now. Aiden's decided that way. Go J.
>> Dude, when he's when he's opening up the stream and
he's like, "You guys are such losers. I can't believe you guys
you guys care about this. Why do you care about this?" It was
worse on Paris before that when he's just like l
Why does anyone even like this? Why does anyone enjoy this? It's
like, bro, you if people were like,
"Wa, Aiden, this ACC Lo Convoy content is the most amazing content
ever. It's so amazing." Like, that's total [__] as
well. That's just a bunch of mentally disabled people on Discord,
but he would be like so happy if everyone was celebrating that.
But because it's something that makes him look silly, he's like
really anal about it.
Is any of the Wait, is any of the Leo Convoy stuff because I've
noticed Aiden just does this stuff like every night. I've seen
in his title every single night I've seen him stream. So, for
the past I want to say three months. Like honestly, just about
every night. But I've not I don't see anybody else covered. Is
it good content? >> No, that sucks. Becket used to cover
it a lot. >> But Becket's sort of been a part been through
it now.
>> But it's it's all just because the Leo convoy like wronged
Goat at some point. So now Aiden has to like, you know, make
make Leo pay for ruining Gokat's life. >> Wild, wild, wild.
Oh, I'm You're suddenly getting me interested in it, but for
like a different reason. So talk into this and see what's going
on there. Okay.
All right. >> Besides me losing my phone in the Uber.
>> Yeah. Yeah. But why? But why does this That's crazy.
Okay. That's a content eye from Dickers right there, right? To
catch that in the chat. Pull that up. Pull that up on stream.
>> Yeah. Some people just have low social boundaries and
first smaller groups. Shrug. Shrug.
>> Is it like why is it like such a why is it such a nuisance
to you? Why is it so bothering? Because
like the apartment we were in, I wanted to leave. I wanted to
leave. And by her >> dude, also when Dickers does join
this call finally, the first thing Aiden does go does is go,
"Dickers, you can confirm that I'm like a normal guy, right?
I'm like totally normal. I've never done I'm not weird. I'm not
weird, right?
How are my socializing skills? Dicker's just like, "Uh, fine.
I guess
>> on finding my valueless ring despite me asking her,
begging with her to please just leave it alone." >> Mhm.
[clears throat] >> It was prolonging
the discomfort of being in these people's apartment. >> I
feel like if I had have done that for you, I don't think you'd
have complained nearly as much. >> I would have said no,
I would have said to you. I've never I I'm not use as a serious
complaint. I just said during the moment, leave it. Leave it.
Just please leave it.
>> What about Okay.
So then why is this even like a >> complaint?
No, I mean I feel like if I'd have done it, it wouldn't have
been a >> Like it was like obsess. It wasn't just looking
for It was like she was obsessively like turning over the couch.
I just looked for it. I just went my I said to her, "Please just
leave it. Just leave it." >> The way you tell this story
though, hold on, GMA. The way you told this story though is as
if she's like cutting
>> actually kind of critical content right here or critical
context rather. >> Hellbent says we were waiting for an
Uber anyway like oh you're just like time and nobody's even sitting
in the room you're in anymore like nobody's going to do anything
else in there. >> Yeah. It's like uh I don't know if we
were quite waiting for the Uber if it had been ordered yet or
what but yeah we were sort of on the way out you know. >> Open
the sofa cushions and keeping the sofa up. But she was turning
she was literally turning the couch upside down. I said to her,
"Please leave." >> But And when you say that, you mean
she was like lifting the sofa cushions to look underneath the
sofa cushions. >> She was like throwing them on top of
each other. These people had were in somebody else's house. I
never feel comfortable doing that. They had stuff on their couch.
Stuff was going on top. I just said leave it. It wasn't even
going to be there.
>> Um wait, Aiden, hold on. Just just like just so like,
you know, for the sake of comparison or for the sake of like
uh contrast here. uh do you not do you like how do you think
you know uh Helman feels about you essentially uh I want to say
and in the lightest way possible her uh to I I guess I could
argue that the people in this environment are peers like right
like the people in IC chat the people in this community uh right
a lot a lot of like YouTubers were in that uh well it might have
just been
complaining about her >> maybe Ignore me feel free >> yeah
yeah like like do you not think that it's like you know there
should be some sort of like you know I want to say uh equalizer
there right like you you felt humiliated but do you not think
that it's like 10 times more humiliated humiliating to just be
negative for no >> I agree
>> see this is the problem this is the problem what you're
saying would make sense and it'd be empathetic if we were like
anywhere else if we're anywhere >> well no it just see
like like sure but like in this case there seems to be like real
world ties to this right it seems like this entire time it seems
like this entire time you have not valued anything that that
could have potentially done for you. >> I've had to state
this every time I meet people. If I meet you in real life, I
don't value you any more than if we've just talked online. I'm
going to value you based on how much we know each other. Meeting
you in real life doesn't bring our connection for me to some
like we're bonded now or some, you know what I mean? >> Yeah.
Nobody's nobody's nobody's saying that though. I mean, ignore
the argument that Soul was doing earlier.
>> I know. I know. Okay. So, ignore that cuz that's
G if you want to go. Yes. Uh I I think what I'm asking you is
>> I just
does does A Z Z A Z A Zen at least acknowledge like the optics
of just debate broing people going you're kind of weird in real
life
like there probably just is no winning that at any point >> he
think he thinks weird >> he legit thinks he's doing like
you know I I don't want to make the comparison I don't want to
make the comparison
>> but he thinks he's like >> he's that he thinks
he's >> he's seen a lot of videos online of people in social
interactions who get celebrated by massive audiences. They're
trying to debate, bro, the most
social faux parts and turn them into wins against the people
there. They've been hanging out with uh he's seen a lot of that
online. I think it's set in in his head and he he just sees himself
playing that out.
>> Would you say he's like, you know, got a really different
lifestyle from most people that he wouldn't recommend, but it
works for him because he's kind of just built different. >> Yeah,
I'm just kind of like unique. You know, most people aren't like
me. But um >> is that typically when you meet in real life,
right? There there's typically like extra arbitrary boundaries
that I guess just aren't written in stone, right? Like like typically
people when they're go to
Didn't Tom Foolery make this same mistake? Well, we haven't seen
Aiden leak nudes of his girlfriend yet and then try to say that
they were a trans man. So,
uh Aiden's at least, you know, he's batten a little little better
than Tom Fury so far. >> Parties and they meet somebody
they don't like because this is actually an extremely common
occurrence. They don't immediately turn around and like have
like, you know, a a 15 to two hour diet tribe. Diet tribe. >> I
was complaining. SOMEBODY ELSE THEN SPOKE. I I No, I just went.
This is the part that's infuriating. It was just >> Hold
on. Hold on. Slow down. I'm
>> dude. It was literally It was just like a normal like
she's like annoying as like she's like annoying as it was like
a 2hour. People are acting like I joined VC. I called everyone
together. We need to talk about this problem because this is
getting out of hand. It was like no. I was like I was like annoying.
Then people called in to talk about it which is what prolonged
it. >> Prolonged it. Yes. Yes. That's what I'm saying.
Complaint the length was totally normal relative to how complaints
or and people in VCs goes in this community. That was all totally
normal.
>> Yeah. But like what what saying here is like that's
like
typically people don't do that and it's kind of like you know
uh again uh kind of like if you
people typically do do that in this community. Okay. No, no,
no. I'm not saying about this community, dickers. I'm very much
comparing this to real life interactions that people have with
each other. Typically, people keep their business to >> I'm
not It's not like we're high school buddies. Like, that's what
I'm getting at. Like, we are in this community whether I'm meeting
you in real life or not. We know each other through this. Like,
this is how we know each other.
I do think that at minimum
Aiden would have to admit, he'd have to just agree that if he's
going to go vent about Hellbent, he really can't complain about
the other people on the trip venting about him, right? That he's
going to just have to deal with all of those
Like there there has to at least be that level of reciprocation
he accepts,
>> Yeah. If he's going to be going and telling like, you
know, his whole Discord about it, then Yeah. Yeah. Well, especially
because like his discord is, you know, there's a lot of people
who maybe aren't primary Aiden watchers who would be in Icy Chat,
right? Like I'm sure a lot of the I'm sure a lot of people from
my Discord, your Discord would be in Icy Chat. >> The old
spicy people are in there. Yeah. And there's, you know, just
a lot of, you know, content creators and it's not like it's a
you can say no leaking, but everyone knows like it's is everyone
relevant to
Aiden's little corner. So, >> yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. for
sure. >> So Aiden,
the fact that Queman has been going on very very long diet tribes
about how you're completely asocial,
complete killjoy, won't join in the conversation, sulking in
the corner. That's a nasty thing to say, right? That's not made
you feel very good. And maybe if you met up with Queen in the
future, that might make you feel slightly self-judgmental or
really self-conscious if you were meeting up with him again.
>> You guys got plans, by the way? >> We do.
No. >> Especially given the fact that you're meeting that
wouldn't >> the comments that Quimman has made would not
make you think. I know this is a lie. I don't know why you're
I don't know why you're lying. >> I swear on my lying,
>> dude. Tickers can't even can't even with this guy.
>> You're Are you saying none of this has upset you? Literally
right before this, like on his own stream, he's like, "There's
only one person I won't talk to, and it's Queen right now." It's
like,
you're obviously annoyed. You're obviously annoyed.
Why are you just saying no? No, I would never get annoyed about
that. He could say whatever he >> I I swear on my live
I >> It would not make you feel more
>> I would not be criticizing myself. No.
>> Him. Him. No. >> That's another story. Would I
be Would I be a critical? [laughter] >> Yes. Myself? No.
>> Swear on my life. >> Sure. If you if you don't
think that it would like chill your reaction or I guess chill
your ability to like have fun or kind of engage in the
or want to even be social just let stuff go for a little bit
>> like make jokes, bring up topics, point things out.
>> Yeah. Do like silly like like night out
>> That wouldn't kill that at all for you. >> Wait,
what were you saying? Gamma >> that that also works the
other way around because don't you think like that some of these
complaints that you had in this VC
that's uh I know you don't love Dicker's faces but that's like
that's from his >> that also works the other way
>> like like
Aiden just went away he did a whole thing trying to make a point
>> he's trying to make a point and a Dickers just got sent
okay Dickers >> don't you think like that some of these
complaints that you had in this VC immediately after the fact
like you know chilled the way that these people interacted with
each other. Like, do you not think that Queen might have potentially
been adverse to uh asking Helen out to hang out with you guys
because she might have been? >> You wouldn't be adverse
to asking Helen out, would you?
>> Potential issue for you to hang out.
>> Interpretation that he got presumably >> the way
he phrased it. >> There's going to be drama.
I think like saying is like
>> Aiden Aiden's basically made it so you can't you can't
>> invite
Hellbent and Aiden to the same >> because Aiden's made
it clear that
you know it's going to cause an issue
>> which is like fine. You just probably should make that
clear publicly or I don't know. You just don't have to Yeah.
You don't have to go or h It's like the same dude. I don't want
to do another comparison. Do you remember when a certain person
was complaining about
Pisco and then Pisco's like, "What do you want me to do about
it?" And they're like, "Nothing." You man like totally antisocial
or deranged freak.
>> It's like, "Dude, just say just say what you want. Don't
Don't do a whole song and dance about how this person is cuz
you don't even care about that. Just say what you want. I want
to hang out with this person again. I'm not hanging out with
this person again. that >> if you're coming, don't don't
don't bring this person. If if we're going to do something, don't
tell this person. Just say that.
>> Yeah. It's so It's so simple. >> No, cuz he only
knew there was a problem after he had left. >> That's not
true.
>> Queen asked you to hang out when we hung out and you
said you didn't want to hang out with Quean. At least not early
on or you left him on. >> Dude, Dickers knows what he's
doing. He's pretending to be like the nice guy with all these
people and then he just drops a little bomb like that in just
like leaks out for no reason. Just like you said you didn't want
to hang out with Queen at all. >> You explained later.
>> You explained later that you didn't you aired Queen
because if he if you hung out with him in the day he would likely
>> you let him know later on that if if you'd have invited
him out, Hellbent would have joined you. So it did it did it
did impact it did impact the social interaction.
No, the question was what I was I leading Quan to have reservations.
Not did not was I having like I agree with you that I didn't
invite him for that reason. Right. But I wasn't doing anything
that was that led him to have that adversity about like inviting
her cuz he was gone when I would have admitted that that's why
I didn't ask
>> Right. So it probably would have had a have a chilling
effect on Quimman kind of inviting both of you except for the
fact that he just didn't know. >> Yeah. Yeah, but when
he was already gone, I was fine saying it. >> Okay. So,
so then there would be there would have been you acknowledge
there would have been a chilling effect. >> No, I think
Hold on. I think
I think Queven Hold on. Hellbent saying that's an unreasonable
logical leave. I don't think it is. I assume that if Aiden was
like complaining about you, Hellbent, and Quean knew that. I
assume he would actually go out of his way to make sure you came
along. I feel like he'd be like, "Here's where we're going to
be." No, Aiden says it's fine. >> Fact, right? >> There
could have been. >> That'd be very funny. Uh typically
people avoid having like you know interactions or confrontations
like this because of the chilling effect because people you know
usually don't want to cause issues or stir drama to make people
like you know have adverse you know reactions to each other.
Well well no that's just that's just your basic socialization.
That's how people typically are basic which is what people are
criticizing you normally loser
>> Okay. Okay. But like that's exactly the contention that
people have. That is exactly the issue. It doesn't seem like
you want to acknowledge or or even address the fact that you
might be the
I think I'm the problem if like I'm going into these and I'm
like like why are people >> Wait, hold on. I will say
>> I will say that you you are Wait, wait, no, no. I will
say that you're objectively correct in saying that uh because
you do acknowledge that there might be, you know, a level of
issue here that you can just like remove yourself from the equation
and let them have a fun time on their own. I will say that you
objectively don't want to hang out with me, that's like fine.
>> I will say that that is like the most correct thing
you've said throughout this entire situation.
>> Is this an intervention? It's just more of Aiden trying
to prove that he's like
>> Nothing. Ain't nothing got to change.
>> It's just it's just preference
tapes. >> like [laughter] I'm the issue in so far as there
it is
>> crazy saying has finally cracked from >> They
choose not to, >> you know, I understand why that might
be offputting to some people. Um, and then they can I get that
my personality
>> is
not going to is not going to be compatible with a lot of people's,
right? And if people choose not to I don't think they're bad
people or or something is wrong, if they don't want to hang out
with me as a result of that, I wouldn't blame them, right?
>> Yeah. But you feel as though you're being treated unfairly
by other people having an issue with it. No. >> No. It's
not them having an issue in regards to like saying like,
oh, like my It depends on the Hold on. Depends on what specifically
you're referring to because there were specific um there were
like people that were saying it as though it wasn't a matter
of like subjectivity. There were people that were coming at it
as like there was like specifically like some wrongdoing on my
part or some error on my part. And I think when it came down
to like calling out those specific errors, uh they weren't talking
about, hey, this doesn't align with my own social preference.
>> Holy [__] I don't know how much more of
this I'm going to watch. This is getting >> says they were
like actually arguing for some wrongdoing on my end. I don't
think anybody's arguing from like a moral point of view that
they feel as though you've I don't know like uh like broken some
kind of I don't know moral statute. It just seems like people
think you've been a bit of a dick.
>> Yeah. So they think I've done something wrong, right?
>> Dude, I don't know. I think it does feel like you people
don't feel like you did anything morally bad. They just think
you were like in the wrong and and being a dick. Like those are
maybe not persistent, but they are bad. You would say you'd have
to say they're bad. I think the love and support Aiden.
You would extreme dad. You would given all of his analogies he's
used so far. >> We do. We do love Aiden. We do love >> What
do you >> We do love Aiden. >> I think Aiden's fine.
I think this is I don't know why he's
I don't know why he keeps doubling down on all this stuff. Apparently,
this is from This says today. It's almost 21 hours ago. Oh, this
would be I thought Perry just finished streaming, but I guess
I've been live. This kind of this kind. Sorry. But yeah.
Well, we got this and then we have you eventually join.
Is this four hours and then let me see when this time stamp is
>> Why didn't you
>> then we got this time stamp which is at 4 hours 20 minutes.
You're like 20 >> First of all, the comment you just made
was the most ironic ever. You can't criticize anyone for going
out when you look like the when you look like the notion of like
dynamic exercise.
the is Perry looking at? >> This is a foreign concept to
you. You're grotesqually fat. So, we know that you don't go out
when you're not on >> And yet,
>> bro, Perry,
>> I'm sorry. You can tell by the way Perry walks that
he'd be a fun hangout. Like, it'd be super fun to hang out with
him. >> this guy just let bounce around. >> Perry's
coming to the [clears throat] UK >> He looks like he'd
be so funny to hang out with. Like, I'm I'm sorry.
Perry lost weight. No, Perry's got
Dude, I I probably shouldn't comment, okay? I am like a PNG tuber.
Is >> there some reviewer coping that he's lost weight
right now? Is that >> he lost weight? I will say Perry
doesn't look heavy from his face. You would never expect Perry
got deceptive. He's deceptive. Okay. >> And yet
when you are and you don't go,
>> It's all in the gut.
>> It's It's like Yeah. It's It's pretty crazy. you are
as well. So, it's two for two on your >> I think that's
like high tea is like women get like fat everywhere. Dudes, they
get fat like in the in the tummy. Okay. Paris has got that big
>> that high tea gut.
>> No, I It's actually 300 p.m. I was I just saw St. Paul
St. Paul's Cathedral. You You're like the You're
out every single hour of the day. >> Every single hour.
every single hour of the day. Right. Right. Right. >> Vacation
is literally you do what you want because it is it is literally
it is vacation. Like it's like what's the point of vacation if
you have some dumb European [__] in your ear the
whole time being like you should be doing this on your vacation.
You should be doing it's not your vacation right now. >> There's
no way. There's no way he's still coping on this like trying
to This is actually a secondary thing to the Hellbent thing where
he does this like vice signaling where he's like I actually am
a total loser and that's great. I love being a total loser that
I do find annoying and genuinely like
I'm kind of done with everybody who does this kind of thing where
they're like yeah I do suck. I am the worst. I am a [__]
loser. It's like and that's cool. It's like, okay, you could
say all of that and sincerely mean that it's like not good or
you could say all that like you think it's kind of funny and
cool, like you're asmin gold. Don't be Asthma Gold. Gay. It's
gay. Just >> It depend. It It just depends what it is.
I think it there's like some things where it's like fine to kind
of be like,
>> you know, be like, "Oh, I don't I don't care about this
thing that normal people care about."
But situations like this where it's like um
the the thing is this is such a common way for like
teenagers
and young adults to feel especially online ones where they're
like, "Oh, who even cares about vacation? Who cares? We're going
to see what's even the point." You know, it's it's like you see
it and either people know people that have been like that or
have been like that a little bit themselves and you can just
so clearly see it's just like a product of him being like 20
and uh and kind of a rich kid.
It's just like insuff if it felt like it was more of a, you know,
something he'd actually come to know about himself, it may it
may land better. But it's not something he's just come to know
about himself. It's him being a petulant kid.
>> It is him being a petulant child. Cuz like I was >> Same
with Asold. Asmin Gold's the same, right? He doesn't live in
filth because he's come to this realization about himself that
oh, I'm just fine living like this. He's like some wretched mentally
ill freak who talks about laying down and anxiety attacks for
hours after his stream and not being able to stream on his main
channel because of the pressure it brings and all this sort of
the idea that it's
like a monk that just doesn't care. Just not >> I was going
to Yeah, I was going to say it's more just pure mental illness
with asthma gold, not like a Like it's it's crazy how much pathology
there is there with Asen Gold like that he tries to normalize
and explain like why he doesn't need to get treatment for. But
um with Aiden, I was going to say I I totally understand.
I've definitely gone on vacations and like canceled what I was
doing for the day because I just didn't feel like doing it. I
was like, "Dude, I'm kind of kind of beat taking this vacation.
I need a vacation from the vacation for a second." But it's like
I would never go, "Oh, that's awesome. That was that's what makes
me cool." I That's what's annoying to me.
God, losing my voice, too.
Well, anyway, I think it's like totally fine. It's just weird
to be like, "No, I'm awesome cuz I do this. Don't tell me what
to do." Like, just go be just go have fun, man. That's all you
got to do. [__] that. What? >> Right. And what
you want to do is be an antisocial freak. >> An antisocial
freak. That's what you want to do. >> You keep using this
buzz word. This is >> antisocial. Yeah, it's a buzz word.
It doesn't mean anything. It's just a madeup word. >> Terrorist.
Terrorists. Terrorists. Terrorists. We all engage in antisocial
behavior to some extent. >> Yeah, you're engaging in it
to a delterious degree to you and everyone else around you. To
you and everyone else around you is actually like totally useless
engagement and a lack of a contribution. That's because >> when
we dive into the specific you know what you do you know what
you do when we dive into the specific when we dive into the specific
public you >> I've been on this I've been there day >> taking
on a position. You saw >> Oh me I've been on your ass about
this since Balta. You're going to say I'm taking a position.
Give me a [__]
anyone in this whole situation. >> It is kind of rough
for Aiden that [clears throat and cough] Perry's like one of
the three people who could be like I met you in real life. I
know you're a weirdo too, >> right? Like he he's fallen
back to that a couple of times. Like I've been complaining about
this problem with you
>> You made me you made me like hell. >> This is
you're going back and forth. You're trying to throw us against
each >> Respect
because I had respect. I had respect for you in the sense of,
oh, this guy doesn't bend over backwards for what everyone else
is thinking. Okay, that's that's totally fair. Then you go, >> wait,
one second. One second. One >> I do respect that about
Perry. [clears throat] Like everybody thought Brandon Buckingham
definitely was sick and in a hospital and Perry was like, I don't
respect, [laughter] do you think? I don't I don't respect that.
I'll say what I want.
>> Firebats. What do you mean
>> by that? Thank you for showing me. What do you mean
by that? Firebats. Is everything okay? Do you want to to hash
this out? All right, Aiden, please
>> Sorry, I had to cuz there was I was doing a drama and
the person I was talking about was came in and you're kind of
calling. So, what were you saying, Aiden? Could you repeat that?
>> I don't even [__] Oh, yeah. >> So,
what did I say? I heard
>> So, just to be clear, uh, calling someone annoying is
actually really normal for this community. If you're upset about
Yeah. But it's not about you calling them annoying. It's about
you engaging with this person, being antiso, and then like [__]
talking them. And then it's like you're doing it as a >> Try
to try to make a criticism, try Okay, so instead of doing a vague
like broad label like des call it specifically what it is. What
was
>> Okay. So what was antisocial about you being in London?
The just Well, there's a variety of things. I mean a lot of them
when people bring them up you seem to get banned. Just don't
drop. Just don't drop
the buzz word. Keep using the buzz word. >> What's antisocial
about you? Let me answer. The only complaint that people actually
have about the nature of my interactions at the time was that
I was like a little bit quiet and unenthusiastic at certain points.
So like so you know >> the problem is the problem
is going to like is going to have like a bit is going to have
like a bigger like emphasis to it and it's going to say >> well
not just that by the way it's the fact that you were late that
you were late. It's the fact that you know you were just like
demanding stuff and the fact that like it's like every single
story about you. >> What was I demanding? Wait, what was
I >> We have to go to this restaurant. We have to go to
this restaurant. No, you have to go this one. >> No, I
didn't say that. I I got a reservation. Nobody contested it.
And then right before >> the parts where you weren't dancing,
the parts where you weren't dancing and not having a good time.
The part where you were being dismissive at the antisocial
mongaloid was honest. If you were honest, what you would say
is you weren't dancing, which anyone observing from the outside
wouldn't care because >> it's about the It's about just
your your attitude to everything you were doing. Based on what
I heard any mind to [__] like that. That's like >> based
on what I heard. No, based on what I heard, every time you do
something, you go to bars. >> You want to look at somebody.
>> Aiden's so lucky that he lives in an era where he can
stream. Oh, wait. [clears throat] His parents are rich. I just
feel like if Aiden was the guy who was like at a company,
just like a random company, let's say it's like the late 80s,
early 90s, and he had to go and be social with people as a part
of the job. You know how like old companies used to have to go
out after work, you'd have like a pint with the boys from work
for a little bit. I feel like Aiden would be in that society.
Okay, >> he's lucky he's in this one. >> In that
it's just like >> I just I don't even to talk to people
being awkward. >> It's a total cope to say, "Oh, I don't
dance. I don't dance. Shut the up. It's such cope. It's uh Yeah.
Again, I see that he is like every young online a person.
It is like Yeah, pretty much exactly that. I don't dance. I don't
drink. Could you imagine wasting your time like Well, I guess
he does drink. You imagine wasting your time dancing? Could you
imagine wasting your time going to the gym? Could you imagine
wasting your time like
trying to date women? Could you imagine all the normal things
people do to like function in society? Could you imagine wasting
your time with stuff like that? I just like talking about like
trans issues on the internet like okay well very fulfilling
was half the commentary community at the club doing the gritty
in a circle um yes that's the whole point that's the whole point
yes half the commentary community what well and dickers were
there and then another guy and hellbent like five of them all
right Chudlo logic was invited becket was invited they decided
not to spend New Year's Eve with Chud like has a stupid family
or something. And
I don't know what Becket's doing. I think I think Chud was Let's
be real. Chud was sitting there waiting by the phone, waiting
by the Discord, thinking Dior was going to call.
>> One more time. >> One more time. >> One
more time. He He bought Arc Raiders. He saw Nick was playing
Arc Raiders on Steam. He bought Arc Raiders. He's like, I know
he's going to call. He's going to We'll We'll do it. It'll happen
again.
>> Actually antisocial. It's you. >> Me? I'm antisocial.
How's that? How's that, Aiden? >> Yes. You engage in behaviors
that actively def like defy the rights of others who like >> defy
the rights of others. >> Yeah. [__] >> cuz
I took that picture of you. Is that what it's about? Or is it
the >> people know inherently an antisocial would be going
through so much without their permission like like that, right?
There would be there's no like that's antisocial.
This type of behavior is
>> asocial. this type is more like you're just like being
like an introvert. You're being shy. You're not dancing. If you
were to actually describe it like that instead of using a buzz
word because you have no idea what the is going on. So you think
using this vague term will make it look like >> Well, I
have an understanding of your circumstances and they are desri
>> uh Aiden
I feel like his conversation with this woman about psychology
sort of defeats all the um asocial I'm just shy stuff to be honest
with you. like he's talking to some random woman about her degree,
entertaining small talk. He's showing every social capability
and then as soon as he has to do it to like fit in with this
group that he's kind of annoyed with, he it all shuts off, right?
The second he needs it to shut off, it shuts off. >> Little
like asking him to, you know,
it changes engagement. It really is more
how are you going to why are you making a massive issue about
this other person who has tried to facilitate like everything
every step of the way when you are such a prick all the time
you
>> It's like be feel free to be a prick but
at least don't start attacking people just tried to help out
the whole time.
>> Make some plans. Set up a you know he set up the reservation.
He didn't want Hellbo to go to the reservation he had then maybe
that's his right. Okay.
>> Yeah. Exactly. He should have said that as well. If
he didn't want didn't want Hellbent. So
>> No Hellbent's not coming here.
>> Becket didn't know there would be a hideous two out
of 10 the part of track. Sorry. I started reading that message
and I realized I shouldn't be reading that message as I started
reading it. I was like, "Oh, some comment about that kid." And
I was like, "Oh, I shouldn't read that. [laughter]
Dude, by
aso. My bad. Asocial. My bad. >> And I called the woman
annoying. And the >> You did call her annoying. No, you
cried about She was being nice and nice to you and you decided
to [__] talk cuz you're a [__] [__]
You're a [__] [__] You couldn't say anything
to her face. You couldn't say anything to her face. I just called
her Yeah. Like a loser. Like a loser. Unfairly, unreasonably,
and you didn't handle it properly in person. >> You know
what? I'll do it again. >> Yeah. You try to kick a chat
out of it after seething over this for hours and you deny the
fact that you called her that. Basically, what did I say?
Nicole, I say it to you. You're just like
on the internet. >> I'm saying no. I say you're wasting
your life. That's what I'm really saying. I'm trying to get you
to like see you're wasting your life. >> To call. >> Yeah.
Why you sound antisocial? Cuz you're like wasting your life and
you're like harsh for everyone else. >> Such a [__]
You're such a fat. >> Then just act this way.
[clears throat] >> Dude, what do you mean seething? You're
such a fat [__] YOU'RE SUCH A FAT. I'm just like,
dude, [laughter] that's probably what he means by saying everyone.
Let them take you as the boss OF THE TRUTH. I UNDERSTAND HOW
you're saying that your entire life you've been sh on and now
all of a sudden all of a sudden all of a sudden for some reason
you're allow you're like the expert in social interactions when
you admit yourself your entire life you've been the bottom of
the joke >> to death meatball. >> You've been the
bottom of the hierarchy and all of a sudden you want to pretend
you understand what it means to be in social conversation. >> No,
I'm not the >> That's what you said. That's what you said.
You said that when you were in group chats, when you were hanging
out in commentary group chats with Keemstar [__]
you were the one getting chats on and you just like took it.
You just sat there and took it. And now because Hellbent doesn't
want to just like let >> took it. >> Yeah, that's
what you say. You sat You used to sat there and take it and now
cuz Hellbent is like setting up for herself after you're like
[__] talking her. She's doing the wrong. That's what
you're saying. >> How is she standing? I called her annoying.
There's no standing up for >> Well, no, but you said it
was just banter. You said it was just banter.
You know, I've repeatedly emphasized that I find her annoying.
This is a lie. And you could verify that this is a lie because
this is an opinion I've reemphasized for a year now in a serious
light. You can engage in banter in a manner that also maintains
some like serious tones like finding
though. If you're like going to go up to somebody and you're
going to [__] them and then they're like, "Okay,
you're mad at [__] Are you okay with us?" And you're
[__] mad at her for her and about the >> So
you never spoke to her. So you never spoke to her. You shot talk
her. She came up to you and was like, "Do you have a problem
with me, Aiden? You have a problem with me, Aiden." >> So
when somebody's like a dishonest [__] fat that doesn't
know how to argue, they need to rely on the literal wording of
statements instead of like
you. That's literally up and saying to her, "Everybody knows
what you meant in that context. Don't like back."
>> Perry just got a crazy build. You [clears throat] would
never be able to tell he's fat from like um yeah from him like
from just his camera.
It's like
I don't know how to explain it cuz it's like comical again. >> He
just looks jolly. He looks like a cool guy. I would want to hang
out with this guy for sure. >> Track and play stupid. >> Yeah,
it means you were saying these things to her. It means you were
saying these things to her. >> Especially stupid. >> You're
the one being like too literal with this. I'm saying you spoke
to her and you said one thing and then she asked for fabrication
and you criticize her for that. You criticize her for that. That's
like ridiculous.
happened either you [__] research >> the research.
Well, you're a lie. When you're saying one thing, other people
are saying other things. >> Can you tell me? Can you >> I
feel like it's not really I feel like if you want to do this,
if you're a person getting criticized, you should probably have
some way to like help people to what you think the interpretation
should be. You shouldn't just be able to say that's not what
happened only and then stop there. Just be like smoke and and
like poke holes and everything and never say like what actually
happened or why you think people are criticizing you. You probably
should have to say something to like I don't know. Give give
people or I don't know, maybe not. But I I feel like if you don't,
then you're basically just saying you're not really you didn't
do anything wrong. >> And I I don't think Aiden can really
maintain that position.
>> Lay out the version of events. Lay out the version of
events. >> Well, which version of which events? I'm saying
at some point Helen comes up to you and you said, "I don't like
when people are being sincere. I don't like when people are being
too sincere and are asking you if we're having fun or not." and
she does something along those lines to you and you cry about
it, but then you reveal later that you weren't bantering. You
actually didn't. You didn't like her. You didn't like her company.
So, you weren't bantering, but then she came up to you clarify
and you criticized her part. >> No. No. Another lie. Completely
wrong. >> No lie. It's either Mr. Explain the problem,
[__] Problem, you [__] >> Out now.
What are we on now? Time. Can you do anything right? Can you
like do anything right? >> I could go on vacation properly.
I'll tell you that much. I'll tell you that >> Details
wrong, dude. You get the most >> I can buy a watch properly.
I can buy a watch properly. I can do that as well. You can buy
I know but I know it doesn't sound impressive and yet to you
it is to you it is. >> So can I watch what >> except
with a lot of struggle with a lot of struggle you know after
a few hours after a few hours of fiddling fiddling with your
little watch making sure it's you know taking enough blood flow.
Maybe eventually you can get it. I can eat dinner without slamming
my wine. >> Unfunny complete failure.
>> Just no response. No respond. Literally can't buy a
watch properly. They're asking people what I can do. I can buy
I can buy clothes probably. Explain the ins. Wait, what? What
says I can't buy a >> Probably the part where you're like
Probably the parts where you go and buy a watch and then afterwards
you should the assistant cuz she didn't she didn't know what
you meant when you said you wanted to throw away a box. Probably
all of that part. Probably all the ridiculous insane.
I swear to God if you just got something else wrong, I'm going
to [__] lose it. What? >> Just no response
by it. So you were being a weird freak. Did you really just get
a minor
story about me being wrong? Did you Did you really just get a
minor detail about this story wrong?
>> Bad faith are the ones who have to take things literally
and not take the implied meanings of things. Yeah. >> It's
like both in the same conversation. >> Fighting for his
life. He's fighting for his life.
>> Properly. Well, see for one, you wanted to buy the display
item of the stuff at the back of the house. For second, you were like,
"Are you sure the box away?" Like for some like extremely strange
asks. For third, as soon as you left, you were sitting at the
sales assistant because of how she was uh treating you. Holy
cow, >> when did this happen? I >> was That's what
Dickers said. So, you were [laughter] >> Dude, I knew that
Aiden might not have seen that conversation. I had a feeling
that he thought Dickers was like on his side and I was like,
"Dude, there's no way he knows that Dickers leaked that additional
story." But you're a [__] or whatever. He just made
it up that he liking or being hyperbolic. Do you know what? You're
such a [__] >> Oh, he's No, he's lying. And
that's on me. So, when he tell Did you even see him tell the
story? >> Just so everybody know, >> Dickers did
not make it seem like Aiden was joking. Dickers made it seem
like that was serious. It sounded like you could infer that Aiden
might be joking.
But Dickers was like, "I don't know what's wrong with this guy."
He kept saying these, "Hey, I don't I don't think he made it
obvious. It was a joke. It sounded serious." >> An exaggerative
dramatic
Perry is. I go into a store. I buy a watch. She's like, "Would
you like a uh would you like to keep the box?" I say, "No." She
says, "Are you sure?"
>> She asked you, "Would you like to keep the box?" What?
>> She brings it up. She brings it up. Well, in the story
the box and then we >> and also
obviously this has been manipulated the story cuz cuz one is
clearly close to the truth cuz Aiden is trying to leave with
the like showpiece watch
and then has had to take that off and then has been given the
the new watch and he's trying to immediately leave without the
box and they're like you you want the box right that's like what's
going on here. It's not they're not like >> do you want
to keep the box as in like oh there's an option here. It's like
they're assuming >> you're like any other normal person
buying a >> watch. Are you walking away? Are you forgetting
the box? >> Are you really walking away without the box
right now? Yeah. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> You couldn't
put a watch on properly.
>> You couldn't put it on properly. You were cutting your
own blood flow. >> Who exaggerates this much? Wait, who
exaggerates this? >> He's okay. He
I don't think Perry's exaggerating the story. Perry is literally
describing what Dickers described pretty accurately. >> I
guess Dickers, according to you, Dickers. So, everybody's just
lying about you all the time. Every single story is a lie. >> Dickers
won't even contest what I've just said. I don't think Dickers
will contest what I just said. And also, >> so you loser
hope of everyone else's wrong. Just prove it then. Prove your
end of the claim, please. >> Wow. So, you're saying, >> "Dude,
this is actually so rough. Having just watched Dickers tell the
watch story and hearing the differences,
>> they should have recorded you without your consent during
the situations. >> You're like, Perry, how dare you take
pre." So, now you want recorded evidence of you being a weird
freak. I thought that was the exact thing you didn't
>> Wait, how is it weird to say I don't want a box?
>> Not taking. >> Do you understand? This is just
like and whining, right? Like nobody cares that I don't want
to take a box for my watch. >> It was your engagement with
the sales assistants which was embarrassing. Which >> how
is that? Wait wait wait. How is that negative engagement? >> How
is that? Well, because after well for according to you afterwards
you say like what a
tell me what I did wrong. Tell me >> what I did wrong.
Well for one you didn't realize that the display watch was not
the watches you're meant to purchase. For two you didn't take
the box. You should take the box. It increases resale value.
It's just, you know, gives you an
>> is the worst person to talk to when you're on the verge
of tears because he will not stop.
>> Yeah. Not just talk to,
>> but um tears just make him go harder. Okay. Something
you should learn about Perry. It's pretty obvious.
>> I'm not reselling it. So, that's a completely irrelevant
Dodgeless point. Uh, which is honestly once again what I expect
of you cuz you're >> It's just fair behavior to go to a
store and not take the [__] packaging of the Do you
like when you're like at a [__] grocery store, do
you open up the granola bars? Oh, I want this granola bar. >> No,
you
>> I feel like it's not that dissimilar, okay, from buying
a phone. Like it feels quite similar to buying a phone to me.
>> a phone or an expensive pair of shoes
>> Sure. Yeah, shoes would be a good one. Well, shoes No,
shoes are a little different cuz usually
swap them. >> Well, yeah. The thing is there are situations
where maybe
>> you're like wearing some your shoes have a hole in you.
You're like, "Do I need to get new shoes?" And you just like
go to the store, buy new shoes, switch them over, throw them
out, throw away the box cuz it's not like a big deal. It's just
like, yeah, maybe it's like $80 pair of shoes or something. >> Yeah.
Yeah. It's like, yeah, it's not a big deal. But let's say you
buy a branded pair of shoes, you're going to want to keep the
box. You You keep the box. You take the box, you keep the box.
>> A phone. >> Yeah. Somebody keep the box. >> Somebody
did say the one decent point is
>> it's not really a decent point, but he's only in what,
the UK for another week or two. Like probably if he's going to
take it back, he's not taking it back to that store or he's probably
not. He's just going to eat the lost probably. So maybe there's
some argument that
the box isn't really like the box is more like a ring box, right?
>> The watch box is like a like leather
>> He's rich. Maybe he's got his own box. >> Yeah,
I somehow doubt that. >> I'm sure he's got like a great
collection of earrings, you know? I'm sure somewhere,
dude. Okay. Why did Dickers have to keep saying he wanted to
go buy like male rings? I feel like at one point he said adult
male rings. I feel like Dickers explicitly led a bunch of people
to think that him and Aiden went shopping for rings
>> like through his language. I actually don't get it,
dude. Adult rings, male >> Gayish as we do, to be fair.
>> That's like so it was so weird. >> You just you
just begged the question. I asked you why is that a problem?
And your response is it's a problem to not take the Do you understand
how stupid it >> So when you go to a grocery store, oh
I need to buy toilet paper, rips open toilet paper, pulls it
out, takes four loose rolls of toilet paper. >> That's
not how you argue. >> So how do you buy stuff? How do you
buy >> Sorry. I think Perry's like doing bad examples intentionally
just to piss them off. I feel like Perry Perry knows how to do
this and just upset people. As if there's one thing Perry can
do, just make everybody angry.
When you purchase Jesus pictures of showing Aiden nude pictures
of Shelbo on stream early to a store, do you like um do you like
wait until you're out of the store to eat >> You wait to
wait out your store to eat. >> Do you um do you just open
up the packaging? Do you open up the cheese and just take a bite
before you go out to to to pay?
>> What? No. No. >> Well, it seem it seems like your
watch behavior. What else? >> No. I wanted to wear a watch
is a vanity. I wanted to wear it out of the store. I had no reason
to keep a box for it cuz I wasn't >> was the uh insulting
the sales assistance of Anthony item. Oh, cuz you're denying
it. You're denying all of the stuff. All the stuff that's Wait,
what was the insult? >> I don't know. Let's pull up the
Let's pull up the clip. Let's pull up the clip from Dickers.
I'll share a screen. I'll share I'll show you what Dickers said
if he's lying. >> I'll share a screen. >> What's
going on there, man? Say it like that. I just said I just made
it up. Watched it. Wait. Wait. We can We can put the >> I
told you what it was. I told you what it was. You don't want
me to show this. You don't want me to show it. You don't want
me to show it. want to be >> 5510 5510 insult. What was
the insult, Perry? What was the insult? >> What was the
insult? The insult that you said Oh, she was like a [__]
>> You already watched this. >> I did. I did watch
it. I did watch it. You wanted exact quotes. Is that what you
want?
>> Is that what you want, man? All right. Well, too bad.
Well, too bad. You leave >> watch. [__] cow.
[__] >> And you say this, you say this. >> Stupid.
Didn't even want me to buy the watch. Cowing.
>> What's going on there? Is she she's supposed to be a
saleserson? She sounds like she didn't want me to [__]
buy the >> What's going on there? >> I didn't say
it like that. I just said I just said all I said was
>> No. No. Once again, all I
>> Oh, I pointed this out multiple times. Queen Bee, that
Aiden's arguing on this story and he doesn't know that Dickers
has already told the story or like he's he he I don't know, man.
He's getting blindsided by the story. >> I think he has
he hasn't seen like how Dick has told it.
Well, you could tell. Yeah. No, no, no. I It was rough when I
watched Dickers tell it and then Dickers like hops on the stream
with him and he's talking like totally normal. And I know that
Aiden's been like crashing out about it for another like 36 hours
since that Dicker stream and they're both just being nice to
each other. I have a feeling Aiden thought Dickers was his guy.
Cuz when Dickers joins that call, he goes, "Dickers, you know
I'm like totally normal, right?" Dickers just finished telling
a story about you being like an antisocial freak on his stream.
And then he's like, "Dickers, you think I'm normal, right?" is
like, "Yeah, your behavior is like >> So, you understand
when you're
like, "You think when you're hearing stories secondhand, you
like drool and take it all as if it's like gospel retelling.
This is exactly
my server.
>> Wait, is that would you call that a secondhand account?
It's like firsthand testimony, right? Like the person was
like you who doesn't talk Queen. Running from Queenman. Running
for Queenman. Running for Queenman. >> Well, how am I running
from Queen? >> I told I'm telling you. You don't listen.
I'm telling you. You need to call. He wants to call in. >> You
just interrupted because you you just like got exposed being
a which is like honestly really [__] bad. >> Insane
how you're running. Insane how you're running, man. Insane.
>> Hey, who wants to call in? Do you want to do you want
to talk to him? All right. Well, join my server. I'll bring him
in.
How is Aiden like this?
Aiden's like a little puppet. I feel like like Perry just knows
that he can go, "Oh, are you running from Queenman?" And even
though Aiden doesn't want to talk to you,
he will stay. Now that the running accusations been dropped,
he will stay. >> Funny coverage. DHX for entertaining
>> Yeah, no problem. Thanks for the thousand kicks, Knox.
Appreciate it, dude. Thank you. Thank you. >> Go on.
>> He has to come in and save you because you're so incompetent.
>> I guess so, man. I guess so. You're running now. You
are running. Now you are running. Now you are running. Now you
are running. Useless incompetent [__] argue. Like
you can't argue for Robert the exact quotes. Give me the quote
I remembered. Give me the quote I >> You give me the quote
I remembered that you just deny existing. That quote that I got
verbatim that quote. So you're not going to join. You're not
>> I'm telling you. I'm telling you that it wasn't said
like that. And and you said
>> Wait. I do get the feeling it wasn't said like that.
Like Dickers was playing it up but the joke wasn't sorry. The
context around that is Dicker saying you were being weird and
then you started this person. So when he delivers it like with
a joking, you know, tone to it, that's him playing it up for
his stream. But I think he made it clear through the story. I
felt that he made it clear that you really were actually this
woman
that you had [__] up in the store and that you were
on the way out. That's how it looked to me.
>> I think the point the point isn't necessarily that that
Aiden was going like super crazy about her. He was obviously
being and then and then she talked and so just playing up >> the
tone. >> Yeah, I do think he probably said something like
cow stupid [__] or >> I don't know how serious
Aiden would have been about that. >> So, but you said that
I got the quotes
effect. You just clearly can't look at or listen to something
and apply context and actually interpret it correctly and realize,
hey, this is a secondhand
>> Be charitable to me. Perry, be charitable to me. Perry,
assume that I was awesome. Actually, Perry, assume I was awesome
during >> stupid to figure that out.
actually, I was awesome. You don't understand. You have to understand.
You don't understand. I was awesome the whole time. You just
forgot that part. >> Food is really good. My mom says that
there's more. >> No engagements. No engagements. No engagements.
Running for queen. No engagements. Running for queen. No engagements.
That's all I have to say. >> You look disgusting and you're
>> insane. Literally, whenever I say, "Hey, you know wants
to call in." What does he say? Oh, you're fat. Awesome, man.
>> He can. We He >> He Well, then join the live channel.
Join the I can't ask him cuz we're not friends on Discord. Uh,
join the live channel. Join the live channel. >> Dude,
why why aren't you friends with Perry? What the Am I not friends
with
>> Apparently, you're not friends with Perry. He can't
even add you to the call. trying to add you to this call. He
can't add you. He's >> Am I really not friends with this
guy? >> That's [__]
>> Oh, no. I'm not. I'll send a friend request. I just
sent him a friend request. There we go. >> Awesome. There
we go. >> I don't know, man. Go on. >> Hold. I'm
looking for your
>> You don't You didn't give me access to the live. You're
so >> Go to the waiting room. Go to the waiting room. Why
didn't you go to the waiting room? Go to the waiting room. Oh
god. Okay.
Do something right. Uh-huh.
Go on. There we go.
You was in the middle of something. Okay. Jeez.
Aiden, you meant to take the box. >> You aware of this?
>> That's a he walk away. Joined and walked
>> Is this a dominance move? Perry was just being rude
to him, so he like joined the channel and walked away to go get
a drink cuz he's the one in control >> of his mic in the
waiting room.
>> Oh, too bad.
>> Skip forward.
There we go. >> So, Aiden, >> test test.
>> The box is part of the purchase. You know, the the box
really is kind of part of the purchase. >> It could be
depending on whether or not you value the box. I didn't need
it. >> No, the box is part of the purchase. And it's not
just that you don't value the box. based on your demeanor. According
to Dicker's story and just the general attitude you seem to have,
it doesn't come off like you're, oh, you're just so ascended,
you're above having the box. It comes off like you're child that
doesn't understand the significance of the box and is being a
ghost.
>> When you stub your >> When you stub your toe,
do you? I had an appendage of my body violently bent. >> Can't
engage. Can't engage. >> I don't own the box. Thank you.
I don't own the box. Thank you. >> And that's like literally
that's the end of it. Nobody like if this is interesting to you
that is like the most >> coping out. Why are we talking
about this? Why are we talking about this? >> Aiden. Charlotte
Perry. Phil Perry. So Aiden, the reason it's interesting is cuz
it's watching someone try and perform like a like an adult or
like a like a rich adult and coming off like a [__]
child. Wait, why why do you think it's a performance to buy something?
>> Because you described the story in a in a way that made
it clear it was a performance where you're walking around the
shop like holding your card out and [__] and doing
like right in the middle of the story.
>> So someone is just like lying then. I w I was [__]
tired and sick. I wanted a watch. I just walked in and bought
it. There was no perform like Sorry. >> I don't understand
why every detail needs to be exaggerated and lied about to like
>> try to like make me look like somehow embarrassing.
I just went in and bought a watch and didn't want the box. >> Aiden,
one second. This is very important. I see someone in chat saying
Milkman Dan is a good chatter. So, Aiden, Milkman Dan is the
one guy in chat defending you right now. You know who this guy
is, right?
>> I don't care. You know, you know this guy is like hell
on steroids that this guy has literally no understanding of when
to talk and when not to talk. He joins Discord VCs with nothing
going on in his life and just talks and talks and talks and talks.
Can you focus on
I have an honest question. Why do people
to go after this guy's throat or what? For no reason. Just like
oh this loser. Yeah, this loser in particular.
Uh yeah,
that seems kind of >> a lie and over like like let's just
get let's just get into the reality of it. I called the woman
annoying after meeting her IRL on Discord. I didn't want to cancel
a reservation knowing that I'd have to pay for it when asked
to change it 15 minutes in advance. And I picked a restaurant
that might not have been so great. I didn't dance and wasn't
like uh wasn't like maybe as social as I should have been or
energetic as I should have been. And I was in my hotel a lot
when I was sick. and I walked in to a store, literally just bought
a watch. Uh, didn't want the >> uh I was gonna say the
other way Aiden could get out of this is he could just say like
he's like anxiety traveling being away from home, but I think
he doesn't want to lean into any like neuronypical
non-neurotypical
behaviors or anything like that.
Like that would almost make sense to me. Like me personally before
I travel I like I sometimes can't pack. I get like super bad
traveling anxiety. Once I'm there, it's all good. But like I
I've felt that. So I don't know. I assume other people have the
opposite where they like once they get there, they feel like
super anxious about
if he if he just said he had something like that that would make
some of his behavior make sense, too. Like he doesn't want to
go out and do
obviously something you have to get over then though. It's not
like cool.
Kind of cuts against the whole thing of him trying to frame himself
as super cool the whole time. >> Box and left. You need
to emphasize all of this for dramatic
pathetic attempt to find some excuse for condemnation or an excuse
to attempt to humiliate me because at the end of the day at the
end of the day at the end of the day all of you are incredibly
embarrassing. Your posture lets me know that you don't [__]
leave your This is like going to London was the first time you've
left your desk in a [__] millennia. Okay, your back
is going to like I'll be surprised you're still walking.
Dude, he's uh he's coming for you. He's coming for you now.
>> You're saying he's lashing out. He's lashing out. >> Wait,
hold on, hold on, hold on,
>> hold on. I got I got a streamer for you. Okay, hold
on. Let me see where can I find this guy's VODs? You have a VOD
playlist. Hold on, hold on. This is literally today topical for
today. >> Got new notebook for New Year's and you're motivating
me to write even more. Also been doing that back on the wall
stretch. Appreciate you in this community, dude. That stretch
has singlehandedly saved me from so many goddamn um tension headaches
so far.
Hold on. Uh back against wall
>> head into the ders. Put them on your chin. Do a slight
chin tuck towards your chest. And now gently press your head
into the door. You're going to >> This is literally to
fix the exact thing by the way. Like I like I swear to God there's
some weird thing going on that I clicked on Bosch's stream to
see this part today and I don't think I watched anything else.
I just clicked on it because I was like, "Oh, what's going on?"
And it was this.
You really did. That's I told my stream today. I'm like, "Dude,
I watch Vos's political opinion. Throw that in the trash." I
tune into Vosch for fashion advice and health advice. Health,
lifestyle advice, and fashion advice. That's what I listen to
Bosch for, okay? How to look awesome, how to be awesome, how
to feel awesome. And then politics is like, eh,
whatever.
This guy does politics. I thought he was a fashion streamer.
>> By the time he turned 50, you're a [__]
hunchback freak. Okay. Half my [__] size, loser.
>> Perry, don't. >> Dude, he's like, dude, again,
he's just like
he is fighting for his life right
>> It's crazy, man. It's crazy.
Yeah. It's like, dude, literally you're I mean, people are just
like, "Go out. Come out. Let's go do >> That's like half
of the reason people are talking [__] Like, let's
go out and actually have fun instead of you being a miserable
miserable prick."
>> Just come out. Let's have fun.
>> All we can get is push. He's like, "Your posture is
bad. You win." >> Pusher doesn't seem that good either.
He's like very lanky. Guys, don't talk. That's the only >> That's
what you're saying about the watch. You're saying that about
the watch to be the most
woman. The most don't talk about how I ravioli
>> Don't talk about the wine. That's buying a watch to
find some like I bought a watch and didn't want the box. You
like think that's a story worth the sales
>> When did that happen? Dicker's Ethan Dicker's dramatic
retelling was >> Do you do you deny >> referring
to a conversation that happened when we were on another street?
That was after the purchase. >> No, with the uh display
stuff.
>> With what display? >> You didn't realize you're
not supposed to take the display watch? I think that's pretty
uh embarrassing. No, >> no, she had me try on the display
watch >> and then you forgot to take it off. You just put
it in your pockets like you were trying to mug them. I didn't
I was not trying to put it in my That's another lie. Can you
just like not lie? Is it like really that hard to just not lie?
Not be dramatic. Not be a dramatic. >> Well, it is just
you know if you're going to deny every single detail every single
person except you says I guess it's all going to be lies. >> No,
no, it's not every there was one other person there and that
person anyone could tell was obviously and I have no issue with
him doing it but he's obviously just like emphasizing certain
parts for dramatic effect.
I mean, he did the exact thing that you were spuring at Perry
for doing. Like, literally the exact thing Perry was doing. That's
what Dickers did one to one. And then he goes, I have but I have
no problem with him doing it. Okay. Kind of weird. >> Like
then that's fine. Most people know not to like most people can
look and not and not take that automatically. >> Need the
box. I don't need the box.
>> Yeah, I don't need the box.
Like you got >> riveting stuff, man. Riveting stuff. I
don't want to buy >> Aiden. There are two like
you ever heard that thing about how it's like you need to like
be able to understand why something is there to get rid of it.
>> Chesterton's fence. That's what you
>> Queenman and Perry, both avid counterpoints viewers.
You love to see >> It's all like that. And you come off
like someone who is just throwing away a fence like a [__]
[__] I didn't know what the fence does. They just
uh Oh my god. Does Jtock know about the Jack and Jones?
No. And to be honest, he's going to get food. So, I'll just say
I'm not I'm not here to listen to Queenman's like neoight fashion
takes. Okay. Not interested. All right. I understand that Jackie
Jones is probably something like an American Eagle, a Banana
Republic, one of these like fast fashion places, right? That's
got to be what Jack and Jones is. That's what I assume. That's
what I infer from context. But maybe not. Maybe it's something
else. It's >> like the defense. I need the fence.
>> And everyone can see that if if you if you were coming
off more like you, you understood the box. Had an appreciation
for why the box was there.
You know, it seemed like
it's like, "Oh, well, I don't need the box cuz I've already got
I've got a watch stand. I've got a watch stand and and a watch
cleaning kit." What is a what? Who gives a [__] Nobody
cares. >> What is a watch stand? What is a watch >> I'm
sorry. This is just like B. Nobody cares. Okay, so this is the
point, right? So, you don't know why the box is there. Like you're
you're going to just like have your watch laying around looking
[__]
>> You're going to just be you're going to be throwing
it. You're going to be getting it scratched. >> Stuck under
the cupboards, stuck under the pillows. >> Aiden, it's
not about being gay or straight. It's about looking after nice
things you have. Notice how I didn't say
>> Well, you can call looking after yourself gay, Aiden,
but you wouldn't spend the money on a watch. >> You literally
had lint on your shirt. >> You had lint on your shirt.
>> it would be sort of like if Queen >> Never mind.
Queen lost. It's over. He got him. A full Aiden. Total Aiden
victory. Aiden, you uh you had lint on your shirt. Actually,
you
did. You You're trying to give me fashion advice. You had lint
on your shirt.
>> Says, "No, leave the lint there." I actually like lints.
That would be the >> It was like, >> "Oh, Perry with
the big brain." Oh, Aiden should have been [__] talking.
Perry. Perry actually turned his brain on now. >> No, not
really.
Do you need a lint roller? No, I don't need a limp roller. No,
I don't need a limp roller. I actually have a lint roller on
me right
>> Yeah. Did you How would you feel if you didn't have
breakfast this morning, Aiden? Aiden, how would you feel if you
didn't have breakfast this morning? Be
>> Because I know how to take care of myself, unlike you.
>> That's crazy. Let roll as well, Aiden. That's crazy.
>> Well, clear Well, clearly you
I guess. >> Why are you trying to flag from the fact that
you just abandoned the the watch box cuz you were like being
an embarrassing rich kid who was like trying to flex himself.
>> There was no you. No, cuz you're just li Like I don't
know why everything needs to be deceptively exaggerated. I was
like not even consciously think like I was like kind of like
half I was even like when I was at the store and the reason I
didn't didn't immediately take off the display watch was I was
like half zoned out and then she's like uh she's like I'll get
you the I'll get you the actual so I took it off and gave it
to her no problem and then I didn't want the box and I left.
It was a It was a quick interaction, made like a brief joke after,
totally like normal thing that most people wouldn't pay any mind
to. The dickers then in a friendly manner kind of uh told for
dramatic effect on stream and that should be like the end of
the story. Then you have like a estrogen fil coming on being
like um um but but but the
I really don't like
he keeps excusing Dickers telling the story. Dickers leaned into
the story, was leaning into it in in the spirit of like making
fun of Aiden for being an antisocial freak.
I I don't understand. Like, you could say that's not true. That's
all wrong. But I don't understand how he keeps going, "Oh, but
Dickers is I have no problem with Dickers. I have no problem
with Dickers."
Yeah. This is This is literally what it is. It's like It's like
just took half of your troops from Italy and Mussolini is like,
"I have no problem with I know you like everybody encroaching
on all sides. I have no problem with Hitler, your only ally.
I have no problem. >> Box, but the box. But the >> That's
probably not a great analogy, but you guys get it. Okay. When
your allies are thin on the ground, sometimes you just got to
support your allies. >> Like, who cares, dude? Nobody gives
a
>> decided to mock you for being a MHL child. You don't
want to stop by the people aren't allowed to make fun of you
in your world. >> It's like embarrassing to No, no. It's
more embarrassing to like you're not the like I don't I don't
think people realize this. You desperately want me to be the
one that is the one being mocked. Okay. You desperately want
me in that position. So you will try to find every story of me
existing
coming out where he feels because you're mad. You're mad that
you every
day. He's taking it. He's taking it personally. He's
>> chill today. >> I thought came in and said we
we need to chill on Aiden. thought he was like, "Oh, I'm genuinely
concerned for Aiden." But what he meant is, "I'm actually just,
you know, going to do a whole bit where I think Aiden's going
to a school if we don't lay up off of him. So, lay off Aiden,
guys, or he's going to kill a bunch of kids." I didn't realize
that was the the tone of lay off Aiden. Okay. I thought he was
like, "Oh, I'm worried this guy's going to have some problems."
But he's like, "No, I just wait until he goes back to the States,
okay? We don't want any British children harmed." >> I
just don't see it personally. Aiden, >> he's he's getting
flashbacks to being a kid again. >> Yeah. It's like the
Keemstar group chats where they all just chat. >> I don't
>> No one should feel like you're back with Nick and Okay.
No one's put you through that, bro. No one wants me to feel that
>> Just cuz they made fun,
>> Yeah. Yeah. This is a part of the conversation last
night. I was talking off stream. I'm like, dude, I know it's
like incredibly serious or incredibly paint by number psychology,
but he's just he wants to make Hellbent like who he was when
he was um when he was a kid with those people. You don't want
to risk ever being that person. >> Fun of you and you were
the butt of a joke. Doesn't mean that we're always going to do
this. It's just sometimes we're going to make >> it is
like the exact thing everybody can point to though. It's like
very obvious paint by number stuff. But unfortunately he just
kind of leans into it and validates it every
fun of other people. >> No, there's not. No, no, there's
not. Sometimes it's that I think you're a ridiculously
embarrassing person and you try to feel better about yourself
by trying to exaggerate everyone.
No, no one should feel this way. Come on. No, we can still hang
out, Aiden. It's not about It's like >> It's not the end
of the world. >> Are you normal, >> dude? I didn't
I didn't pause there. That That was a full Like that 5 seconds
of silence was real. >> Are you normal weight now? You've
had months, by the way. I just want to make
>> You got me, man.
>> No, that's not a got you. That was a question. I'd appreciate
it if you could answer it. You You debate people all the time
and you >> If you don't want me to bring up the watch stuff,
if you don't want me to bring up the watch stuff anymore, >> answer
my question. Have you stuff anymore? And if so, how much?
>> I won't listen. I also bring up the Malta stuff too.
Like I it's I understand that you were upset about
>> and I explained to you in private how I understood but
>> notice how the question notice how he's >> Ever
since you told me I I still bring it up >> running since
I've seen him in Malta.
>> Hope you appreciate that I've like tried to stray away
from that stuff. And similarly, if this new stuff is just as
annoying, I'll refrain from talking >> appreciate it. I
don't appreciate it. I don't appreciate it. I don't appreciate
you. I don't appreciate you. Okay. >> Why not?
>> Because I know what you're doing. I know what you're
doing. >> Trying to compromise with you, man. >> No.
You've been participating in this like cry. [snorts] Like you've
been enabling this like essentially crying. This harassment campaign.
>> No. No. A whining. No. No. A whining campaign. You called
someone annoying. as if like we're this isn't this is not like
the same [__] I'm sorry dude it's JUST LIKE WELL
HE ALMOST GOT IT. It is like the same thing. It is like the same
thing that you decided to go vent about hellbent and they're
doing a little bit of the same thing back to you and it's really
frustrating. It makes you feel like
Oh, he's right there. He's literally right there.
So close. You're doing the same thing. >> A whining. No.
No. A whining campaign. You called someone annoying. As if like
we're this isn't this is not like the same. I'm sorry,
>> dude. He had to catch himself. As if this is not the
same.
It's just like it's what's making me angry is that nobody can
realize
how stupid it is that this community cares that I called [snorts]
someone annoying or thinks it's worth paying mine to that I didn't
want to dance to some stupid music. This is This is Photosh
What What am I saying right now? That is like That is like uh
embarrassing or
>> Oh, your job involves people being interested in It's
not like it's particularly embarrassing as it's outside the total
possible behavior that someone would expect from you, but it's
it's amusing and people watch you a lot anyway because they find
you amusing and so they want to hear
>> details about your amusing interactions as well. But
people watch me and they watch you and they watch Perry and then
they're very interested when all of those come together and have
interactions together. So that >> why are we acting like
it wasn't cool to watch sometimes like random creators who you'd
never seen interact before go to like TwitchCon and like actually
hang out and try to be normal people.
Normal person challenge. It's always interesting.
It's not always content. It's not always really funny, but it's
always it's always like, "Oh, I'm interested in that." Do you
remember? We'd never have gotten Chud totally tearing into Will
and his channel, kicking him out of a Airbnb if it wasn't for
streamers meet up in real life trying to pretend they could be
normal, >> right? really interested in that, Aiden?
>> Yeah. Well, I'm not interested in and I'm not interested
in existing so that I could so that people can uh so that I could
I could be
essentially the the butt of everyone's >> Aiden isn't interested
in that content though, so he doesn't get it. I'll I'll try to
figure think of an example where Destiny's involved so he could
get it. >> what is it? Humor, I guess. That's what I'm
saying. I don't want you to feel like you're back in back in
the RFC community. I want it to feel like you're back in back
in, >> dude. Uh, that's evil. That's pretty evil, too.
This is like This is This is just a more advanced and more version
of
You sound kind of mad right now. This is just a far more version
of it. Okay. You sound kind of You're Are you Are you upset?
You sound kind of mad. I don't want to put you back in that community
where you were like mocked and derided, Aiden. I don't want to
do that to you. What did Augie do to him? Genuine question. He
was just like a cringe squeaker kid who was like 12 when they
were all like 17. So he just got bullied cuz he was just this
cringe squeaker >> No, been abused by Nicki. Okay, good.
Good get on by. >> It wasn't Nickogi. It was his m middle
school or high school friends. He said that uh he had to like
burn the bridge with
and it's listen I mean if that's how you feel Aiden I I don't
think it's particularly fair because obviously
>> Helvin feels like she's back in school being bullied
as well >> cuz I called her
you is quite hypocritical to be >> you have permission
to call me annoying but no it's not hypocritical cuz I don't
I haven't exaggerated I haven't had to blatantly exaggerate like
normal behavior that hellbent has done like like
quite frankly
>> actually that is a totally
legitimate stand behind it. Not even joking allegation from Queenman
and Dickers both was, yeah, when we watch Hellbent do this, we
just go like classic Hellbent.
Goofy ass Elbent. Okay, Elbent. Oh my god, that's like
that's what Queen and Dickers both said. And Soul Sci seemed
to not mind Hellbent either. Obviously, Hellbent helped him out
a lot, so he's probably going to be biased, but seemed like everybody
else was like, "Oh, Hellbent's trying to tell jokes and be funny,
but she's not. It's kind of cringe." And you just go, "Huh, classic
Hellbent." But you're like, "This is the worst person." You go
and see them in Discord chat about it. It's just a little goofy,
man. >> Me not wanting to dance is not that like weird
for like uh for like somebody that is like online generally like
introverted and like a
setting. >> She deserves it. She deserves it. Okay. No,
she pulled up the couch cushion. She pulled them up one by one.
Violated her >> If Helen No, I No, I wasn't. I don't think
there was a serious complaint about that. You're complaining
that I brought that up. Like the complaint is on your end, not
mine. Like, you're the one like I hope you realize that you're
the one. >> No, I understand. Uh we can make fun of people
except Dayton. No, I I got it now. I figured it out.
just like once again uh doing like a ironic like
that [laughter] is your conclusion. >> Hold on. Sorry,
not to sorry. This just popped up on my feed here.
I I may or may not have been uh doing something, bro. Did she
get like punched in the face? What the [__]
Sorry, this popped up on my feed and I'm just like, what? I think
it's a joke,
>> I tried. I tried so hard. I tried so hard. Oh, it's
going to be about her getting It's going to be some thing >> to
get and my pimp. He just like, you know, I love my job. Was that
too morbid of a joke? Was that a little too morbid?
Was that a little too morbid for you guys?
[laughter] Cuz right after I started saying it, I was like, maybe,
maybe, maybe,
>> dude. Okay. All right. All right. What? >> Sorry,
I saw that on the side. I had to check that out real quick.
So true. Take end. So true. This is exactly how I feel.
>> You can't make fun of me. It's not interesting. It's
>> So what exactly did So what exactly happened? She probably
got slapped by a dude. Okay.
>> Telling you. She probably actually she's just like >> interesting
to make fun of other people like Kelvin. [__] that
I've actually >> You're making fun of me if I if I laughing
exaggerating
story, which is something you've already done because you know,
you know that if you weren't exaggerating, so like you know it
would be totally uninteresting to the general public and also
um you would know that in comparison to me, you look ridiculous
be mostly because your disgusting malformed body. I really hate
Btuber and presumed fat until proven otherwise. Aiden getting
on a massive high horse about his looks in a totally unearned
fashion. Okay. Like
this has been a joke. The Hania thing's a joke, but it's not
that far off. Okay. I don't know who's been gassing you up. You
won too many group chats with your mom, I think. Okay. This is
like too much. You cannot try to mob people on on your looks.
You're not looks maxing. That's not what's happening here. Okay.
You're like at best the third best looking person in this photo.
At best. I You got to chill the out. Okay. You might get saved.
Is he at least 6 feet
Maybe he's like 6'2 or something. Maybe.
But like other than that, I don't even Who's the fourth? No comment.
It actually changes based on preference. It's just Aiden is consistently
three or four. Aiden is 61 or 62. Okay, so he's got the height
going for him, but that's it.
That's literally it.
Which, by the way, the height will fail for you if you are sufficiently
insecure, which he clearly is.
Okay?
If you're insecure enough, you will get because of the height
will not help you. The height is supposed to look like confidence.
It's supposed to like mimic confidence. Women see the height
and they're like, "That's a confident guy."
If you're if you're you're self-conscious, if you're a little
too not confident, it's it's too much, man.
You need you need the self-confidence with it that comes with
it should be built in. It's genetic, man. Anyway anyway
knowledge to to understand like why it's funny. It's like it
is like hearing a curb your enthusiasm episode. hearing someone
go in, try and buy the showpiece watch, refuse the box, be angry
with the customer service over then thinking
>> Yeah, but if you understand that that's not actually
what happened. If you understand that's not actually what happened,
then we're the problem is that's actually how it went down. >> Make
a mess. The bread.
>> there was no m you ravioli. >> Oh, I got to I
do have to I do have to ask about this dinner. Okay.
Wait, are you back yet? Eat your food. >> Yeah, I'm in
here the minute. Yeah. >> Okay. Um,
was that the point at which you decided to ruin Aiden's entire
life was like basically when he's sawing this bread, he's rocking
the table and he like spills your wine on the table. You're like,
"Okay, [__] this guy. >> Blow up this guy's
whole world right
>> I started talking about what a weird freak this guy
is to everyone.
>> No. No. I I figured that was the moment was he was like
rocking the table at this Italian place that you didn't want
to be at. You just wanted curry. Okay. The real reason
immigration, by the way, >> he wanted to go to a curry
house. Okay. He wants the curry to [laughter] be >> I think
I think it's I thought it was all funny. I think I think being
around with Aiden when he's being like super antisocial and like
even when he's being like, you know, a complete it's funny, you
know. I find I find humor in there. Same reason I agree with
them that hellbent can be kind of a annoying but like why is
that ruining your [__] day you know? Why is that
not just funny to you?
>> That much can certainly be funny. People's quirks are
funny.
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, that's fair. >> You held the lo.
You were literally arguing with the waitress to keep you ate
two loaves of by yourself at the >> and you dropped the
ravioli.
>> See, but it's okay for you to make fun of me. But I've
learned that we can't make fun of you. That's That's the >> No,
but I'm not exaggerating.
>> All right, I got to hear Perry tell this ravioli story.
Okay, whatever the [__] this is. He just keeps referencing
the ravioli over and over again. >> You need to watch a
couple of the stories of from Mort if you haven't seen them.
They are so funny, man.
>> He just keeps going over how this guy ate ravioli. Dude,
he must have been a disaster with that ravioli. >> I don't
need to exaggerate. I I had a brief interaction. The woman doesn't
probably doesn't even remember it. I just said, "I don't want
the box." If you're working in retail, do you >> Oh, oh,
Hellbent in the VC.
Does Hellbent not understand that the reason she's currently
winning in this drama is cuz she hasn't gone on a VC to talk
about? >> Yeah, I think I leave here cuz I'm just like
I'm I'm having my performance drag down. [laughter] >> Yes,
dude. It's like you the critically important is that you do not
participate. Hellbent. No. Hellbent. NO. WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
YEAH. OKAY. All right. Um, if somebody wants to find that time
stamp, I'll watch the ravioli story. If somebody could find it
>> that somebody doesn't want a box
>> like days like a day later. >> The assistant.
Well, no, but if you're like friends with >> It's a watch.
Yes. If it's a watch. Yeah. You You'll be like that. >> If
you're buying like a if you're if you're buying like a Rolex,
sure.
>> I So I said this to her earlier, Snick. She was in the
chat and I'm like, you have like a pathology. You have like a
a real problem. this will ruin your life if you keep doing it.
You should treat the people who are nice to you nicely and the
people who are to you, you shouldn't have an extra need to treat
treat them nicely. You should walk away from those people. Do
not like find people who hate you and then make your life about
pleasing them. That is the perfect way to be miserable. That
is the perfect like you're the perfect abused woman in that case.
Okay? Just don't do that. Find the people who are kind to you
and then hang out with those people.
any watch is like such a customary
thing of a watch. You get the box, you keep it in the box. It's
like with rings, dude. >> It's like buying toilet paper.
>> We were out walking out. Why would I want to carry a
box in a bag, bro? It's like a It's like a 6 in box. It's like
going out shopping. It wasn't spread.
>> Aiden definitely got a satchel, right? I feel like Aiden's
definitely got like a satchel. So, he's got like some >> He
wasn't using a satchel when I saw him. I didn't I didn't see
him wearing a satchel at all. >> He wasn't I feel like
he owns one. I feel like
carry a bag like
>> just get a backpack. Just be a guy. Get a backpack.
>> You know, you know >> that wasn't that was the
plan. You didn't think you'd have bags or boxes?
>> No. I'd be wearing the the watch because that's that's
what you do with a watch.
Wait, Perry, do you think like a watch?
Where do you >> You went out shopping. You went out shopping
and you didn't Oh, I can't carry anything. >> You know
where Perry Perry, >> do you wear the clothes you buy at
the at the clothes store? Like you go buy shirts, you have to
like throw away your clothes you came in with.
>> Well, no, but that that's obviously that because that
article of clothing that article first of all uh get like dyes
and like and like >> Isn't that perfect? He He had been
Wait, wait, wait. He had been to a clothes shop that day. He
must have been carrying Shut the [__] up. That's
what I was saying. No, but he I don't think he found anything,
but he planned to he planned to be carrying. >> Oh, no.
He He was going to say jeans. He did. He bought stuff. He bought
stuff. >> Oh, he did buy stuff. Okay. Yeah, >> he
went to Jack Jones.
>> Okay, that's okay. There you go. Cuz I was like, somebody
told a story about him looking for Levis's or something,
>> Yeah. He was looking for Levis's in this department
store and I guess they decided it was too expensive or some [__]
Both our shorts get both stories in this one.
>> This Aiden guy, he was eating the ravioli in the strangest
way. So he takes the ravioli and you know he he balances it on
the fork likeoo.
And it's like it falls off. It's it actually falls off, guys.
It like he has the ravioli balanced on like a bloop. It like
falls off into the plates. He doesn't just pierce the ravioli.
Well, sometimes he did, but one of them did he just balanced
it on his fork like like he's doing a what the is your [__]
glob glob glob. But he he was it fell off. I'm telling you guys,
it fell off. I was like I was looking I was I was trying to fix
like what the is this guy
>> Perry is kind of an artist with the paint thing. Okay.
He just makes it work somehow. This is like his thing. He makes
it work each time. >> This guy is like
he's like playing with his food, I guess. I don't know. I don't
think he's playing. He just grabbed it like it was a spoon. He
grabs the ravioli like But sometimes he does I don't even know
why he did it. It's not like he does this with every ravioli,
right guys? Some of them he he's like balancing all
Oh no. And so he just like pierces like a normal human being.
I don't get it. I didn't get it. I was watching I was transfixed
with this guy.
Okay. That was worth whatever 30 seconds, 60 seconds.
This is another one. This guy is like B. >> This is This
is the very This is the very long version. Hold on. There's like
another short version that I'm going to grab. I could probably
watch this at another time.
Might just watch it off stream. We'll see. Here's the bread one.
When the second ricketon dish came, Aiden wanted to dip the bread
in the rickoni, but she took the first bread dish. Not I assuming
it was the bread was basically like leftover and untouched, right?
So I see them and say, "Hey, no, could you leave the bread there?"
You like, "Leave the bread there." And they go like, "What? I
said no like the bread, you know, we're going I was going to
the bread. Can you like leave it? So they go like, "Oh, don't
worry. I'll get you some more bread." It's like, "No, take like
I have to ask like three times." I'm serious. I have to ask like
three times. Leave the bread that you're holding on the table.
Take the bread. Why didn't you say we were still eating that?
Do I have to What What these else am I telling them to leave
the bread there for? And it's like they leave the bread there.
There's like an awkward tension. I don't even remember it exactly.
It was a very awkward tension though. They leave the bread there
and it's like I I try and like smooth things over. I said, "Oh,
you know, I just really like that bread." I I get Dude, the repetition
is very very funny to me as well. I was like, "Just leave the
bread." No, I was like, "Just leave the bread there. Just leave
the bread there." How many times do I have to say just leave
the bread there? I don't know, man. >> I It's like my pet.
I gave it a name or some [__] like that, right? And
they go like, "What?" >> That's that's every story, by
the way.
>> And I like I repeat myself. Oh, you know, I just like
this is like nice looking bread. I wanted to keep the bread.
And he go, "Huh?" And it's like, "Do you want me to [__]
repeat this again?" I asked three times.
>> He wanted to repeat it again. >> For you to leave
the bread and you're such a
undomemesticated
brain dead Italian that you had I thought three times for you
to leave the bread there. And now that there was like a bit of
tension, you're looking at me like, "Huh?" Like I'm the reason
for wanting the bread that I ordered when the second ricaton
dish >> Wow. Wow. That could be that could be funny. Oh,
I just closed the Hellbent >> What do you want to debate?
I'm way out. Hold on. Let me go to wherever Hellbent hops on.
Helmet hops on. Queen wasn't gone quite yet.
Straight >> uh and where uh wearing it. >> No, you
can just wear your clothes over. >> Wait, wait, shut the
[__] up. So, Aiden, what are you going to do? >> So,
that was that was an in comparison from Just to be clear. >> Aiden,
what are you going to do with this watch when you're not wearing
it? I'm I will always be wearing it. You're always going to >> Dude,
8 in one. A in one. I'll literally never take it off. It will
be on my wrist forever.
I will never be without it. Dude, is this is this not like a
some kind of mechanical watch? Some sort of like entry level
crystal watch that
you wouldn't want to take and put in like the bath or something.
I assume that's the kind of watch it was. He didn't just get
like a diving watch, right? like a proof up to 100 meters diving
watch.
I'm guessing >> no wear the watch. I'm never going to take
the watch off. It's waterproof.
>> Well, I mean I don't know.
Why would I take it off? >> You can take it off to clean
it.
>> I guess I'd take it off to clean it.
>> Show it. That's going to clean it.
what if you get another watch and there are times where you want
to wear one
>> versus the other watch. >> I'm not going to get
another watch. I don't need two watches.
>> Wait, you might not. You really don't think you'll ever
be at a point in your life where you're like, you know what,
this watch doesn't fit this outfit very well. Maybe I'll get
a different watch. >> I mean, maybe it's not like a
Yeah, >> I'll be real. If you're not a watch guy, this
is the watch he got. If you're not like a watch guy, if you don't
already know you're a watch guy,
would this really be the first watch you buy? Why wouldn't you
just get an iPhone? Sorry, uh, Apple Watch
that like synchronizes with all your devices and
like I have an Apple Watch. I'm not really a watch wearer, but
if you're going to wear a watch, why wouldn't you just get like
a Apple Watch? Why would you get this?
Like I I would get it, but I don't think I would buy a watch
unless it was for an event or for an outfit.
Like that is what I would buy a watch for, right?
Literally, I'm going to get like a suit. I'm going to get a nice
watch that goes with that suit like as an accessory.
I'm going to get I'm going to like some event, some big event.
Uh maybe like a very close friend's wedding. Maybe
I don't know, maybe I'm speaking at like a conference or something.
Then I might get like a nice watch, but it would go with like
an outfit. It would be a whole
I don't know. Yeah, this doesn't feel like
I don't know. Yeah, I just don't know
that. That would have been the question. Hold on. That's a nice
dress watch. Kind of an annoying day day watch. Somebody should
have asked him what he wanted to do that. But I guess he said
it's a day-to-day watch now. Somebody should have asked him though.
What do you want to use this watch for? Why did you get this
watch?
Did nobody ask him why he got the watch? What made you want a
watch? Why did you decide to get a watch?
Oh, these would be good questions to
>> It would be. Oh well. >> It was like a $100 watch.
I mean, like that's like not I don't see myself with it in 50
years.
>> Here's the thing is is you're immediately going to say
it's a $100 watch. That that's that's nothing. And that's like
your whole life. >> I'm not saying that's nothing. I'm
saying I'm saying you're treating it all. No. No. It's >> should
have checked the sticky thread at r/watches like Queenman did
at r/ raw
You doing r/male fashion advice now? Spending some time. The
silence says everything we need to hear. Thing is >> in
I can appreciate like I can appreciate that like like I'm not
going to go I'm not getting the watch and then [__]
I don't know
uh chewing on it or whatever, right? But um I I I can also understand
like this is I'm not treating this like it's a [__]
family like heirloom. like I'm going to what about 50 years from
now when I >> It's like it's literally like it is like
the level of putting your video games back in their cases, you
know? It's it's like that that's the level >> it is cool
to take care of your stuff. I say that as somebody who probably
has pretty significant issues, not unlike Aiden being brought
up like um I wouldn't say I was like brought up affluent, but
I was definitely brought up in a way where I didn't really um
I [clears throat] didn't like I wasn't super concerned about
my things. It's like cool to care about stuff. It's cool to take
care of your [__] It's cool and you shouldn't let
other people convince you it's not cool. Okay. It's always cool
to have stuff that you need to maintain a little bit. You need
to put some work into. That's awesome. >> We're at here
is like you've gone you've gone and bought a new game and you're
like, "No, I don't need the I don't need the case." And and you've
thrown your Xbox 360 case on the floor as you're leaving a shop.
>> It's his money. Well, his parents money. He can do whatever
he wants with it. If he needs a storage box later, he can get
>> Okay. Yeah. Oh, the Russian Janney is here to sweep
it up for Aiden. >> Don't try to defend him just to wait
in favor back. Shut the [__] up. Give her the rest.
>> I hadn't even seen this. And I gave Hellbent a whole
speech about how this was like a stupid thing to do. I didn't
even know she went and did this today.
I gave a whole speech about how this is really never going to
be happy your life if you do [__] like this. A >> CD
case. It would be a CD case. That That would make sense. You
wouldn't want to put an Xbox 360 game in a CD case. >> a
CD case would probably be fine for it.
elements, you want to join. What do you have to say to Aiden?
No, I don't have something goofy.
I was just uh politely waiting for the watch conversation to
seize.
>> I wanted to say I don't have any issue with Aiden calling
me annoying
uh doing my face behind my back, whatever. The only issue I had
was Aiden from what I gather and what I heard blaming me for
quote unquote ruining the trip or ruining something. And as well
as >> I never said that. I never said that. >> Let
her finish, Aiden. Let her finish.
>> As well as blaming me for flaking on Queen as if I'm
somehow package deal with Queenman when I never was going to
join whatever you were guys going to do that afternoon. The same
way I didn't join when you guys went to the museum. Um like you've
had plenty of opportunities to hang out with people without me.
So, um I don't think it was reasonable to
blame my presence for any kind of negative experience that you
had. That that was my problem the whole
>> Hang out with any of these people seems exhausting.
Honestly, you could think all of the Nobody has any problem with
the things they thought, right? You think any of these things.
Hellbent's annoying. Aiden's annoying. You just like don't put
it out publicly unless you want to litigate it like this on
And Aiden was the one who put it out
More than what? >> Did I hit play? No, it didn't hit play.
>> But you can call me whatever you want. I don't have
a problem >> blaming your experience.
>> I need to know if you still have the box to get your
PC out of. Lol. I think you do. Oh, I hoard boxes and stuff for
sure. But um that's cuz I like reselling stuff. Like when I'm
done with the device, I resell it and I resell the original box.
And literally, if you just have the original box, I find people
will
actually pay you a lot more for it.
They think it's like less used if you have the original box for
it. I don't know. That's like me personally. I keep Dude, I
was doing like a cleanup here recently. When I say I, I mean,
yeah, it's fine. Um, but I I wanted to keep all my PC boxes,
all my like laptop. I have like two MacBook Pro boxes or I had
them and they ended up getting put in the recycle.
I just like having the boxes, too. I just like I don't know.
I like the boxes for expensive electronics,
but just expensive electronics. I don't think I keep the boxes
for anything else.
Expensive electronics, man. You keep the boxes for that [__]
>> So, first of all, the first thing that's just made up.
Um, you just made that up. So, uh, you're a liar. I want that
on note. Um, I've never to this day, I would I would love if
somebody could pull up. Exactly. I've never said you ruined my
trip. So, that's just like a complete and total lie. Uh, in regards
to the second part, >> to be fair, Kman, do you remember
telling me that? >> Oh, he left. >> Quan left.
>> well, whoever said that and whoever whoever said that
is a liar and whoever is reiter
I don't even know. Is he here? He wasn't here just a little while
ago.
Did you say this? Did you say hellbent? Aiden said hellbent ruined
the trip. Can we get that on the record? Once again, the silence
speaks volumes. >> Oh, I was listening. I came back just
to address this. Okay. Just I don't believe I don't believe I've
ever
>> You didn't come back for the r/male fashion device stuff.
You're like, "No, that's fairly accurate. I'll let that >> Yeah.
I [laughter] didn't hear that.
>> Okay. All right. Fair enough.
>> Should like I don't know. Learn to like
>> Soul is saying you said it. So Soul was there. I heard
you say it. Soul's confirming.
Why do people like critically engage with clans? Every claim
needs to be taken like without
>> Oh claim I posted a photo that you posted your >> What
do you mean? What do you mean without scrutiny? What scrutiny
can we
He was there. He says it happened. Apparently multiple people
may have said it happened that you were complaining about this.
Dude, I wish um I do wish someone had recorded the icy chat combo.
I think that would have been good. >> That would have been
quite funny. >> We did do that. Yeah, I was there for >> Wait,
okay, but does he feel like she ruined the trip? [__]
No, I said no. I said no. I didn't say that. Nor have I ever
said that. What is weasly about that? I am stating it directly.
I have
>> So, you are kind of walking people. >> Where did
I say it? >> I already said soul said you said it. Apparently,
said you said it. People are saying you said it.
>> Listen, if he says he didn't say it, he didn't say it.
If you didn't doesn't feel that way, it doesn't feel that way.
I'm happy with that. Obviously, I wish that
um you would, you know, speak to me directly cuz I've I've tried
to get you to, you know, talk to me at least for 10 minutes yesterday,
but um you refused. So, obviously now
this is happening. I don't I don't have any
um ill will towards you, Aiden. Um I think everyone had fun hanging
out. At least that was my experience. Uh it was surprising that
there were uh whatever complaints afterwards, but I have no problem
with you calling me annoying.
Um you can keep doing that. Just do not use me as an excuse for
bailing on people or anything of the sort cuz >> Yeah.
Please don't lie about what I said about you. Um I've never seen
you. I would love if you could uh substantiate that at some point
or uh retract your statement and admit you lied. Um yeah, but
yeah. [snorts]
Uh, in regards to me, >> I feel like Aiden Aiden 100% feels
like he won. Like he leaves this and he's like, "Yeah, I won.
I'm that guy." >> Um,
about small things constantly uh from one particular chatter
uh who just uh brought that up. I I talked about this like in
a VC twice uh for like in terms of this community and the times
VC's go that's like actually like a totally normal and appropriate
amount of times to discuss something and the only about the only
way the only way the only way you would interpret uh me bring
up a singular grievance as like an overall uh description of
the trip as a whole. The only way uh you could do that, and that
could be implied, is if you're incompetent and like just don't
know how
>> The only way you could possibly think there's something
wrong with me is if you're a loser and incompetent and worthless
cuz I'm awesome. Thank you. Oh my god, I didn't even think about
that. >> I just like don't know how to heard it's your
first
>> You can either believe
>> I'm sorry
that that right there at the very end of this totally pirate
software coded. I'm sorry, Queenman didn't like that I said that
and put the cursor. That is 100% pirate software coded and I
will not hear any other commentary. Okay,
for to just go like I won completely. The only way you could
think I'm weird is if you're a loser yourself. Like come on,
that's crazy to take it to that extent unless he's playing a
character. The the only option here is the only option that's
not super weird or pirates offer code is if he's like intentionally
playing a character that he could step out of at any moment.
I don't believe that to be the case though. I don't think so,
dude.
>> Five people or Aiden? And I mean, I think the answer's
always. >> Wait, five people. Wait, who are five people?
My bad. Sorry. Three people. Three people. That's what I mean.
>> Dickers. Dickers has because this is bringing up was
made before. Someone said, "Hell did not ruin your whole trip."
And I was like, "Never said that." This was two days ago. And
Dickers himself literally admits that he he did he didn't hear
me say that. So, I don't know who is five people like It's not
just me saying this. Someone else who I've been with more than
the others literally says they never heard me say this. The people
that you're referring to, maybe like Soul, they can't tell you
in what context they ever heard me say this.
Hellbent doesn't even say she heard me say this. She says she
heard someone else tell her I said this. Queen like, so no, you're
actually believing people who won't even like give you the specifics
of their uh when I supposedly said this. And it seems like the
people who are reiterating it are doing this game of telephone
where they all heard it from somebody else. So if you think that
that's a reliable claim, you're a idiot with like no like media
literacy or whatever. Sorry, media literacy. >> Well, you're
in communications. You would know. >> Well, that that's
how you that's how you like I I mean you just would fall for
anything using this logic.
>> Well, no. I mean I I guess fair enough. If you didn't
say it, you didn't say it. I'm glad I guess that you never made
it and seem like Hilbent was the reason you weren't meeting up.
But I'm glad that you didn't go that far.
>> Wait, can this JJK guy call in? He was threatening to
beat me up, but like can you get him to call? >> Yeah,
JJ. Yeah.
>> Aiden totally won. Aiden stands
just like every other avenue, every other place Aiden's been.
Eventually, people get tired of arguing with him and leave and
that makes him the winner by default.
Let's go.
Sorry. Um, it's not that big a deal. I got no problem with Aiden.
He's like eccentric. It's whatever.
I just wish he could like accept an L like on some things. Just
does. It feels weird that he will not take an L on anything.
But whatever. You don't have to. It's fine. You're fine. Everything's
fine. Okay. Okay.
And with that being said, I think I'm gonna go to bed.
Looks like Chud is online doing some just raid this guy, I think.
Go to sleep. All right, we'll talk to you guys later.
Have a good night, everybody. Be back tomorrow. Probably earlier.
Hopefully earlier. Holy sh I'm waking up late in the day, though.
But hopefully earlier. Okay. All right. Have a good night, everybody.
See you later. Bye.